hi everyone welcome to this video
tutorial on python programming full
course by simply learn
python is amongst popular general
purpose programming languages used in
the companies for web development
application development data analytics
and machine learning in this video we
will cover everything you need to know
to become an expert in python
our highly experienced instructor anish
will take us through this course but
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply learn channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn
so we will start by looking at an
introduction to python and understanding
python installation along with its
basics
you will learn the fundamentals of
python programming such as conditional
statements loops object oriented
programming concepts and functions in
python you will also work on a hands-on
project in python
next we will cover some of the crucial
advanced programming concepts such as
iterators modules packages generators
list comprehensions and regular
expressions you will also get an idea
about serialization closers and
decorators finally you will learn about
map filter and reduce functions so over
to anish now hello everyone and welcome
to our course on python programming my
name is anish karan and i will help you
learn the fundamentals of python
programming and what programming in
python really means and what it is all
about
i am sure there are plenty of you over
here that are watching this video that
have their own reasons and multiple
reasons to start learning programming
and programming in python in particular
our goal over the duration of this
course is to ensure that you are able to
learn python and learn python
programming to a level in which you can
tackle whatever problems you have and
whatever projects you set out to do in
the future now i'm sure you must have
heard that the some of the most upcoming
fields and some of the high prospect
domains in the market right now such as
data science ai machine learning require
python programming and our goal in this
course is to get it to a level where you
can start tackling and creating
solutions to whatever problems you may
occur whether it be in your job or in
your studies or anywhere else or any
personal projects that you may
take up in the future now before we
actually get started on the actual
concepts and the fundamentals of python
i want to show you over the next two or
three videos exactly what how python
came to be what was the philosophy
behind creating this language and uh
basically a brief introduction behind
python and python programming so python
programming was developed first by a
person a dutch programmer by the name of
guido van rossum and python was first
released by him in the year 1991 now the
design philosophy behind python was to
create a language which was much easier
to read and much easier to actually code
in compared to the
or in contrast to the languages that
were prevalent back in those days such
as the language c and now formally
python is an interpreted high level
general purpose programming and what
this means is that
python is a it's a language that can be
used for a wide variety of applications
as we will see later
the high level
part of this definition basically tells
us that python is written in a language
that is very abstract at a much higher
abstract level compared to the
instructions that a computer can
actually read so in layman's term you
can say that python is very close to the
actual
language that we humans use and that's
the way python has been designed and the
difference between a high level
programming language and the lower level
programming language is that low level
languages are essentially machine
language instructions that are the
actual instructions that a computer can
actually understand a high level
language like python is something that
we humans understand better and we can
write in it better now the term
interpreted over here essentially means
that we don't need to compile our
instructions that we give in python now
as i mentioned earlier that the
computers or any system that involves
computing needs low level language to be
fed to it so that the computer can
actually understand because computers
cannot understand the way we write our
code and this process of converting from
high level to lower level called
compilation and in most languages such
as c there's a special process involved
called compilation which we do after we
create our blocks of code or scripts or
whatever now when we say python is an
interpreted language what this means is
that we can actually work on python and
see the results right at the get go we
can skip this step of compilation uh
because our system that runs python
actually does all of that conversion
from high level to a low level
language as we type our code and
this actually speeds up the process very
well for us and makes programming in
python
and other interpreted languages as well
much much easier for us python is of
course an open source language it's uh
the most bare implementation of python
known as c python is actually
even currently being maintained by a
foundation known as the software python
software foundation so essentially
python is being maintained developed by
a group of very talented developers and
it's it's open to pretty much anyone to
work with and to create libraries for
this allows python to be an amazing
language in the in the modern world
because in the modern world we have
different issues and different problems
in different spheres and domains that we
we would need
to update our libraries or update our
packages that we use in our programming
language on a very regular basis and so
python being an open source language
allows us to keep updating and keep up
with the times essentially when it comes
to solving problems now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very it's
a very readable program code readability
is very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as i mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
python we since python is open source as
as i already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in python and
we create in a particular system say on
windows
we don't need to make any changes if we
wanted to use the same script or that
same piece of code on some other system
say on a linux system or
a mac system python itself comes with a
very large standard library this this
facilitates us
a lot because we don't need to
create our own libraries or modules or
have to download very specific libraries
most of the problems that we do
encounter
quite commonly can already be solved by
the standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python write right from the beginning
now later later on during the course we
will encounter what is the meaning of a
data structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and
as as you will see later
python has one of the most user friendly
data structures
that can be found in any language
especially compared to some of its
contemporaries now python is a
dynamically programmed language and this
is very important and what this means is
that in most compiler based languages we
there are certain processes that can
only happen during the compilation stage
so
what a dynamic programming language does
is it takes all those
compilation specific
tasks and processes and
it it does it for us as we actually type
the code so we don't need to waste time
or spend extra time to do something that
would otherwise be needed to be only
done in compilation we would have to set
out specific uh runtimes just for that
so this allows us to create our programs
and solutions much faster and allows us
to debug much easier and
yeah so it's a it's it's a very
important feature about python now
quickly i will just go over some of the
areas of python where
like areas of um or different domains
where python is very heavily implemented
and the first one the first few ones
that come to mind are like web
development and
ai and machine learning so you have
technologies like django and flash that
are
built on top of python that
are used extensively for web development
when it comes to something like
artificial intelligence or machine
learning you have
distributions such as anaconda you have
pandas and many other libraries like
scipy and numpy that are used
extensively to so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
use in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays
because of
again some of the libraries that i have
already mentioned such as scipy
interestingly if you are into game
development or gaming in general you
would see that python actually has
certain libraries and certain
technologies that facilitate game
development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop uh be
creating desktop gui's image processing
graphic design applications and uh
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses
there are many technologies
in the environment of python that
were almost designed for the specific
purpose of
being able to present certain concepts
or to be able to
teach certain classes and
i can't think of too many programs or
too many environments outside of python
that are better to solve these education
and training course related
problems and situations so i will show
you how to install python on windows
since i have a windows system uh however
i will also point out uh the way you you
would have to install python on aim on
mac os or linux or even on mobile so uh
yeah let's get started so to install
python on your windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the downloads
section when you do click on downloads
you get redirected to this website that
this webpage that i'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version but of course if
you for whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well
by just scrolling down and choosing the
option that you want now it's important
to note that whatever option you choose
of course i would recommend the latest
one but no matter what option you choose
i would recommend you choose a version
of python three point something because
uh previous versions of python uh namely
python 2.7 and uh and basically every
version of python two point something
has it will not receive any more
maintenance and updates uh because uh
the developers have decided that python
will they are trying to shift towards uh
maintaining and updating python
three-point whatever completely right
now so yeah
let's not delay this uh any further and
let's download python 3.9 so once you
select the option out here you'll be
you'll get an installer all you have to
do is click on that and it'll give you
two options to customize installation or
install now i would of course recommend
this to install now since you're a
beginner do not worry about what a
custom installation is if you have
multiple drives in your system by
default the python will be downloaded
into
the drive where your windows is actually
installed your your main drive so as you
can see now that once my setup is done
it should give me a pop-up soon so my
setup is done for python and this is
essentially how you would um download
python on your windows system
but what if you had mac os or if you
were using linux well for mac it's a
it's actually almost as simple you just
go
if you see out here below this download
button python option you get the website
asking you are you looking for python on
a different os and it gives you the
options of linux mac and even other os's
but for mac if you wanted you would just
open this tab and
just like the windows option you would
choose a version and you would choose an
installer for that version so if i
wanted say python the latest one i would
just download this installer and i would
install in my mac system now when it
comes to linux i cannot show you exactly
how you would install it there are
certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
would just choose the linux option out
here it would take you to a page with
different installers and
essentially packages for linux systems
in specific what i would recommend to
you if you are a linux user and you need
python is to go over to the real
python.com website and
they have a very good uh essentially
instructions on how to install python
and since i don't have a linux system i
cannot directly show you how to install
python on linux so yeah if you do have
linux please head over to this website
and this should be of a lot of help to
you now
as i had mentioned you can actually
install python on your mobile devices as
well so if you were say an ios user you
would go to the ios app store and
download an app called the python is the
app for ios it essentially is like a
full-fledged
python environment where you can develop
in python on your iphone or even ipad
and if you're an android user you could
you would go and download an app called
the pydroid3
there's a free version and a paid
version for this app and of course the
difference between the free and paid is
that the paid supports uh code analysis
and code prediction these are certain
details you don't have to worry about
right now and uh honestly if i wouldn't
uh worry too much about installing
python on your mobile devices currently
since uh i am assuming most people would
be learning programming and programming
in python on their pcs or laptops now
that
we've mentioned how to install python
what i had actually shown you was
installing uh what is called an
implementation of python on your system
an implementation is essentially a
program or a software or an environment
that allows you to actually work in
python so what i showed you was how to
install the by default or the most basic
or reference implementation that has
been created by the developers which is
actually called c python even though you
would not you would not have seen the
word the letter c or the prefix c
but yeah that implementation that i had
i had downloaded myself and i had shown
you to download uh is actually the c
python implementation which is python
built
on top of c the the c language
essentially uh there are other
implementations such as iron python
which uses the.net framework and j
python that uses java virtual machines
that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that i would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python i want to introduce
what is called a distribution to you
this distribution is called anaconda
anaconda is a very important
distribution especially if you are
looking to
use python in data science and machine
learning and ai which i am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards moving
towards data science and if that is your
goal or in any case whatever your goal
may be i would recommend that
you install anaconda distribution now do
not get confused between anaconda and
python their anaconda is python with i
in the form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that i had shown you
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and technologies and softwares
as well so of course this means that
would you need to download both of
course not if you download a python you
do not need anaconda to work on python
and if you have already downloaded
anaconda which i will show you how to do
it in some time if you have already
downloaded anaconda you don't need to
download python separately so i'll just
speak about anaconda a little briefly so
as i said it's a distribution it it it
contains a bundle uh which includes the
basic python implementation and a lot of
technologies and softwares and
applications
that have essentially helped us
to use python in
in in specifically managing their big
data applications and data science
related projects so so now i will show
you actually how to install python i
mean anaconda on your system it's as
simple it was it's actually as simple as
downloading just the this thing so if i
did a quick quick google of anaconda
so the website that i'm looking for is
anaconda.com and i'm looking at products
and i'm looking at individual edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial team edition these are for
companies usually or
for more professional sort of projects
so of course we are looking at the
individual edition and if you selected
this page you would be taken to this
particular web page where it will ask
you if you want to download and again
there are options depending on which
machine you're using after you're using
a linux you would choose one of these
two if you are using mac os you would
use one of these two and since i am a
windows user and i have a 64-bit system
this is the option i would use so again
it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been uh downloaded so
now upon opening it it will open up this
installation thing
you can just click next on most of these
again if you want to specify your
destination folder you can change it
here mine will be with a default folder
in the c drive and you can leave this
unticked you can you can change these
options much later so
this is how you install anaconda on
windows and it's pretty much the same on
other systems as well now once it's done
i will show you what exactly what are
some of the things that anaconda
contains that are not there if you
uh installed python like the way i had
shown you earlier just the bare bones
python implementation so as you can see
here my installation is actually
complete
and
now i will open anaconda and i'll show
you what how you can actually use this
anaconda so if i search for anaconda in
my system i would look for something
called anaconda navigator to actually
get started with this and when i open
that it should open something like this
so this is what opens when you click on
the anaconda navigator and as you can
see
there are a bunch of applications you
don't need to worry about what these
mean
right now
uh just understand that this this is
essentially a bundle of
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install anaconda navigator now now
that we have actually tackled
where we've seen how to install and i'm
hoping and i would recommend definitely
that everyone is watching this video
installs anaconda not just the
normal python
installation or implementation uh now
that we have gotten all the
introductions and the basics and the
installations uh regarding python aside
uh let's get right let's get down to
actually creating our first script so
now the question is uh how do we
actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we
how do we realize uh now that we've
installed a python like
now let's how do we start doing
something so
the answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic things that
you can do is create a python script and
execute a script a script is essentially
a sequence of commands and instructions
that you give
for python to run and execute to give
you a certain result so i will show you
how you can create a python script now
there are multiple ways of creating a
python script you can create it directly
from command line which is obviously
something i would not recommend because
it is not convenient and easy and it's
not very useful for a beginner another
way is using a text editor such as the
one i have opened right now which is the
notepad plus plus the text editor now
it's very important to not get confused
uh between notepad plus plus and the
standard notepad that comes with your
windows
or wordpad for that matter in fact text
editors such as notepad and
wordpad
that you are more familiar with create
text and files in a form that is called
rich text now rich text is something
is text that
contains formatting and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text plain
text is obviously text which does not
contain these fonts and these
formattings
and it only respects white spaces and
indentations those two being actually
useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
a plain text documents
that is very that was actually created
with programming in mind
obviously you can use a bunch of other
text editors such as wim and atom and
you can google for these there are
plenty of them so
without any further ado let's create our
first python script so one of the most
common or the most famous examples of
a first program in any program for that
matter not just python is creating a
print statement that gives us a
statement saying hello world so in
python this is how you would go about or
this is the syntax you would use to
create the statement
all right
now where it is very important when you
are saving your python program that you
use the dot py prefix so if i were to
save this i can choose whatever folder i
am going to choose
yeah this folder seems fine so now i
give the file name over here as say i
want to keep it as test i need to prefix
this with dot py and this
tells
any uh sort of interpreter or anytime we
need to read the script to know that
it's a python script we need to add a
dot py otherwise it will not be treated
as a python script it will be treated as
some normal document sort of a thing so
now that i have stored it as dot py
i have created my first python script
now
obviously the next question is i need to
see
what happens when i execute this line
when i run this script essentially so
to see that um there are multiple ways
the first way that i will show you is a
command line method which is obviously
again before we get into it it's not
something that i will be using to teach
you it's not something i would recommend
you just immediately start using
but for the sake of showing i will show
you how to execute a script in command
line well to do this you go since i have
installed anaconda in my system and i
will be using anaconda to
work in python what i will look for is
something called the anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that i
get anaconda prompt uh this will
essentially open you a command line uh
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this
now i'm already in the folder i believe
that had my script so
how do i call this script or how do i
run the script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so i enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders and command
line which is again something that i
might show you later but since my file
is already in the folder that i am in in
my command line i would just have to
enter this command right now so if i
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what i wanted i wanted it to
print this
these two words and of course the
command line is now waiting for the next
command for me so this is uh one of the
most simple ways of or the most
rudimentary ways of executing a python
script now another question would be
well
this isn't the most visually appealing
or
not the easy to read or easy to use way
of
executing scripts and i would agree and
that's why i'm going to introduce a
another technology or a software called
the ide so the ide in python or in any
programming language stands for
integrated development environment it's
essentially a software that not only
allows us to run scripts but it allows
us to create the scripts it allows us to
debug it allows us to see outputs it
allows us to see intermediary outputs
it allows us to do a wide variety of
tools and tasks and it comes with a
bunch of robust features to enhance our
python programming experience so let's
let's see so i will show you a an ide
called spider which comes bundled along
with the anaconda distribution that i
had mentioned earlier so if i open the
anaconda navigator
as you can see the anaconda navigator
shows me a bunch of technologies and
options and i'm looking for something
called the spider ide which is over here
as you can see here it's a scientific
python development environment uh this
is exactly what i'm looking for so
i am looking to launch this so now that
i've launched it you can see out here
this is what an ide looks like now this
looks very sophisticated and it's it's a
one and any almost any ide is a
wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider id in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
console console essentially
so now that we have already created our
script in notepad plus plus and i want
to open that script and i want to see uh
how an i how it would uh the result of
that script would look in an ide so
let's just open it so we can browse for
our file and as i had
named it test this is the file over here
i open this and as you can see out here
in the left hand pane
my script has opened and the command
that had given our had written is out
over here now if i want to run this
application i press this green button
and as you can see the result of my my
execution essentially is over here it's
in slightly small font but as you can
see over here uh it says hello world and
it's way and the next line is
essentially it's it's waiting for me to
do another execution of the script and
then it will give me new results so
let's actually give the system new
results so now that i have printed
something called hello world let's let's
change what's written over here let's
say i will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what i'm exactly doing these are things
that we will actually cover in the in
upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
a number three let's create a variable b
story number five all right let's get
another variable c
uh which will store the result of what's
in a and b in the addition of a and b
all right and let's print the result or
print what's in uh this variable c or
what's the result of a plus b i will
print a statement saying
the result of
the addition
of 3 and 5 is all right and i will put
my result over here
as you can see
i should get the result in this pane so
let's execute this and you can see
my first line is executed saying i will
perform basic maths and the next line
says the result of the addition of three
and five is eight so
this in this script what i've done is
i've performed uh two print statements
and i've performed a basic expression
some variable assignments uh all of
these things we will be doing later this
is what i what i'm essentially trying to
show you is that ides are a very
convenient way of not only creating the
scripts but actually seeing the results
and then making adjustments as well we
can com we can create a completely new
script we don't need to create a script
from some special file or text editor i
can just create a new file here and this
is my new script essentially so i can
start working on with this new script
right over here from the get go so ides
are very powerful spider ide comes
bundled with anaconda there are other
ides such as the i idle ide it stands
for
indicated development and learning
environment so the idle
ide comes
as part of the
basic python implementation that i had
shown you in the previous video where if
you just installed a basic
python
implementation it would come along with
a basic ide known as idle or integrated
development and learning environment
but of course since we are using python
and that is what i would recommend
it comes with a more robust ide called
spider
which is actually very very helpful for
scientific
and numeric applications
and was designed specifically with that
in mind
now um this is not the only way we can
actually work with python there's
another very interesting and uh a very
educative
method of creating python let's say
python programs and it's something that
i will be using extensively throughout
this course to explain different
concepts so this technology is called or
the software is called uh notebooks
now before i get into the details i will
state i will just open node a basic
notebook so the notebook that comes as
part of anaconda is called the jupiter
notebook and when i open or when i
launch the jupyter notebook this is what
i get
now
a very important
feature or a
a feature of notebooks is that notebooks
uh a web browser or a web-based
application so you it's not something
that you can use if you are offline or
disconnected basically if you're
disconnected from the internet it is
something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good uh properties that allow
it to be used in education or for
presentations and such so as you can see
this is my jupyter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now i will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here now you go to new and
you select under notebook the python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see
this line is essentially waiting for me
to enter some sort of a command or a
statement that i would give in a normal
python thing now if you would have
noticed the diff in
until now everything that we were doing
involved us uh creating a script which
was the whole series of commands and
functions so if i go back to my spider
ide as you can see like this is a whole
script and this script contains multiple
different
tasks and functions that are
individually
being performed so this is a separate
print function this is a separate
edition another separated print function
and for longer uh programs or larger
programs you like you have multiple
different tasks being done and if you
were using a script you can only see the
result of something like this by
executing the whole thing at once you
cannot see exactly like uh what is the
result of just this print statement or
just this uh it's not typically what an
ide is used for and this is where
notebooks come in super handy if i had
to break down my previous script
essentially where i first did a print
statement where i said some random thing
say hello
yeah so if i execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now i want to do what is five plus three
it should give me the result over here
eight now the next
another part of your program might be
storing five and three into variables so
i can do this and i can do this so now
this line will store the variables now i
want to do the addition of what is 5
plus 3 but i want to use the variables
and i want to see what's the result as
you can see a plus b means 5 plus 3
which is 8 and i've essentially broken
down various different parts of my
previous script into
into its individual tasks and i'm able
to see what each part of that script
does and this is very good when it comes
to making presentations or trying to
teach a class so i will personally be
using notebooks a lot to explain
different different concepts of um
different concepts when it comes to
python and i would recommend that you
get used to
notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to learn python
programming or programming in general in
fact
and again as i had mentioned earlier
notebooks are something that it's an
online
application it's a web-based application
so i will have to need a active internet
connection to be able to work on a
notebook which could be a disadvantage
if you do not have a consistent internet
connection and in that case you would
probably use your ides or text editor
which you can be used offline as well in
this video we will be introduced to the
concept of variables and expressions
let's start with expressions well an
expression in python is anything that
results in a value
its difference although the difference
between an expression and a standard
statement in python is that a statement
in python is something that results in
an action or an execution of a command
there is no calculation per se or any
sort of manipulation or as i said
earlier calculation resulting in between
two different say numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if i were to add two numbers
say 5 plus
10 this is an expression which should
where two objects 5 and 10 are being
added and a result is being given to me
which is 15. now let's see an example of
a statement well a statement could be
something like a print statement so when
i ask python to print something for me
it's not calculating anything it's not
evaluating anything it's simply
performing an action that i have or a
command that i have given the system
which is to print whatever i have
entered over here as you can see so this
is a statement similarly there are
another type of statement known as
assignment statements which we will
learn actually right in the next section
well let's move on to variables right
now now earlier you might have learned
about objects in python so
objects are essentially data
that we can work with or manipulate in
python now variables are a place to
store these different objects
usually
it's much easier to
store objects in python instead of using
the objects explicitly themselves
because objects may be very completely
complicated whereas variables are very
simple to use and very simply
very are named in a very simple manner
so that we can use them quite often in
our programs now it's important to note
that in python we do not have to
explicitly declare or define a variable
to create them in fact variables are
created in the same statement where we
assign some object to that variable in
python the assignment of variables
happens using the assignment operator
which is the equals to sign so if i were
to if i wanted to assign a number say
100 to a variable say b well it would be
as simple as doing this now anytime i
want to know what is stored in b i just
have to enter b and i will get the value
that is stored in it and we can store
different types of objects inside a any
variable let's say i store i want to
store this particular word in the form
of a string now this is stored in x and
if i want to know what is an x i can
just see what is here and it's a string
hello which i had stored earlier now
it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown errors or we might get
some problems in our program so the
first rule is that you cannot start your
variable name with a number so if i were
to give a variable name like four num is
equal to something say
the same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and i will get an
error when i try this so if i were to
choose a num for
is equal to hello this would be
perfectly fine i won't get an error the
second rule is we are not allowed to use
any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if i were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and i
say i said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if i
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if i have a variable called num
or say num if this was one of my
variables and i stored say the value of
50 this is not the same as me writing
num all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call reserve words in python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are used as identifiers
for certain special functions in python
that we that have a special purpose like
that particular word has a special
purpose within the python programming
language and we cannot use them to name
our variables so a list of them either
you can see over here some of them are
like false def if
uh d e l raise and there are like there
are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated
now let's let's move on to a concept
where we try to really understand
what do we mean by storing data inside a
variable now when i say that we are
storing something inside a variable
you get an image or you get an idea in
your head that this variable is like a
container where we store or we put a
particular object inside it so does this
mean that variables have a place in the
memory are they also an object that is
placed in the memory where we can put
other objects inside of well i'll show
you an example where this idea is kind
of disproven or where i'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say i'm storing the same object
i will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and i'm going to
store it into two different variables so
i take x is equal to 100 over here
and in the next line i will store 100 in
y as well now if objects were i mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then x and y should have two
different ids but let's see what happens
when i check the id of x and the id of y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the id of x and the id of
y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
python cannot have the same id so does
this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
i said x is equal to 100 and y is equal
to 100 what i am actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called x that i want to refer or
point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and i do the
same thing with another variable y so i
am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when i do id of x and id of y
it's not giving me the idea of something
called x or the id of something called y
it's giving me the id of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in x and y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what i'm trying
to say and similarly if if i were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see i've used the
value of 50 to explain my point so as
you can see initially x and y are
pointing towards this value 50 because i
have stored 50 and 50 in both x and y
now what if i changed the object that is
stored in x well that means x is now
pointing towards
this new object and i have stored this
new object called hello the string
called hello as you can see here so now
x is pointing to a new object in the
system and it's called hello and
i haven't changed anything with respect
to y so y will point towards the same
thing and i can also make the pointer of
y different or what i'm trying to say is
i can store something else in y see i
stored this list in y 50 60 100. when i
do that now y is pointing towards a
different object in python and x is also
pointing towards something else so what
happens to this object 50 well now that
there's no variable referring to this
object 50 it becomes what we call an
orphaned object and we can actually see
that when we do the id of x now let's go
back to my example on the right where i
stored x is equal to 100 so as you can
see it gives me some id represented by
this number now let's say i stored x i
stored something different index say 200
now if i do the id of x it should give
me a different id because as you can see
the values are different and this is
because this object 200 is what is
stored in x and when i do the id of x
i'm actually getting the id of this new
object now 200. so as you can see point
as you can see variables are
they should be and they are treated more
like references or pointers
instead of containers for a particular
object in this video you will be
introduced to the concept of objects in
python now what are objects in python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
the usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually store it in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in python has three
important properties that kind of define
that particular object they are its
identity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change one once it has been
created so for example if i took an
example of
say a string called hello i can use the
id function which is this is how you use
the id function to find out the id of
this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the id of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in python have an identity we
have another operation with uh regarding
the identity of an object is the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially
what defines what kind of values and
operations
that that object can have so for example
a numeric data type in python such as an
integer would allow us to do arithmetic
operations and similarly string object
type in python will allow us to do
concatenation operations much like its
identity the type of an object cannot be
changed as well now let's see what's the
type of that particular object that i
had shown you above as you can see it
should be string str stands for string
similarly if i did a type for a number
say 50 it should give me int
as you can see now the third property of
an object in python is its value now the
value is the actual data that is
contained in the object it's the thing
that we use that we display that we can
manipulate and that we can perform
operations on so for example if i were
to talk about this string the string is
hello so the value of the string is the
word or the sequence of letters that
spell out hello and similarly this
particular object is a numeric object
with the value of 50. let's see in this
in this pictorial representation i have
shown you that you can assume this dash
blue area as the memory of the system
now within this memory we have objects
created called 50 and hello and this
list containing smaller objects called
cat pen and 40. now what i'm trying to
show you here is each of these objects
have a type an id and a value and let's
see what they are if i wanted to see as
we had already seen the type of 50 now
let's find the id of 50. as you can see
we get this unique id for the object 50
which is obviously not the same as the
id of the object hello above and the
value of this object is the valuable 50
itself so that was a brief introduction
into objects in python in this video we
will cover the topics of numeric object
types and type conversions in python now
let's get started numeric object types
in python are a broad classification of
objects plenty of common real life
applications that we associate with
numerals such as arithmetic operations
and calculus are done in python using
numeric object data types there are
three main types of numerals or numeric
data types in python they are integers
float and complex integers as the name
suggests represent all integer values in
python these can be such as 100 minus 3
to 305 and so on floats are used to
represent numerals that contain decimal
points such as 100.3 3.9 4.8 minus 6.8
and so on then there is the complex
object type which is used to represent
complex numbers in python and this is an
example of a complex number three plus
seven j
this is a complex number three plus
seven j where the real component is
three and the imaginary component is
seven all complex numbers have a real
and imaginary component and this is how
we denote them now it's important to
note that this j is a very common symbol
in maths and engineering used to denote
the imaginary portion of a complex
number and it's the same in python as
well so moving on let's talk about type
conversion in python type conversion
refers to the conversion of an object
from one data type to another for
example from string to an integer and
there are different types of conversions
and let's go through some of them first
of all let's consider the conversion of
something to an integer and more
specifically let's consider the example
where we convert a string to an integer
so let's consider
my example string to be
some something called 145 and i'm sewing
this within a string for a reason
because i want to convert a string to an
integer so as you can see i have stored
this 145 within my within a variable x
and if i were to confirm that is
actually an integer i can use the type
function and see that it is actually an
integer str now let's convert this into
an integer using the int function so how
would we use it is
simply passing the end
sim by passing the variable that we want
to convert into the in function and as
you can see this is what i've done over
here but before this i will also store
it into another variable all right now
let's see what's in y well y gives us
145 but are we sure that it's an int we
can just check it by using the type
function and as you can see the type
gives us
the answer end that means that we've
converted the string to an end
interestingly
we can convert something and
also specify what base we have to treat
the number as by default when we pass
something in the in function the program
or python will treat whatever we have
passed
within the string as something in base
of decimal but what if we were to pass
something that is well not in a decimal
well we could do it like this now let's
store y
and ny let's store
let's do this and i will show you what
this means x
and i will give a comma and 8. what this
does python is well i want to convert
the string in x
into an integer but i want to treat
whatever is an x as a number of base 8.
so 145 is actually 145 in the base 8.
now when we
see what's in y
we get 101 which is different to 145
because
well 1 0 1 is actually the decimal
equivalent of 145 in the base 8.
similarly if we were to give it in the
base 2 we would just replace 8 with 2
over here now next let's talk about
converting something to a float now as
we know float is just simply something
that has a decimal point so let's
convert an integer into a float how
would we do that simply by using the
float function so if i give 120 and i
pass this integer through the float
function i should get 120.0
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and one
120.0 is a different object which is a
float and this is how we convert
something to a float now what if we
wanted to convert an integer to a string
well we can use the str function
we can also use the hex and the oct
function if we want to convert a
particular number to a hexadecimal or an
octal string respectively let's look at
all three examples say i have a number
688 and i want to convert this into a
string i just use the str function
around this so as we know just to
confirm let's see what the type of 688
is this is this should be an end as we
can see but when we pass when we let's
say
we convert it into a string 688 and
let's store it into some variable let's
call it a all right now let's see what's
in a it gives us 688 in the form of a
string but we can confirm by checking
the type of a it is an str so it is a
string similarly we can use hex
if we wanted to convert an integer into
its hexadecimal equivalent in the in in
as an output of a string as you can see
this comp this sort of this sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this zero
should not be treated as anything it's
more like a an identifier which says
that
the letter
after this first 0 is the base of this
whole number so it's saying that x x
stands for hexadecimal so it's saying
that 2 b 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths
you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688. similarly if i
did oct if i use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first zero is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this zero is the base of
the number following these two
following these two characters so as you
can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an oct
represented by this letter o
and the number itself that we are
dealing with is one two six zero and one
two six zero in octal system is the
equivalent of six eight eight in the
decimal system so this is how we've
converted a an integer in uh an integer
into a hexadecimal or a an octal string
now what if we wanted to convert two
numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if i passed complex
5 and say
say something like 3.1
let's see what this gives us as you can
see it gives us an
a complex object where
our real part is 5 and our imaginary
part is 3.1 so what this does is
essentially
you pass two numbers the first one is
the real component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if i
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
i will use the tuple function and as you
can see over here
so let's say i have a string called
random let's call it random all right
now if i want to convert this to a tuple
i will use the tuple function as you can
see over here the output will give me
tuples where each individual component
of this tuple are the individual
components or the individual characters
of my string random similarly if i
wanted to convert the string to a list i
would use the
list function and this will give me a
list of the individual characters
of the word or the the string random and
i could do the same thing with the set
function to create
a set of
individual characters of
the string random as you can see here
so yeah these were some of the basic
python
type conversions that i have shown you
as we learn about more complex data
types and different object types in
python we will learn different
type conversions and functions
associated with them in this video you
will be introduced to the concept of
strings strings are an object type in
python used to store textual data this
textual data could be something like for
example someone's name it could be ns of
a place or it could be something like a
word or a sentence now strings in python
are an object type that is actually a
subtype of a broader classification of
objects called sequences sequences are
objects in python which contain
components placed one after the other
where each component is given what we
call an index a numeric index this
numeric index identifies the component
in the sequence and disposition within
the sequence now since python is a zero
index based language the first object of
any sequence is always index zero the
second is index one the third is index
two and so on now let's move on to
defining strings how do we define them
well strings are defined using what we
call delimiters and delimiters occur in
pairs an opening and a closing delimiter
in python these denominators are pairs
of single or double quotes so for
example if i were to use single quotes
to define a string i could i would do it
like this
this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if i were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this this is
also a
as you can see
now a valid question arises what if i
wanted to include a
single quote within my string well
if i tried to let's see what happens if
i try to print a statement with a single
quote naturally inside it so say i'm
saying it's my
birthday
all right let's see what happens if i
try to print this statement it says
invalid syntax and this is because as i
had mentioned in python single quotes in
double quotes are delimiters so they
have a special function in python and we
cannot simply just use them within a
string because python will treat them
specially for a special purpose so what
python will do is it will pair this and
this delimiter so single quotes and say
okay this looks like a string to me and
it's not going to understand the rest of
this and then it'll find a random single
quote and it won't find its pair and it
will basically throw us an error because
of this so
one way or one workaround to introduce
single quotes into a string is simply to
delimit our string itself using the
other type of delimiter or double quotes
so if i want to include a single quote i
will close my string using double quotes
so if i did this instead of what i had
done earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and i could i
would do the opposite if i had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string i would use single quotes to
close it so
if i were to write a speech statement
she said
i am
hungry all right i have i want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and i'm gonna close the
string using single quotes and this is a
valid way of doing it as you can see my
string has these two double quotes now i
had mentioned that strings are sequences
well let's describe how are they
sequences so first of all all sequences
in python are a um it's a essentially a
sequence of smaller objects that form
the sequence right so let's try to
understand like how do how are strings
to be treated as sequences some
sequences that we will learn later are
like lists or tuples and in all
sequences
we can retrieve any particular object or
component in that sequence using its
index and how do we use indexes in
python well we enclose a numeric index
within square brackets now let's see
what i'm trying to talk about by this
example now say i'm storing a particular
string called say random within now my
variable name here is test and i'm
storing the string random within it all
right and this is a way of retrieving a
particular
index from test i write the variable
name and then next to it i put the
square brackets now i'm supposed to put
um a numeral within the square brackets
to
tell python like what a particular index
i'm looking for so let's try zero now as
i said python is zero index based
language so
the zero index essentially means the
first part of for the first component of
a sequence so let's see what happens
when i ask python to retrieve the first
part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string r in fact is just one character r
and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is r so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
random is essentially a collection of
the string r the string a the string n
and so on together combined to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if i wanted the character at
the third position of this thing i would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in python i would
use the index 2 and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's given
me the letter n so this is how we can
show that our strings are also sequences
in python well now let's move on to
certain string operations and functions
that we can perform well as you have
seen already that we can retrieve any
particular character within a
within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we want to know what index
is a particular character at and we can
do it like this we use the index
function so let's say my test and i want
to know where or what position the
character d is in my string random so
this is how i would use the index
function index and within the index say
i'm looking for the character d and now
i it should give me the answer 0 1 2. it
should give me the answer 3. so if i
execute this it gives me the index 3. so
this is
the index function that we can use for
our strings now what if we want to
say slice a string into a into its into
a smaller part we want to slice it and
we want to retrieve only that particular
size well here is an example say i'm
gonna i'm gonna use the same string
called random and stored in test right
so let's
so one way of so the way of doing this
is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if i went to my
string random a and d is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what i
have done by entering one colon for
well what this has done is it's
retrieved a slice
from the first position uh the first
index which is the character a
up until the fourth position which is
the character o but it has not included
o so it's very important when i index
like this every every time i put
something to the right of this colon i
am not including this itself all right
so it's essentially one when i say one
colon for what i'm telling python is
give me the first the second and the
third character but not the fourth one
so it's given me a n and d and it's
that's this is how we do a slicing
operation in python similarly if i were
to say slice
from the first if i wanted only the
first and the second character i would
do this is what i would do
if i wanted the first and the second
character i would do one two three so
this way it says python that i want the
first i want the second but not the
third off so as you can see i get a and
n now so this is a basic slicing what if
i wanted the portion of a string from a
particular point all the way to the
right or all the way to the left well
let's consider the example of where i
want the portion of the string random
from the say fourth character until the
left well the way i would do this is
test now since i want it all the way to
the left i don't enter any index to the
left of my colon sign and since i want
everything to the left of the fourth
character i enter 4 here so as you can
see it gives me a r a and d which is
everything from the fourth character of
my string random to the left similarly
if i wanted something to the right of it
i would just do it like this i would
enter some index here and i would leave
the portion to the right of the colon
blank so this will give me everything
including the third character since this
is how we treat the uh indexing in
python everything including the third
character all the way to the right so
this is dom as you can see now another
perfectly valid um slicing is say i want
to slice
or take out
different characters from the string but
i want to skip certain characters like i
want this one then i want to skip one
and i want to take the next one and then
i want to skip one well in that case we
have to introduce a step
so one way of doing this is now how do
we read this so as you can see i have
written 0 colon 6 colon 2. so what this
is telling python is i want every
character from my string test
starting from the zeroth character up
until the sixth but not including the
sixth after skipping or taking two at a
time taken to a time can also be assumed
as skipping one at each step or skipping
one character at each step so what this
will do is it will go to random it will
take the zeroth one it will take r and
then it will skip the next one so it
will not consider a and then it will
pick n and then it will not consider d
and then it will consider o up until the
sixth character whichever that may
whichever that may be and if you see the
output it gives us r and o which is
exactly what we wanted we wanted r you
wanted n we wanted o where we skipped uh
a and d or we skipped the every second
character essentially so this is a way
of um slicing strings while also
skipping certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if i were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is a minus 1 index it gives me
the character m now remember a string is
random so minus 1 gave us the last
character of the string random which was
m so this is a way of using negative
indexes and similarly if i used test
minus 2 it would give me the second last
character which should be the character
o as you can see here now there are some
other important functions that you may
use in python for that let's create
another let's get another string let's
call it upper
lower all right i'm sorrying it again in
the same variable test let's see what
happens when i use the upper function
and what happens when i use the lower
function
now i'm going to use the lower function
for this
these two functions will respectively
give out or give us the result or give
us our string in uppercase and lowercase
respectively so as you can see the upper
function created the first string in
full upper case and the second one
created this bar the string in full
lowercase now another important and
probably one of the most important
methods that we use for strings
especially
when it comes to data science is the
split function so let's see what i mean
by split function let me create another
string let's call it hello world
all right i'm going to use a split
function and i'm going to see what
happens when i
use this function essentially so what
i'm doing in these in this these three
lines is i'm creating the string hello
world i am storing it in test and then i
am using the split function on the test
and whatever result i get i'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
i'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that i have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and i've stored
both of these into what we call a list
now you might ask well how does python
know that it has to separate at a blank
space well the split function by default
will break up a string at its blank
spaces but if we wanted we could break
it up using or add every comma so for
example if i wrote hello world using
comma and if i put a comma inside over
here and now if i try to execute this
like for example i am going to find i'm
going to look for commas in the string
and i'm going to try to split it as you
can see there's no splitting happening i
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if i introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and it's caused a split
between hello and world similarly if i
in my string if i put this comma again
and i put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
define our split using some whatever we
put in between these circle brackets
after the split function it's just
important to note that by default if in
case we do not enter anything over here
it will use blank spaces to do the
splitting
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if i have two
strings first and say another string
second
and i want to join these together well
the operator i would use to do this is
called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing let's see what is
the result as you can see what this has
done is it has combined the first string
first and the string second into one
string called first second so this is
the concatenated concatenation operator
now finally
the last topic in this lesson is the
topic of escape sequences now escape
sequences are special commands that tell
python to either suppress special
meaning of some character or symbol in a
string or give or give the special or
give some special meaning to an
otherwise ordinary character
in a string so let's look at the first
example now remember my in my for
earlier in this video where i was i was
telling you like uh what what is the way
of writing or how do we introduce single
quotes or double quotes into a string
and i told you the trick if i want to
use a single quote in my string
i just close it using double quotes or
if i want to use a double quote i close
it using single
well another way of doing this is using
what we call an escape sequence and an
escape sequence in python is the
backslash character all right so let's
see what happens when i use the
backslash character where i want to
introduce my single quote so if i use my
previous example where i wanted to
introduce a single quote and say
i am going to close it using single
quotes as
well so i am going to go back to my
error example so as to speak now this
would throw me an error right as you can
see it has thrown me an error so what if
i used the escape sequence that i
mentioned the escape sequence is just
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where i want my my
single quote so i introduce the
backslash now i have my single quote and
i continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backslash character has told python
to not read this
special character or the single quote do
not treat it specially and let it be as
a part of the string so as you can see
that's what's happened here now the next
case or the other uh use case of escape
sequences is when we want to
give a particular character that is
otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so
let's take the example of the character
t and the character n we use the
character t to introduce tab space
and we use a character n to introduce
what we call line brick well let's see
by an example so
normally the character t has no special
function
so the character t within a string will
just
be outputted as the characterity itself
however as you can see here i'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we call a tab space
which is the larger than normal space
similarly if i were to use the
backslash n combination this would
introduce what we call
a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where i have this combination of
backslash n a line break has occurred so
there are plenty of other escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and
these are just two of the probably the
most common ones that are used so yeah
this was an introduction into strings in
python in this video i will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists
are a collection of ordered orbit
arbitrary objects that are similar to
what we call an array in other
programming languages but lists are way
more flexible when it comes to python
python lists are a type of sequence and
we might have you might have seen what a
sequence is when we were learning about
strings and much like in sequences or
any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever we want to uh
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way
or a simple list that i have just
created and assigned to a variable a
which contains three objects one two and
three let's talk about some of the
features of python lists python lists
are ordered and what this means is that
even if two lists contain the exact same
elements if they if the elements are
placed in a different order the two
lists are actually unique and different
and i can check that over here i have
created a list one two and three and see
if i create another list two
and one and three the same elements were
in different order i will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when i use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they are not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see i
get the value false because even though
i have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where i
show you list operations the next
property is list are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making or as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are
programming without having to go through
a compilation stage so if we had to say
increase the or we had to add certain
elements to an already created list that
original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can
contain any arbitrary objects so if i
created a list right now where
say if i want to store some numbers
say some floating point numbers now
and i can put strings
as well into my list all of these are
valid uh when it comes to objects that
can be put inside a list we have no such
restrictions so we can put any arbitrary
objects inside our list the final
property that i want to talk about is
that lists are
they can be nested to any arbitrary
depth what this means is that i can put
a list within a list and i can keep
nesting it essentially by putting
as many lists i want within my list and
i'm only essentially restricted by my
systems memory so if i created a list
like this
within this say i put another list and
within this list i put another list i
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and i'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that i'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where i'm storing six numbers
so now say if i wanted to retrieve a
particular element say if i wanted to
find out what's on the index 3 this is
how i would do it if i wanted a slice of
my original list and much like strings i
do it the same way so what this does is
it tells python that i want all the
elements of list a from index one to
index four but not including index four
so it will give me one two and three
index uh objects so it should give me
two three and four in this case as you
can see here two three and four i can do
the same thing by considering elements
say two at a time if i wanted to
consider elements or consider every
second element what i would do is this
syntax i would use this syntax and when
i give this command to python what it
tells what it understands is i want
every element from a
from index 1 to index 4 but not
including index 4 but i am going to
consider 2
every second uh
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then skip one
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call start
slicing by using strides so i'm taking
strides i'm not considering elements
consecutively but i'm skipping certain
elements in between if i wanted to
consider every third element i would
change this to three and fourth element
i would change this to four alright so
let's see what happens when i take every
second element it should it should give
me uh it will consider say from one to
index three right so it should consider
essentially
this section but since it's going to
skip one it's going to consider this
skip this and then consider this it
should give me two and four as you can
see it has given me two and four and
like in other
sequences we can use negative indexes as
well negative indexing essentially
starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when i say a minus one it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
object six if i did a minus two it gives
me the second last element similarly
another neat trick that we can use for
sequences is the following syntax double
colon and we give a minus one what this
tells the
what this tells the system is i want the
list a but with all the elements
reversed as you can see i get my element
uh my list a but the elements have been
reversed right now let's move on to
uh concatenation and replication well
concatenation much like in strings is
done by using the plus sign so as we
know on either side of the plus sign
should be two similar objects so if i'm
doing a plus something a being a list on
the other side it should be a list as
well so let's add a list like this
now let's see what's in a as you can see
my original list has a 7 8 9 added to it
and i can also add things to the
beginning of a list similarly so if i
wanted to add say
you know at the beginning of a list i
just do it like this
and i get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that i
i i actually added 0 within a list
because if i did 0 like this
it would throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an int object and it's
not a list but when i put the square
brackets i make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if i did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where i'm repeating
the values in a twice if i did a star 3
it's the same function
but now i'll have the elements repeated
thrice as you can see here let's move on
to modifying list values
this also shows the mutable property of
lists that i had mentioned earlier so
let's consider this example so i created
a list with elements where there's three
strings eggs apples and carrots and i
have
five int objects one two three four and
five
now if i wanted to change say the first
element all i have to do is take the
zero width index
and say if i want to replace eggs with
say mango
this is how i would do it
now i've replaced eggs with mango if i
check what's in b
you can see the eggs have been replaced
with the element mango similarly i can
use the slice syntax to replace
a particular slice from my list with a
slice essentially so let's look at this
i'm replacing i want to replace the
first three elements i want to replace
mango i want to replace apple and carrot
so what i will do is i will consider
this since this carrot is the second
index so i will consider zero to three
because the third is not counted now i'm
going to replace this with three
different um
let's see
and say sponge now let's check what's in
b you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact i don't have to
replace like for like if i want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if i want to replace the first three
elements kiwi orange and sponge
with
um just one element this is how i'll do
it let's say
wine
now let's check what's here as you can
see three elements have been replaced
with one mine i can double vice versa as
well i can replace smaller number of
elements with a larger number of
elements but here there is a slight
caveat that i want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if i wanted to replace the first element
wind with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index
and then put whatever objects you want
say i want to add instead of wine i want
to add beer i want to add
ball
and
say
club yeah well let's see what happens
now if i say b
check what's inside my now you can see
my elements have been added but they
seem to have been added as is you know
i had entered a list over here and that
whole list has been replaced uh or this
vine has been replaced by this whole
list in the first position but that's
not exactly what i wanted i wanted the
elements within this list to be
individually placed into my list and the
way to do that is not this syntax but
actually what i'm going to show you now
if i want to replace one if i want to
replace the index of the object at index
0 i would give this statement a slice
statement where i will give 0 colon 1 so
when i do this and if i
so let's create my old scenario again
where i had wine
and i had one two three four and five
now if i do this b
zero but i give a slice then this slice
is essentially a single object slice
it's essentially the zeroth index again
but because of this
formatting or this this type of syntax
that i'm using
what python will do is now when i say
beer
and
ball
and club now what python will do is it
will not consider this whole list and
add it to in place of
wine or whatever i want to replace it
will actually consider the elements
inside of this individually and then
replace so if you see here
now if you see my list i actually have
the
i've removed wine and in place of it i
put beer ball in club but these three
are actually individual objects within
my list and not objects within a list
that is then placed within my original
list so this is an important caveat that
you should take note of so moving on
let's talk about certain methods
associated to lists let's take a simple
list now one two and three the first
operation that i want to show you or the
first method is the append method so
when i do a append and say if i want to
append the list by one object called
four
i just do it like this now let's see
what's in a i put so as you can see the
append has put the object 4 into my
original list now say if i wanted to
append
three different objects i want to append
5 6 and 7 now let's see what append
function does
oh no as you can see it's done a similar
operation to what we have seen earlier
when we gave a single index or the
single element replacement
that we saw earlier it essentially put
this whole list into this particular
spot into the list and this is not what
i wanted i wanted 5 6 and 7 to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what i'll
show you next now if i want to extend
say the original list by three different
elements eight nine ten when i use the
extend function it will not put this
whole thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what i wanted now the next
method that i want to discuss is the
remove method
so the remove method is
what you how you use it is within the
parent thesis you put the
object that is present in the list that
you want to removed so you don't give an
index over here you give the object
itself so if i want the object 8 all
right this number if i want 8 itself
removed what i will do is put the value
8 here and it will remove it from my
list so if i check my list a as you can
see the value 8 has
it's gone a next another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the right most value from the
list but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value
and that value is what we have popped
out of the list so by default it will
pop out the right route right most value
of a list a rightmost element of a list
and in this case that element is 10 so
it should give me 10. but of course if
we want to pop out any particular object
in this case we do not give that
particular object we give its index so
now say if i want to remove this
this list object from my bigger list
as i can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4
it's the fourth index so if i want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index i give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for lists let's move on to tuples next
so tuples are another ordered collection
of objects much like lists but they
differ from lists in two key properties
first of all the tuples are defined
using parenthesis instead of square
brackets so this is how i would define a
tuple with elements one two and three
and the next very important property
that is different or that differentiates
tuples from lists is that tuples are
immutable and what this means is that
once we create an object of type tuple
we cannot make any modifications to it
we would have to only create a new
object if we wanted something different
and this is obviously a key difference
between a tuple and a list but apart
from this
every operation that we have done on
lists are actually possible to do in the
case of tuples as well so any operation
that we did to lists that did not modify
the list or that does not do any
modification we can actually apply to
tuples as well so if i wanted the first
element of this dupl all i have to do is
call it by the index 0 it should give me
the value 1 as you can see if i wanted a
slice
i can do that as well it should give me
2 and 3. and if i wanted to reverse my
tuple well i can use my same neat
technique that i've used for lists and
that i can use for the sequence i mean
strings as well so it gives me my old
tuple but with the elements reversed so
now the natural question is why do we
use tuples over list well one important
difference is that when we con when we
make a program execution where or where
we are manipulating a tuple if we did
the same thing for the exact same
objects in uh that if it were present in
a list it would be much faster in a
tuple essentially program execution is
just faster on tuples when compared to
an identical list so use tuples over
list when we want to be efficient while
we are creating an ordered list of
objects so whenever we create an ordered
list of objects that we don't need to or
we don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is
when we are using dictionaries
dictionaries as we will see later is a
data type in python that needs an
immutable component
while we are creating the dictionary so
if we
want to use
uh something that is like a list but
since lists are mutable we can use a
tuple instead and use that when we are
creating our dictionary and we will see
like what uh what i mean by
the immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually uh learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuple
over a list uh a brief section on tuple
unpacking and packing is what i would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when i create when i give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be
me packing this tuple into a object or a
variable t now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that i can unpack a tuple
onto another tuple so let me show you
what i mean by that so now that i have
packed one two three and four tuple into
t let's unpack it into another tuple
let's call this let's
put these elements into this tuple and i
put this into t all right now let's see
what i mean by unpacking something onto
something let's see what's uh what what
what happens when i put a if i just want
to see what's in a it actually gives me
the value 1 if i see what's in b it
gives me the value 2. if i see what's in
3 giving value 3 and d gives me value 4.
so essentially if you think of it what i
have done is i have matched this tuple
then put it into t and then put that
tuple t into this tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been uh
or a better way to say this would be the
element 1 has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a 2 has been unpacked onto
b 3 has been unpacked onto c 4 has been
unpacked onto d to show you what i've
done in a single line is essentially
this
this is essentially what i've done
i have assigned 1 to a
2 to b 3 to c 4 to d i have matched
these two tuples together like this and
this is a very neat feature of tuples
the only only important thing that you
have to keep in mind is the elements of
this tuple and the elements on this
tuple
should be equal so if there are four
elements here there should be four
elements here all right i in fact
another very important thing about or a
neat feature is that we don't really
need to mention the parenthesis when
we're doing this
unpacking or packing so if i did x
comma y comma z if i did it like this if
i put say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a
valid way of packing and unpacking so
now if i see what's the value in x it is
actually 5 if i see what's the value in
y it is 6. if i see what is the value of
x and
z it should give me a tuple containing 5
and 7 as you can see over here so this
is a neat feature of pupils called
packing and unpacking so yeah in this
video we will cover concepts surrounding
dictionaries dictionaries are another
type of composite data type in python
that are also a collection of objects
much like tuples and lists and like
lists they are also mutable dynamic and
can be nested however a key difference
and property of dictionaries is that
they are unordered items in dictionaries
are paired using keys unlike in lists
and tuples where the objects are
assigned numerical indexes to define a
dictionary we use curly braces each key
value pair in this dictionary in a
dictionary is separated using commas and
the key and values themselves in a pair
are separated using a colon let's look
at an example this is a dictionary where
i have three key value pairs as you can
see they have been separated by colons
and each of the pair themselves are
separated by commas and these are
enclosed in curly braces to define the
whole dictionary in this
example
these are the keys banana apple and
grape and their respective values are
yellow red
and green so this is very important that
in this particular
data type we have what we call a key and
that key is assigned a value and we can
have multiple such pairings and we have
three such pairs in this particular
example another example or the or
another type of way to define a
dictionary is using the dict function
this is how we use it as you can see i
have
inputted two value or two object tuples
this is a tuple this is a tuple and this
is a tuple and when i use it in a dict
function
when i place it within a list what
python will do is it will consider the
first element of each tuple as a key and
the second element of each tuple as its
respective value now if i check what's
in d as you can see the key banana has a
value yellow the key apple has a value
red the key grape has a value green this
is another way of defining dictionaries
an important
note over here is that
the
the objects that we use for keys have to
be of an immutable data type so we
cannot use for example lists
as an example of keys but we can use say
integers or strings for our dictionary
keys also keys have to be unique when it
comes to a dictionary you cannot have
two different keys with uh
or should i say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have a mutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if i
created a dictionary with a key say
banana
and if i give if i associated with it
a value green i cannot create
another key banana and associate
a value yellow let's see what happens
when i actually do this if you actually
see
what has happened here is python has
considered the second case so it's it
first looks at the first pair it goes
okay so my dictionary has a key banana
with a value green but right after it
sees another key banana with the value
yellow so it overwrites my first key
banana with the second key and it
overrides the first value green with the
second value and we essentially get one
key banana with the second value yellow
so obviously this is uh python does this
to avoid duplicates however if i
created a dictionary with a key banana
again
if i created i gave it a value yellow or
say green
if i created another
key and if i gave this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not
nothing special will happen in this case
because values do not have to follow
such rules let's speak or let's see
certain dictionary operation operations
and functions now so let's
bring back our
original dictionary which we had created
earlier with the three pairs all right
so what if i wanted to
we can use keys to
essentially do these operations and
functions let's see what happens when we
so much like how we use sequence how we
use indexes in example of sequences we
use keys when it comes to dictionary so
let's see what happens when we use a key
over here
so we actually know banana is a key in
this dictionary let's see what happens
when we do where we give this command it
actually gives the value associated with
that key which is yellow what if we
wanted to change a particular value
associated to a particular key i would
give i would do this i would give the
key and assign it
the value that i want to change it with
all right now if i check my dictionary
you can see the key banana no more has
yellow value but the value gold what if
i wanted to add a new pair you know a
new key with a new value completely i
would do it pretty much the same same
way as i did in the previous step i
would um essentially write my new key
whatever i wanted say if i wanted a new
key called watermelon i would assign it
a value
red
and now if i check my dictionary
at the end of the dictionary you will
see that my
new key pair key value pair has been
added watermelon red as you can see over
here now what if i wanted to remove if i
wanted to remove a
key value pair from my dictionary i can
use the delete function which is
called by using this the del function
now how do i do it say if i want to
remove the key value apple in red so all
i have to do is do d e l
d and within square brackets i have to
only mention the key i don't even need
to mention the value just the key so
you can probably draw parallels in how
we use indexes when it comes to lists
and tuples and even strings and how we
use keys when it comes to dictionaries
they are quite similar so if i did this
and if i um oops i think red is actually
not a key as you can see red is a value
my
key is apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if i see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operations that we can do
for dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use the
get function all we have to do is uh
enter a key inside the parenthesis and
it will get the value associated with
that key so if i gave the key great
let's see what value is associated with
it as you can see it's green
there is also a function called items
that returns the key and value pairs in
our dictionary as a list of two object
tuples where the first object is the
key and the second object is the tuple
so let's see what it does as you can see
it gave me a
list and in this list the
objects inside the list are two object
tuples where the first object is always
the key and the second is the value and
it's the same for each of the tuples so
this is what items function does let's
see what
the next so the next function is keys
let's see what the keys function does as
you can see it returns a list of all the
unique keys within our list i mean
within our dictionary similarly we can
there is a function for values as well
and as you can see it returns all of the
different values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say i had another key
where its value was green again so i
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the
pop function in list
it gives us the last entered
key value pair that is present in our
dictionary so the last centered pair was
watermelon
key watermelon with the value red and
that's what has popped out when we give
this function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if i had a dictionary let's say i'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where
i have say
some key called key kv so as i had
mentioned i will use two object tuples
in this case
and
let's say i give this also a value green
all right and another
pair would be
say mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called kiwi with value green and
another key mango with the value yellow
and i already have a dictionary d with
these values all right
now if i want to merge these two
dictionaries i can use the update
function what i do is say if i want to
merge d with x or x with d only the
ordering will change and that doesn't
really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if i want to merge d
with x i use d update and then inside it
i put my target dictionary now when i
check what's in d i have
the
the dictionary x and its key value pairs
uh merged inside my original dictionary
d as you can see i have my original ones
here and i have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video i will explain what we
call the
type hierarchy or the standard type
hierarchy in python it's also known as
the data model in python and it probably
has other names so essentially in the
what we do or what we speak about in
this is
how the different types that we use in
python are categorized and classified
and what are their subtypes so it's
important to note before we continue
further that they're in future versions
of python there might be new types that
are introduced or the existing ones may
be modified but it's safe to say that
what i will speak about in this video
will still form the core of what we call
python standard type hierarchy so let's
begin so the first type is the nun type
uh it's accessed through the built-in
name none its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote um
functions or it's you it's returned as
the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it
then there is the ellipses ellipsis is
something that you might encounter later
it is accessed through the built-in name
ellipsis
it is used to indicate the presence of
this particular
syntax this particular symbol or
expression
or syntax in a slice its truth value is
true again don't worry too much about
ellipses right now next is numbers and
numbers is something that we are very
familiar with we have seen we work with
numbers a lot they are an immutable type
they are created through numeric
literals and they are the outputs of
arithmetic expressions and built-in
arithmetic functions its subtypes are
integers floating point numbers and
complex numbers
within integers you have plane integers
that represent numbers in the range
this number and this number so this this
number is basically the largest positive
value that you can represent using 32
bit notation in two's complement and
this is the equivalent
for the the negative the negative side
long integers on the other hand are used
to represent numbers in an unlimited
range that is only subject to the
available memory of your system so these
are two types of integers and as we know
floating point numbers represent machine
level double precision floating point
numbers or numbers with a decimal point
and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating point number that represents a
real part and a floating point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed by natural numbers
so each element in a sequence has an
index and that index is a natural number
the different types of sequences are
based on the mutability whether the
objects can be changed or not is
essentially what we mean by mutability
right once we create an object whether
we can modify it or not and that is how
we differentiate different types of
sequences so there are
mutable and there are immutable types
now the different types of immutable
ones are strings we know what strings
are they are sequences that contain
characters unicode is the other
immutable sequence and then there are
tuples tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and uh there is only one
currently there is only one built-in
mutable sequence in python and that is
lists
lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects
finally we have well not finally but
next we have mappings and mappings are
again
sets of
objects
but these objects are now indexed using
arbitrary
index sets you know the difference
between a mapping and a sequence you
could consider
sequences are ordered but mappings are
not ordered and
the indexes given to the objects and
sequences are always numbers they're
natural numbers whereas in mappings they
are not natural numbers but they are
certain arbitrary objects that we can
set for ourselves again in python there
is only one built in standard
mapping type of objects indexed by
nearly arbitrary values the only
condition is so what i have mentioned
until now are probably the most common
data types that available types such as
user-defined functions user-defined
methods built-in functions built-in
methods classes and class instances so
again callable types as a whole are
referenced using the call function and
this is something that we will learn
when we start learning about functions
when we learn about object oriented
programming
and methods and functions and such the
other type are modules so modules are
module objects or modules essentially
are referenced or called using the
import function again modules can be
considered as these large libraries or
larger pieces of code or applications
that we
that contain various different methods
and functions and objects and classes
within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will during the course of this tutorial
we
are during the course of this uh
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using
the function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types
finally there are internal types that
are used by python interpreter again
this is something that
does not concern us right now but just
know that
the interpreter for python uses these
data types for its functioning so into
python
type hierarchy in this video i will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication so let's go
over them one by one so a simple
addition operation would be like 5 plus
6 giving me the value 11. i can do 5
minus 3 that's subtraction similarly i
can do a multiplication using five say
five into two there's division where i
use the backslash so say i did division
of eight divided by two now you might
encounter another type of division which
is called the floor division where we
use a double backslash and what this
does is it returns us the largest whole
number that is lesser than the result of
our division so the division difference
between the float division and the
normal floored and
the floor division or the single and the
double backslash is this say i did 9
divided by 2 using a single backslash it
should give me as you can see 4.5 right
so this is the actual value now let's
see what happens when i do 9 double
backslash 2. it will give me 4 which is
the largest number lesser than or equal
to 4.5 that is also a whole number so
this is what we call flow division
essentially finally we also have
if we want to raise something to the
power of something so if i want to do
five i say six raised to the power three
because i would use double asterisks and
this is how i would do it it give me 216
as you can see uh if i wanted remainder
between the division between two
different numbers i will use the
percentage sign so if i wanted the
remainder of the division between seven
and three this is how i would do it i
get the answer one as you can see so
next category of operations are logical
operations the first one is the logical
and operation where we use the operator
end alright so let's see
what we mean by this i am creating so as
we know the and operation returns the
value true if both the operands are true
so
let's actually let's actually do this
for an example let's give this variable
the value true and this the value of
false
it should be done like this false so now
uh think of it like one and zero so one
and zero is obviously zero right so if i
did a
and
b i should get the answer false or zero
because i'm doing true and false so it's
like doing 1 and 0. so if you see this i
should get the answer false if i change
this to true as well now if i do this i
will get the answer true as you can see
the next logical operation is the or
operation
where
well logical or is if either of the
operands are true then we should get the
answer to our order operation as true as
well so in this case obviously if i did
or over here it will naturally give us
true if i change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us false if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is the logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the
value that we get
is true if the operand is false so let's
take a as we know a is false over here
so if i did not a i should get the
answer true but if i change this to true
now if i do not a i should get false as
you can see so this was the
logical operations let's move on to the
next set of operations that is
comparison operations so there are a
bunch of them let's go over them one by
one if i want to check if two operands
are equal so if i did x is say equal to
two and now y is equal to three if i
want to check if they are equal i will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal i will get the value true
if they aren't it'll i'll get value
false as you can see since x is 2 and y
is 3 as you can see x and y are not the
same so there's false they are not equal
if i change this also to 2 now i will
get the answer too another the next
comparison is the x uh not equal to or
where we use the exclamation sign so
over here this is this
the result of this is true if x and y
are not actually it's the same so i
should get false over here as you can
see but if i change this to say 5 now i
will get true because x is not equal to
y in this case the next one is greater
than so if i did x greater than y
as we can see 2 is not greater than 5 i
will get false over here similarly there
is a lesser than if i did x lesser than
y i should get true over here as you can
see there's also a
greater than or equal to and lesser than
or equal to we simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if i say x is
lesser than or equal to 3 i should get
true because x is 2.
and if i put 2 here i should also get 2
but what if i put 1 here since x is
equal to 2 and 2 is not less than equal
to 1 this is a false statement and i can
do the same thing with like this using
the greater than equal to now it's true
because 2 is actually greater than equal
to 1. and so this was comparison
operations the next set of operations
that we can do in python are assignment
operations we've already seen a whole
bunch we've already been assigning
values to variables we've been doing
assignments throughout already but let's
go over them and see some of the
assignment operations so as we already
know the equal to operation is assigning
everything that is on the or the value
on the right hand side of the equal to
sign to what is on the left so if i did
a is equal to 5 plus 6 it will assign
the value 5 plus 6 or 11 to a let's
check what's in a as you can see it is
11. there is a plus equal to sign and
what this does is so for example if i
did
say a now since a is 11 let's create
another variable called b and call this
five all right so now if i did a plus
equal to b what this will do is it will
add b to a and then store it in a so
let's see what this does once i do this
now let's check what's in a it should be
5 11 as you can see 16. so this a plus
so this plus equal to sign is
essentially the same as doing a is equal
to a plus b it's essentially the same
thing they're both the same uh there's a
similar thing for this the negative
symbol or subtraction as well minus
equal to so now that a is 16 and b is
still 5 of course if i did minus equal
to b now i'm subtracting the value 5
from 16 so i should get a is equal to 11
again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus b a is
equal to a minus b i mean as you can see
so
uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say b is equal to
i will say 2 all right now if i do a
star
star equal to b what this does is it
multiplies b to a and then assigns it
back to a so if i see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if i did a is
equal to 6 and b is equal to 2 if i did
a sorry for division so if i did a
division symbol and
equal to sign and then if i give b what
it will do is it will divide a by b or 6
by 2 and it will assign that back to a
so my value in a should be three as you
can see here three point zero obviously
this is a single uh single backslash so
this is a float division the resultant
of a single backslash is always a float
i can do the same thing with a double
backslash so let's see if i did a is
equal to 7 now and then b is equal to 3.
now if i did a double backslash equal to
b now it will do the same division
but uh it will do a floor function so it
should give me 2 in this case
if i did the same thing
with a single backslash just to show you
the difference between single backslash
and double backslash division in this
case it will give me
the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment um say a is equal to say 5
now b is equal to 2 now if i do a
percentage symbol equal to 2 i mean the
it should give me it will assign the uh
it will take the modulus in both sides
and then assign it to the left hand
operand now let's see what's in a as you
can see it it did a divided by two the
modulus symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by b and then give me the remainder and
then put the remainder back in a and as
you can see the remainder of 5 divided
by 2 is 1 and we get that over here
similarly we can also do exponential so
if i have a is equal to say
5 b is equal to 2 and i want to raise a
by if i wanted to raise the value of a
by the value of b and then store that
back in a this is how i would do it
so it should be 5 to the power 2 which
is 25 as you can see here so this is
assignment operations so finally we move
on to
uh two special sets of operators one is
the identity set identity operators and
the other is the membership operators
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands uh have the same location in
the memory essentially this does not
mean that it does not check for whether
two objects have the same value and this
is very important so let's look at this
if a is equal to 1001
and b is equal to 1000 plus 1 all right
if i did a is equal to this is an
equality check are they the same values
true now if i say a is b let's see what
happens as you can see it's false this
is because this object and this object
are not the same and this is what the is
operation does uh we can confirm this by
checking the id of a the id of a gives
us some value like this and the id of b
gives us as you can see a different
value so the two objects are not located
in the same place in the memory as we
have seen using the id function and that
is what we check
through the is operator and the is not
is essentially just the opposite of that
so so that is the identity operator now
the membership operator is used for
checking whether something is present in
a sequence or not so let's create a
sequence i will create a list to
show in this example my list is one two
and three basically simple list with
three integer objects one two and three
i will check whether now say two in a so
is 2 in a if it is it will give me true
as you can see is 5 in a it should give
me false because 5 is not in a and the a
not in operator is just the opposite of
that it checks the other condition
essentially so this is the membership
operators in python in this video i will
be speaking about what precedence or
what importance each operator has when
you use multiple of them in a particular
statement or a command this is what we
call operator precedence so of course
there's confusion when we don't know
which operator has presidents over the
other and in python there is a strict
precedence that is followed in such
scenarios so this table gives us the
precedence so as we can see the
the operators at the top are at the
lowest precedence and as we go down we
get operators with higher precedence
over the ones above them so the low of
the operators that we have seen the or
operator the and and the not have the
lowest precedence so
or and not and then we have comparisons
and identity operators such as the equal
to equal to sign the exclamation equal
to sign so these operators come at the
next level then you have addition and
subtraction followed by multiplication
division modulus and flow division and
finally the highest precedence of all
the operators that we have seen till now
is the exponentiation or the double
asterisks so let's see a couple of
examples that explain this point a
little more so as we can see in this
line we have 20 plus then there's a 5 an
asterisk 3 minus 25 and we want to know
like okay what is the precedence in this
case so as we know we have the plus sign
we have a minus sign and we have the
asterisk sign so we have addition
subtraction and multiplication so which
one will take precedence over the other
well let's refer to this table as you
can see the addition and subtraction
have lesser precedence over
multiplication so this multiplication
will happen first so we actually do 5
into 3 first we get 15 after that we do
plus and minus so we get 5 into 3 15
then we add it or we can subtract it
over 25 that does not matter so we do 5
into 3 15 and then we do 20 plus 15
which is 35 minus 25 so we should get an
answer 10 as you can see we do get the
answer 10. another example would be
where we have this plus symbol we have a
double asterisk talking which shows
exponentiation and a subtraction and a
division so again as we know
exponentiation has the highest
precedence so in this whole operation or
this whole expression we first do uh the
operation associated with the
exponential so we do 5 to the power 2 or
5 exponent did exponentiated by the
power 2. so we have 5 to the power 2
which is 25 now we look at okay once we
have that we still have a addition and
we still have a subtraction and we still
have a division symbol and as we know
division takes precedence over addition
and subtraction over here so once we do
this we finally move on to this step
where we do the division of 6 divided by
2 where we get 3 so we have 25 from this
5 to the power 2 which is 25 and we have
3 over here so now we do 20 plus 25
which is 45 minus 3 which is 42 and as
you can see that is the answer over here
let's look at um
precedences when it comes to certain of
the certain
comparisons or
the logical operations or the comparison
operations so as to speak so i have
created a variable called season with
the string summer i have created the
variable age with the value uh with the
string 10. so you don't need to put it
in a string so i have the into object 10
and i have the color uh a variable
called color with the string pink now
i'm going to see in this line uh i'm
going to do an if and else statement so
if you don't know what an fns statement
is just follow along with me so what
this does is if this condition is met i
will print this statement otherwise else
i will print this statement now what is
this first condition it is saying
season equal to equal to summer whether
this variable is equal to the string
value or as we know about the or
operation age is equal to this and color
is equal to equal to pink so as we can
see in our
comparisons
and our logical operations the
precedence for or and not is or is the
lowest precedence uh and is above that
and then not is above that in this we
have the or and we have the and so of
course the first check is the and
function so it's going to check whether
this whole condition and this condition
are
it's going to cover it's going to do
that operation so it's going to do this
and this so is color pink color is
indeed pink okay so this this part is
true now let's see if this part is true
as well now once we're going to check
whether this is true or not what we need
to see is
this condition itself has an or
statement so the first part of it is
saying is season summer season is indeed
somewhere as you can see here next part
is saying is age greater than 0 but this
does not matter since the or function
just needs one of the operands to be
true and in this case this is true in
this case it is also true so this is
this whole statement is true as well so
once we have this statement as true and
then this statement is true
we can we finally move on to we come
back to this and statement and we say
since both the operations or both the
operands i mean are true the resultant
of this and should also be true and
since this is true this whole condition
we actually move into this section of
our ins if else condition where we say
okay we can
do this statement this print statement
and we do not have to print this
particular thing so
our answer should be our result should
be the uh printing of this string this
string okay and as you can see the ok
string is actually what is printed over
here so this is an example on operator
precedence of course it's it always
helps to
you know try to fiddle around on your
own uh
create random expressions out of like
out of the top of your head and see how
exactly python is evaluating that and
try to understand break it break it down
on your own and this is probably the
best practice you can do to understand
operator precedence in this video we
will be looking at the math module in
python and we will look at some of the
math functions that are associated with
this module in python so starting off
what is this math module well the python
map module is an important library or a
feature that is uh designed to deal with
mathematical operations this math module
is part of the
basic python installation so you don't
have to install this separately
to use this math module all you have to
do is import this module and this is how
you would do it you just do import
math and this will import your math
module for you to use in your
programming and in this in the course of
this video i will be showing you certain
concepts surrounding the math module
such as what are the constants that come
with the mass module some of the
arithmetic functions the logarithmic
functions
power functions and even trigonometric
functions that we can do using this
mathematical and the functions inside
the math module so starting off let's
look at some of the constants that are
part of this so as you can see
the standard constants are available uh
in this module are pi there is tau there
is euler's number nan which is a special
it's a it's a programming specific
concept and infinity
so let's look at this one by one so
starting off
our first constant is pi um
pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circle's circumference
to its diameter and pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7 so how do we access this
pi
constant is as simple as this once you
have imported maths uh the maths module
all you have to do is do match.pi and it
will give you the value as you can see
so as you can see the value returned to
us is a float this is important to note
and
the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default uh thing for python that if
you call the pi constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle 3 it can be in n
units three meters or whatever you want
um and you want to find out its uh say
circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is two pi r so
if i had to find the
circumference of a circle in my say my
code for some application with the
radius 3 or all i would have to do is
use the formula 2 pi r and to call the
value 2 pi r instead of specifically
writing 3.14 or something i can just use
this function math
dot pi over here and then i can enter
the r as you can see it will return me
the radius as you can see so moving on
uh the next constant that we will talk
about is tau tau is similar to pi
in fact tau is a ratio of a
circle circumference to its radius pi is
the ratio of a circle's circumference to
its diameter and tau is the ratio of a
circle's circumference to its radius so
important to note this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
two times the value of pi this is by
definition and uh much like pi if you
call the tau constant in
you from the math module it will also
return you a float number and
to find that this is the function that
we use or this is the syntax so as you
can see this is this is actually 2 times
the value of pi 6.283 and even this is
returned correct up to 15
places to the right of the decimal point
and this is by default uh next constant
is the user's number uh the euler's
number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of science in the scientific community
in the mathematical community
you will be using the uh euler's number
probably a lot as a if if you move into
data science or ai or something like
that so what is the euler's number it is
uh it is the
base of the natural logarithm if you
know what the natural algorithm is it is
used to calculate rates of growth or
rates of decay and as with numbers or
constants like pi and tau even the
euler's number is an irrational number
with infinite decimal places
the value of
the euler's number uh in short it's
denoted by the small letter e so this
value of e is
usually approximated around 2.718 so how
do we call this
constant is simply as math dot e
this is how we do it so you get this
value again this is also a float and
it's correct up to 15 decimal places so
the next concept that we will be talking
about is infinity now infinity is a it's
more of a mathematical concept and this
is very important to note because
infinity doesn't is not really a number
there is no number called infinity it is
it is used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive infinity something that
is higher than any known number to us
and negative infinity is lower than any
known number to us um so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this
it might look like a string to you but
this is actually a special type in
python um which is not a string this is
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this uh infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can
you can consider as an equivalent to a
float but um it's not it's not a typical
float that we know like you know three
point one four or two point seven one
the value of mathematics will give us um
inf and this is this inf is actually not
a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when i do a
typed when i check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in python 3.5
a special type known as math.inf um it
returns this inf data type
which is the equivalent wavefloat
so this is this is how we use infinity
if you wanted to get the
value of say minus infinity all you
would have to do is math dot inf with a
minus sign preceding this constant and
you will get minus inf now let's check
if
the concepts or the properties of
infinity are
maintained you know like every a
positive infinity is greater than any
number that we know and negative
infinity is greater than any number that
we know so let's just confirm this
so i'll take math throat in and i will
do a check
is this greater than say some really
large number something that comes off
the top of my head immediately okay so
let's see if it's if this is true then
this is conceptually correct and as you
can see it is true in fact i can change
this number to anything as large as i
want this will be true because infinity
is true is larger than any number that
we know
and similarly if i did minus math dot in
inf uh and i checked some very small
number you know a very very small
negative number so just consider some
minus
10 to the power something right this
should also be true
sorry it should be a smaller sign symbol
this should also be true because i'm
checking minus infinity is smaller than
any known number to us and it is true as
you can see so uh it's very uh also if
you did uh if you did something like so
let's say if we do uh let's add
something to this you know it's a number
so we should be able to do arithmetic on
this let's actually see what happens
when i add say 10 to positive infinity
it actually gives us the same value back
infinity because uh intuitively we know
that infinity plus anything is still
going to be infinity right and this is
exactly what python does for us even if
we add a number to this the math dot inf
or the infinity constant in python it
will still give us uh the same value the
same data type of inf or infinity
similarly if we subtracted something
from the negative of math dot inf you
know um say minus say again let's say
minus 100 so if you subtract something
from minus infinity we're technically
still minus infinity itself so this will
again give us minus and then minus inf
as you can see and this is absolutely
what we need and this is a very very
interesting feature in python uh finally
the last uh constant that we will
discuss is the nan or the not a number
constant so this is not really a
mathematical constant uh there is no
constant in maths called not a number
this is a computer science related
concept that
it's used to
is used to
denote invalid inputs or in it's used to
indicate
a certain places where say a variable
that should have a
number um it's been corrupted for
whatever reason and it it now has a text
or a symbol and our code throws an error
then in these in these cases where
python expects a number from us or from
your code and it does not get it it will
throw you a nan
value and this is usually used in cases
where you have errors in your code so
again just to check like what this this
constant like how to call it this is how
you actually do it math.nan and it will
give you a data type called nan also
much like the infinity constant let's
see what's the type of this um this
constant again might look like a string
to you but of course this is not a
string this is a
numerical concept and as you can see
it's still a float so this is like um
it's another special uh data type that
was created for specifically this case
where uh it's some it's the equivalent
of a float but um it's not really the
typical float that we are that we
associate with so this is a constants in
the math module so our next topic will
be arithmetic functions that we can do
in the
using the math module so some of the
common arithmetic functions that are
available to us are factorials the
ceiling operation floor operation
there's permutations there's
combinations you can find the greatest
common divisor or the gcd and the lcm or
the least common multiple and you can
truncate numbers so let's look at them
one by one so starting off with the
factorial operation the factor of
operation is done using the factorial
function as you can see here actually
defined like this math dot factorial all
right so now what we pass in between the
parenthesis will be uh what we calculate
the factorial for
as you know factorial is so factorial is
always for a positive integer and the
factorial for say a number 10 would mean
10 times 9 times 8 times 7 so on until
the number 1. obviously factors are only
defined for positive integers uh it is
not defined for uh negative values or
it's uh and it's also not defined for
decimal values so let's see let's look
at an example so as we know um so let's
say we pass
math dot factorial for six and let's see
what's the value so
this is exactly what we expect so we
expect the value of six times five times
four times three times two uh that is
actually 720. let's see what happens
when we pass zero
this should give us 1 since we know 0
factorial is 1. now let's see an error
case where we pass say minus 5. as you
can see this will throw us an error
because factorials are not defined for
negative numbers now moving on let's uh
so the next function that we'll talk
about is the sealing function so the
ceiling function is defined using math
dot seal seal as you see here so again
we pass the number that we want the
ceiling for in between the parenthesis
so what is the serine function it gives
you the largest uh sorry excuse me it
gives you the smallest number that is uh
greater than or equal to what we pass
over here so
for an example if i gave you 6.6 and i
asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for six point six it should
give you seven because seven is the
largest integra in integral value that
is greater than six point six or equal
to it obviously if you give the ceiling
function for an integer it will give you
the integer itself so let's look at an
example 7.8 so this should give me the
value 8 as you can see here let's look
at another negative number so minus 12.3
uh an integer that is greater than minus
12.3
is -12 the smallest integer that is
greater than minus 12.3 and this should
give you 12 as you can minus 12 as you
can see here
a similar function is the floor function
which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than
whatever value we pass between the
parent thesis so if i gave it 2.3 it
should give me the value 2. um again if
we pass integers it will uh just give us
the integer itself again just to
reiterate this uh ceiling and floor
functions uh they give you int in
integer values so the floor function
will give you the largest integer that
is smaller than what we pass over here
so let's look at 6.7 so the largest
integer that is smaller than 6.7 is six
and as you can see this is our answer
over here uh the next function that we
will look at is the truncate function um
the truncate function is defined using
this truncate is very similar to what we
have seen this is how we define the
truncate function uh it is very similar
to the ceiling and floor uh in the
truncate function what we do is um we
pass a decimal value a float number to
the between between the parentheses and
what we get back is the number without
the decimal component so only the
integral component so if i give it 7.8
for example it will give me only the
seventh part it will return me only the
seventh part and it will chop away the
0.8 part um if i give it minus 12.3 uh
it will chop away the 0.3 part and give
me only -12 back so let's look at an
example 8.9 it should give me only 8 as
you can see here see i did minus 8 or
minus six point nine it should be minus
six so you can think of truncate
function as
it does the floor function for positive
values and it does the ceiling function
for negative values because it rounds
down and rounds up respectively for
positive and negative values so now
let's look at the next set of arithmetic
functions um let's move on to
permutations permutations are defined
using this as you know so in between the
parentheses i have to pass two values n
and k so i have to pass n n and a k
the k has to be less than or equal to n
because the permutation as you know is
uh the number of ways in which we can
permute
from n objects k
k different objects
so what this mathematically what this is
is
permutation of n and k is n factorial
divided by n minus k factorial so if i
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value
15 150 1200
similarly there is a combination
function and this is a combination of
permutations are used a lot in
probability so if you're going to move
into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in
machine learning ai you will be using
these functions quite a bit um so the
combination function again you pass an n
and a k again the n should be greater
than or equal to this k what this
evaluates is n factorial divided by n
minus k factorial times k factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6 so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section um our gcd
and lcm as we know gcd is the greatest
common divisor lcm is least common
multiple so as of the newest version of
python in 3.0 python 3.9 the math module
gets these two new functions that were
very lately added actually um since i i
cannot show you that because i don't
have the absolute latest version of
python on my system but using the math
dot gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
would do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if i gave these say for
example if i gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the lcm
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst
whatever we pass over here so if i
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the lsim of
20 and 30. so again these are uh it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or
if you have python 3.9 or after that
you will have access to these functions
as well if you when you import the math
module so that was for the arithmetic uh
functions let's move on to the next
section which are power and log
arithmetic logarithmic functions so
let's start off with the power function
um there are two there are uh multiple
ways you know you can actually do a
power function in math in python so you
can do something like this which is the
equivalent of 2 to the power 3 or you
can use the inbuilt
module math and you can use the
pow or the power function which is this
is how you do it and if i had to do same
2 to the power 3 i would just pass 2 and
3 as arguments like this and it should
give me the value as you can see 8 over
here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is
not part of the math module it's a
function not part of the math module but
it's still part of the
base python you can use this as well and
you can do the same thing vow 2 and 3 it
should give you the value 8 again the
now you might ask what's the difference
between these two functions well it's
not much for at least in a beginner's
standpoint it's not that much uh just
note that the maths dot
power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah moving on the
next topic would be the next function
that we'll discuss is the exponential
function which is defined like this
again exponential function is again e to
the power something so if i did
exponential of 3
this would give me e to the power 3. as
you can see oh of course i did not
define the module beforehand so math.exp
now when i do this it should it'll give
me some value which is basically euler's
number or e to the power 3. so this was
the exponential function and let's look
at uh an example so we will look at the
example of rate of decay and we will use
the uh this function in that example so
the exponential rate of decay
for
is used to calculate the amount of
radioactive elements that is present in
a substance after a certain amount of
time so the the
the the expression is uh something like
the initial amount of radioactive
elements that were present uh right at
the beginning times the exponent of
minus 693 times t
t for time divided by the time period
the half lifetime uh so let's just write
it down to make it simple so again as
you can see the uh so this will give me
the remaining amount of radioactive
elements right so let's uh slide down
remaining let's assign this to a
variable remaining so the initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100 um the time let's
assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
half-life
is
around i don't know let's give some
value say 3 or something again this is
the details are not important so this
will uh i'm using the math dot
exponential function over here as you
can see and for these values uh now when
i check what's the value of remaining
after i calculated it it's something uh
so this is it's basically what this
tells me is that i started off with 100
units of some radioactive element
and in 10 years if this is what is left
so yeah so this is how we would use say
the
exponential functions in a particular
example of ours so next the next type of
again
functions are logarithmic functions so
let's look at some of the logarithmic
functions that are part of the math
module so basic log function would be
written like this math.log in between
this i would pass the number that i want
the log for by default if i just pass
one number it will it will calculate the
log of 8 to the base of e as we know e
is the euler's number so let's see what
it does in this case it gives me some
value what if i wanted to specify a
particular base well i would pass a
second argument in this case i want to
find the log of 8 to the base 2 this
should be the value 3 as you can see
over here
there are two specific functions that
are also provided in this math module
that is log two uh what this will do is
again it will again i have to just pass
one argument and this will automatically
find the value of the log of eight to
the base two as you can see here uh
similarly there is a math dot log 10
function if i gave if i did this i would
find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was logarithmic functions
then you have the final you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math uh the square root function is
math dot sqrt
again we pass the what we want over here
if we want the square root of say
49 this should give me the value seven
as you can see finally maybe move on to
the final set of functions that we can
do using this math module they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so
uh let's start off with some of the
trigonometric functions as we know um we
can do sine we can do cosine and tan
some of the basic functions
the way we would do it is math dot sign
in between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular
angle and this angle must be passed in
radians and this is very important to
note we do not pass it in degrees but in
radians so if i say past
sine of
3.14 as we know 3.14 is an approximation
of the value pi
sine pi is uh supposed to be
uh in fact it's supposed to be zero so
let's see we get something close to zero
again since this is an approximation it
won't give us the exact value uh
similarly we can use math dot cos to
find the value of a particular angle um
if you want to find uh if you want to
find the value of the uh sorry the cost
of a particular angle we can use the tan
function in case
we wanted to find the tan similarly uh
we have the next set for arc sine and
the arc cosines of
the certain of angles so to use to find
the arc sine for example we would use a
dot sine i mean sorry a sine
for r cosine we would use this and for
r10 we would use this the next set would
be hyperbolic functions again hyperbolic
functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the tine calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas
again the details don't have to be you
don't have to know the details you just
should you should know that if you
wanted to say for example find out the
uh hyperbolic sign of an a of an angle
we would use math dot
sine h and we would pass what we wanted
between this similarly if we wanted to
find the cosine it would be cos h uh tan
it would be tan h and if we wanted to
find the inverse of
the hyperbolic inverse what we would do
is what we would do is use a so we would
use a tan h if we wanted to find the
hyperbolic inverse
of sine we would use a sine h and
similarly for cos it would be cos
a cos h in this video we will learn
about conditional statements
and we will learn about how do we create
these control structures
where we have these conditional
statements we will learn about the
keywords that we use in python to create
a conditional statement block the if
keyword the lf keyword and the else
keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in python
so let's get started so the basic uh
syntax if you will for a if statement in
python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this uh pictorial if if there's an
if statement there is a expression
there is this block of code which if you
can actually see is slightly indented to
the rest of the code
and then we have the rest of the rest of
our code after that so what we're
looking at is this so this is our if
statement block now let's let's break
this down so what is this expression
that are speaking of
an expression in this context is a
boolean expression which evaluates to a
true or false statement so when we are
speaking about the if statement we have
an expression and if this expression
evaluates to true then we execute
everything below the if statement
otherwise we skip that portion as you
can see if the statement is true we
execute this statement or these
statement blocks
otherwise if it's false we move on to
the next the next statement block or the
beginning of a new statement so let's
look at an example to further understand
this let's take this if statement over
here as you can see in this if statement
i have this expression 50 greater than
30 so what python is going to do now is
it's going to check whether 50 is
greater than 30 and it's going to check
in a boolean context if this is true
then we can move on to the next portion
which is this but if it is false then we
will skip this so let's see what this
what happens over here so since we know
that 50 is indeed greater than 30 this
is a true expression we move on to this
block of code which is saying that print
50 is indeed a larger number than 30. so
let's see if this actually gets printed
so as you can see we get this the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at
what happens if i give a false
expression now i'm checking if 50 is
lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if i have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed in fact my print statement is
just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in python and this is how the uh
how we move on to how we check for the
true the truth truthfulness or the
falseness of a particular expression in
the if statement so moving on um let's
move on to the topic of indentation in
in python so as you can see
this uh this if statement is an example
of a control structure so without moving
without defining a what a construct
control structure is
in detail control structures consists of
these conditionals or loops or
iterations if you will
so all of these control structures
involve heavy indentation so what does
an indentation mean well what if i gave
you an example say i gave you some
variable called h and i wrote 20 over
here now if i give you an if statement
saying if age is greater than 10 now
it's very important to note that when
i'm defining an if statement i need this
colon otherwise this if statement is not
defined so this uh colon is important uh
anyways so now i'm checking this
expression if age is greater than 10.
now what is this what happens if h is
greater than 10. now what if i want
python to do something only if age is
greater than 10 well how do i tell
python that there is a piece of code
or a section of code that i want
executed only if this condition is met
well this is where indentation comes
into play so if i want say if i want
this line
this person is an adult again this is
some random line where i'm assuming age
is pertaining to this adult all right or
this person so
if i have uh this variable age where i
write this number 20 which denotes the
age of some person and i'm doing a check
if age is greater than 10. actually
let's be specific here well the adult
age for most people is 18 in most
countries so let's see if age is greater
than 18. now if i'm doing this check
i want to print this statement only if
this person is a person's age is above
20 above 18. so
how do i tell python that i only want
this statement to be
executed only during this if this
condition is met well this is where
indentation comes into play and as you
can see exactly as you can see uh this
part this portion of the code is
slightly indented compared to the if
statement so when this condition is met
then only do we move on to this if this
condition is not met we move on to
whatever the next section of code will
be like whatever whatever
code that we have after this if
statement so let's see so this since
this condition is actually met as you
can see this print statement is actually
executed so this is the importance of
indentation now we will see uh in as we
move as we learn more about if
statements and else statements and lf
statements how indentation plays a key
role in defining what we want as an
output when a certain condition is met
all right so for now it's very important
to understand that
this is how indentation is used in
python in other languages we might use
uh we probably don't use indentation in
fact popular language the c language uh
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for indentation and
programming so you might say that
so different people have different
opinions on an indentation the general
consensus is that indentation helps make
the code look very presentable and very
readable and this actually is one of the
facets of python programming is the
indentation and the easy readability of
it anyways moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this
list or let's actually just copy this
example that i have written over here as
you can see what i'm doing in this piece
of code is i have a list x where i have
this integer 50 i have two strings cat
and apple now i want to check a bunch of
things so i want to check if 60 is an x
and i also want to check if the string
cat is an x
and i
want a final sort of like if none of
these conditions are met i want
something to happen so how do we do that
well we start off our state our if
statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have
one more condition that we want met then
we can use the l lf which is kind of a
short form for else if
so we use the l if keyword so it so what
this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is the keyword
used in our block to tell python that if
none of our earlier expressions have
been true then do
what is in the uh
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the s keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is
only we only reach this l as statement
in case all of the other earlier
conditions have not been met or have
come to be false and not true so let's
look at uh this particular example so we
have a list of 50 cat and apple and i'm
my first expression that i'm checking is
is 60 in x so this is how we check
actually so if 60 and x should be read
as is 60 in the list x so is this 16
elix list x well actually no we don't
have the object 60. so this part is not
executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in x well
actually it is the string cat is indeed
in x so we move on to this statement
block which is within the condition that
is met which is print cat is in list x
and you will see that none of the other
statement blocks will be executed
because we have met our condition over
here so if i execute this as you can see
that the print statement cat is in list
x is what is actually executed and we do
not uh execute this obviously because it
is false and we do not even check or we
do not even move on to the statement
because well we have a condition met
over here so it's a one thing that is
important to note is that we can use as
many elif statements to check for as
many conditions that we we want to check
for
but it's very important that we only use
and if we are using that we only use one
else statement and only at the end of
our block okay so moving on now i'm
going to show you a very neat example
about how python actually does its uh
these these condition checkings so it's
very important to note that once a
condition is met none of the other
conditions are even checked for so
we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this if
statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that i have over here is where i've
stored the string cat in x now i have
three um i have three conditions that
i'm checking i'm checking is 50 greater
than 60 i am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and i'm checking i'm some
random expression 1 divided by 0. this
is not even a check this is literally
just checking if 1 divided by 0 is true
or false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by 0. so let's see what happens
when i execute this statement now
typically if i wrote 1 divided by 0
python will throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by zero that is an
error error in a statement so let's see
what happens when i do this actually as
you can see i have a statement being
printed but i have no error even though
i gave a wrong i gave an error statement
in one divided by zero well now you
might ask why is that so well it's
simply because i have actually never
reached this condition i have not even
uh python has not bothered looking at
this because if you actually see there
is a condition previous to this
over here which is met and which is true
so we move on to this block we execute
this block and we forget about the rest
of the code so we don't actually get to
uh this erroneous statement which is an
interesting thing and which is an
example that i have shown
to show you that once a condition is met
in an if statement block we do not look
at any of the further conditions that
are being checked okay so finally um i
have one
one small topic that i would like to
share with you is the conditional
expressions or the pythons ternary
operator now this is slightly different
to the if statement that we have talked
about up until now
in the sense that it is not a control
structure so what this actually is is
more of an operator that defines some
expression so let's see what i am trying
to say over here so as you can see over
here highlighted is the
syntax for what i'm trying to talk about
this ternary operator so let's look at
this example and let's see what i'm
trying to do over here so i have this
variable age all right and this age is
26. now x now just just read this
statement x is equal to adult if age is
greater than 18 else child now i could
have done an elaborate control structure
with an if statement and an indentation
within that if statement and then
i could have written else and then
another indentation and i would have
written another statement over there but
instead of that i have used this
operator to assign a particular value to
the variable x and this uh what value
i'm assigning to x depends on if this
condition is true or false so
as you can see the condition says is age
greater than 18. so if this is true then
i assign this particular string if it is
false then i go to the else statement
and i assign this so since age 26 is
greater than 18 i should assign the
string adult to x and as you can see if
i execute this and check what is in x
you can see adult is indeed an x so this
is a very neat a very needable readable
and a very um
it's a it's probably a more it's a
better looking way uh to perform simple
else uh some simple if and else
statements where you don't want to
create a whole um if stay if if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we let's uh we make a short note
on the path statement
in python so the path statement or the
past keyword is a
a place where is is a placeholder of
sorts so what if i had an if statement
and i'm writing a piece of code but i
don't know what to do with this if
statement so if if a statement is
correct if a statement is true
but i don't know what to do if this
statement was true
how do i tell python well let's just
keep it a hold for now and i might
put something into this block later in
the future well i would use the pass
statement so if i had this uh say the
sum condition again so i'm checking age
is greater than 18 but i don't know what
to do with this i would just simply use
this pass statement and uh this
basically does nothing uh it it's a way
to it's it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future i
might have i might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently i don't have
anything to place over here so i just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is a way where you can use a pass
statement in um if and as statement or
infinite control structures so yeah this
was a uh basic or the an introduction
into conditional statements and
the control structure
of if and l statements in python in this
video we will be doing a small exercise
on if statements just to drive home the
point or the purpose of an if statement
we will be doing a small exercise so
let's first revise some of the concepts
of an if statement so basic if statement
can be something like this we have a
small condition where we're checking if
a variable x is greater than 5 or not
and if it is greater than x we print a
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement else we
move to the statement block now our
variable x has the value 5. now since x
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this multiple
statements we use the l if statement in
such a case so
if x is equal to 5 or if x is greater
than 5 and then finally if both of these
conditions are not met we say else and
we print whatever or we do whatever is
in this particular statement block which
is a simple print statement so as you
can see x is indeed good is equal to
five so this is the block that will get
executed as you can see here now another
example are nested if statements so
nested if else statements are if
statements within if else statements so
let's look at an exalty and the string
is fresh
now we have an integer or a float in
this case 4.0 stored in orange price now
our first statement is checking whether
orange quality the variable orange
quality is it equal to the string fresh
now within that if the statement or if
this condition is met we do another
check where we're checking what is the
price is it lesser than 5 if it is we do
this block else we execute this block
finally if our initial statement or
initial condition is not met we move on
to this else block now when i execute
this what should happen is i will enter
this block because this is true and
finally i will enter this block because
this condition is also true so i should
have this printed i will buy five dozens
as you can see here now let's move on to
our main exercise for this video so this
was all just a revision now we're going
to use some or all of these concepts in
a sample project or a sample exercise
to for your further practice
so in this exercise what we're going to
do is we're going to request the user to
enter a number between 1 and 20 and our
our code is going to check whether this
number entered is an even number of code
the first check is going to be whether
the number that is entered is between 1
1 and 20 we have to move on to the
further checks which is whether it is an
even or an odd number so let's see how
we do that so in this piece of code what
we start with is a print statement
saying please enter a number between 1
and 20 and then we add an input command
this input command will open a box where
we can enter whatever number that we
want to enter
now we use this in keyword to make sure
that whatever we have entered into the
input box is stored as a int data type
in the enter num variable
once we do that our first if statement
is going to check whether the entered
number is greater than or equal to 1 or
less than equal to 20. sorry and less
than equal to 20. so both of these
conditions have to be met if this
condition is true then we have a valid
input and this statement is printed that
we have entered a valid number and then
we move on to the rest of the statement
block within this if statement which is
another set of if and else if statements
if our number is not between 120 we move
to this block and this block prints that
we have entered an invalid number now
once we have say entered a valid number
we move on to this block this is in
if else if elif statement block now what
this block is checking is whether the by
two one leaves the remainder zero when
divided by two so this is what this
check is doing if this check is true
that means our number is even and we get
printed that our number is even the
other other check or the other
uh if statement is checking whether it's
here and we get printed your number is
odd so let's execute this and see what
happens when we enter a number now it's
asking me to enter a number let's say i
enter 17.
now that i have entered 17 as you can
see it's a valid number that i have
entered and the code is telling me that
my number is indeed odd let's look at
some other what if i entered something
else here let's say if i enter 16 now
since it's an even number as you can see
16 is also a valid number as it's
between 1 and 20 and my number is even
and the code checks for that let's see
if i what happens when i enter an
invalid number let's say 25
now i enter 25 as you can see it has not
met and i have moved on to the statement
block so to give you a breakdown as to
when i enter 9 the first check that
happens of course is this check and in
this block is checking whether our
number is divisible by two or not recap
into the if statement and if else
statements necessary file statements the
other video we will be i will introduce
you to the concept of iterations in
python and we will so let's look at what
an iteration means an iteration is uh
executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
indefinite iterations in python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
just like in fl statements a set of
statements where
what happens here is following the while
keyword we have this expression where
this expression is evaluated in and if
it is true we
execute all the statements or the
statement block that is indented below
this file statement now this is another
example of control structure much like
uh infinite statement blocks where we
use a lot of indentation so let's look
at a basic example now of while loop so
let's copy this example and let's see
what this does so i have a variable n
where i am assigning it a value 0. this
is called an initializing process and
it's very important to note that most
while loops consist of an expression
which contains a variable a control
variable uh which
is usually initialized prior to starting
the loop and then this control variable
is typically very modified somewhere
within the
main loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and i am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0. so let's uh move into the loop
now so the loop has this while keyword
as you can see followed by a
an expression n less than or equal to
five now what this is is an expression
which is going to check if it's true or
false is n lesser than or equal to five
and as long as this expression is true
we will continue doing whatever is
indented below this y statement and what
is below this while statement is a print
statement first of all which says value
of n is and it basically prints the
value of n in that particular iteration
and as you can see at this compound
assignment where we add the value of n
by one and we assign it back to n so
what this is uh let's see what this does
actually let's execute this and see what
this does uh important to note the value
of n again is initialized at zero so
this while low five so as you can see i
have the execution of this
particular block of code or this while
loop where i get the
multiple different iterations of this
print statement that you can see here
the first iteration it says value of n
is 0 then it's the value of n is 1. what
i'm doing is i am writing i am assign
i'm writing uh the value of n multiple
times uh and each time the value of n is
written over here based on what
iteration it is so what is happening
actually is
that initially value of n is zero and i
print the statement value of n is 0. now
i add
the value of what is in n by 1. so now
what is the value of n so again we do
this check so after this first iteration
we
come back like once this whole uh block
of code is executed we again come back
to this expression and we again check if
this statement is true so now that the
value of n is actually 1 if this
statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is one now again we add
the value of n by one and again we go
back here once this uh this block is
executed and we check if the statement
is true again and as you can see the
value of n when it's two is still uh
making sure that this expression is true
and this keeps happening until the value
of n is greater than 5 so we do not
execute the statement because this
expression evaluates to false and we do
not do this anymore and we finally leave
our while loop so let's check what the
value of n is just to confirm this as
you can see the value of n is indeed 6
and that is why we have left this while
loop over here so this is an example of
a basic while loop where we check for
this
an expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't we don't
necessarily have to define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use iterables and an example of
an iterable is
the list so let's look at this list and
let's look at this whole block all right
so i created this list a which contains
five objects one two three four and five
all integer objects and i have another
variable a x where i store the integer
one now i'm this while statement now it
might look confusing now it's it says it
says while a now what is a well a is not
uh your typical expression where you're
making sure if some condition is being
met or not but this the way you read
this is while a exists so in the context
of a list as long as a which is a list
contains objects within it a is true if
it does not have any objects within it a
is false so while a basically what it
means is while a has objects within it
and if it does have objects within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we uh do like we
we have this value x where we um we're
doing this this we're printing this is
iteration number and uh we pass x so the
first iteration obviously pass x is
equal to one and then we add x by one
and then the second iteration should
pass this iteration number two and then
so on and finally we have another
statement within this block called the a
called the pop statement where we're
popping the elements of a now as if you
would have seen the list the video and
list the pop statement removes the right
most value
from a list so if i do a dot pop
initially it will remove five from this
list and i will have the rest of them
again if i do pop it will remove four
from this list and then you will have
the rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so that i'll also print the list
a each uh during each iteration and
let's see what happens over here as you
can see what is happening out here is
while a or while a has elements we are
going to continue doing this why
statement whatever is within it so in
the first iteration obviously we have
all of it uh and it is iteration number
one and as you can see the list contains
everything then i pop it then iteration
number two it again has elements but it
has lost its most rightmost element and
this keeps on happening until the list
finally has no elements left and once
element or events the list has no
elements left we this expression while a
evaluates to false and we do not execute
this anymore and we leave the while loop
and again let's check what is in a a
should have no elements as you can see
it's an empty list when i check what's
in a it's an empty list and that is why
while a returned near false and we did
not print any further so this is an
example of using a while statement using
lists
and of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and
this is a broad topic what i mean by
this is that when when i'm saying nested
while loops i'm actually talking about
nested control structures so we can have
while loops within while loops not only
that we can have if and if statements
within while loops we can have while
loops within if and else statements and
we can have if and l statements within
if and l statements so if you think of
all of these loops
and we will even speak about for loops
in the in the in in another video
for loops again are a type of control
structure so all of these are control
structures while loops are control
structures for loops or control
structures if and have statements or
control structures all of these are
control structures and nesting can
happen within them and it does not
matter
which is the like the parent of the nest
and then the child of the nest we can
have a while loop within an fnl
statement you can have for loops within
a while loop all of this is valid in
python and uh it's one of the one of the
great features of python that is very
flexible in this way so let's look at an
example where i have a while loop within
another while loop so i'm copying this
piece of code where i have this list one
two three four five and another list
first and second now my first while loop
i print i print what is pop from a so i
take a then i pop the zeroth index so
basically from the left hand side and i
print what is that all right and then i
have another while loop where i have
this list b and i'm doing the same thing
but this while loop is within the first
while loop and let's see what happens
out here so as you can see my first uh
my first iteration of this parent while
loop causes me to pop what is the first
element which is one then i do these
while loops and this is completely
executed and only then do i go back to
this first one and then i come back and
do all of this again then i go back to
this one and then i come back and do all
of this again and that's why you can see
this repetition so i have this first
iteration and then i do uh the second
while loop then i have the second
iteration and then i do the second while
loop and i keep doing this and this is
an example of a nested while loop okay
so our next topic in this section this
video would be break and continue
statements now break in continue
statements are ways to abruptly end
iterations uh in in a particular loop
you can use break in continue statements
not only in while loop but you can use
it in also in for loops so let's look at
how we use it in while loops and let's
look at what we mean by breaking
continuous statements first of all well
the break statement terminates the loop
entirely so once the break statement is
found
the the complete while loop that we are
using is completely terminated and the
continuous statement on the other hand
terminates only the current loop
iteration and it goes back to the
beginning or the expression and it
checks whether the expression or the the
controlling expression is again
reevaluated and it is checked whether uh
the loop will execute again or terminate
this pictorial that you can see here
actually emphasizes or it shows the
difference between break and continue so
i have this while loop and i have an
expression all right i have a bunch of
statements and i have a break command
over here and i have a continue command
over here so if i encounter the break
command it will not execute any of this
in fact it will not execute this while
statement at all and it will move on to
the next piece of code that we have but
a continuous statement if a continuous
statement is encountered in a while loop
will not completely break away but it
will not uh it will not execute the the
rest of the statements in that iteration
only these two but it will go back here
it will check this expression again and
again we will do this all over again so
this is this small uh difference between
the break and continue statements but
both are used to abruptly end an
iteration in a loop so let's look at an
example of how we use the break
statement so i will use this example
where i have again i have initialized
some controlling variable n to 0
my first loop will check whether n is
less than equal to five if this is true
then i will now in my previous my
earlier example using a similar uh using
the similar example uh i had no like
this this part was not there so what you
got was i was printing the value of n so
it was printing as like value of n is
one i mean zero and then one and then
two and then three four and five but
over here i've included a small i've
nested an if statement and within that i
put a break statement and this if
statement is checking if if n is equal
to let's see what happens now as you can
see once
so when i have executed this i don't get
the whole value of n is zero and then
one and then two three four five i o i
stop at one and that is because once n
is equal to 2 i actually do not execute
this while loop again i do not go back
and execute print value of n is 2 now in
fact i break from this whole while loop
and my while loop terminates right then
and there and that's why you only get
these two iterations value of n is zero
and then value of n is one okay so now
i'm going to show you a neat example of
what happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we're printing
this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
but i've added one more statement where
i print hello at each iteration so let's
see what happens when i do this as you
can see it will print hello after each
of whatever i was doing already now
let's introduce our break statement
first of all so when i do break well
let's
go back to this if statement if
if we check this condition then we break
let's see what happens now as you can
see something interesting has happened
where we have this first iteration
completely being executed but the second
iteration kind of stops where there's no
hello and that is because we have broken
from this while loop before the second
iterations hello was printed let's see
the difference between a break and
continue now so now i have this
continuous statement and instead of a
break let's see what happens here as you
can see it seems familiar to our first
example where we did not have any break
or continue but there is a small
difference that i want you to catch and
that is very important about this
continue uh statement so as you can see
the first iteration has value of n is 0
and then hello then value of n is 1 but
there is no hello and this is because
and this is because once this condition
is actually met we do not move on to
this statement but we go back to this
expression and we will evaluate this
expression and then once we evaluate
this expression again and it's found to
be correct we do everything the same
again where we print hello but except
for that one step where this if
statement was met and we did continue
and this following statement was not
executed and that happens only for one
iteration and that is when n is equal to
equal to two and as you can see that is
what happens over here in one of the
iterations we may say hello and that is
the difference of the continue statement
between uh there is a difference of the
continued statement with the break
statement so this concludes it for our
video on indefinite iterations this
video we will be looking at three
examples where we are using while loops
along with other stuff like say if and
if statements so our first example will
be where we calculate the factorial of a
number in this example as you can see
here we are first going to ask the user
to enter a particular number for us now
this number is supposed to be an integer
once we have this integer we store it to
a variable called number now we have
this you can say this
variable called fac which does one and
you we will see how we are using it
later now we know that the factorial of
0 is 1 that's how it's just defined so
we have an if statement checking whether
our entered number is 0 and if it is 0
we say that the result is 1 or the
factorial is 1. however if we enter a
number that is greater than 0 we must
calculate the factorial for this number
and that is what we are going to do in
this else statement block over here now
in this else statement block we have a
while loop in this while loop the
condition is checking
while number is greater than or equal to
one so as long as this condition is true
everything within that while loop will
be executed so as long as number is
greater than equal to 1 we are going to
execute these two lines now what do
these two lines do let us see so the
first line takes the variable fac where
we had the number one stored and we are
going to store fac times number into it
number being the number that we have
inputted so in case for example we still
we entered 8 then what this will do this
line will do is 1 into 8 and it will
store that back into fac now once that
is done we move on to the next line
where we are decrementing the number
variable by 1 so if we have stored 8 or
we have entered 8 into our input it will
become 7. now as we know 7 is still
greater than or equal to 1 so this
condition is still being met and then we
do this process again where we are going
to multiply fac this time f ac stores
the value 8 and we multiply times the
new number which is 7 now so we do 8
into 7 and then again we decrement this
also once we do 8 into 7 we store it
back into fac and we keep doing this
where we keep multiplying 8 times 7 and
then we decrement the number variable
by 1 and then we check this condition
again so what ends up happening is we
are going to keep doing 8 into 7 into 6
into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1 and
once we are at 1 again when we do this
decrement operation the number variable
will store the value 0 and then this
condition will no longer be met so
number will be 0 and this condition will
be false and we can move out of this
while loop then finally we store the
result into a variable called result
which stores the result of 8 into 7 into
6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1.
this is of course if we did enter 8 when
we were asked to give an input so let's
see this
in real time once we execute this so i'm
executing this the first thing it asks
me is to enter a number so let's say i
enter my number eight as i was speaking
about eight all right now that i've
entered eight as you can see the result
that it gives me is factorial of eight
is four zero three two zero which is
correct and you can check this for
yourself where it will show you um eight
times seven or eight factorial is
basically this this number okay so now
in our next example we will be looking
at how we can generate fibonacci numbers
for this example we will be using bunch
of if and else if statements along with
a while loop so let's look at this piece
of code where we are actually doing this
so as you can see the first part of the
code is basically an input statement
asking us how many fibonacci numbers we
would like to generate and then the user
would be asked to give an input which is
stored as an end into a variable count
now in this
fl statement the first
if statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
fib next if our
entered integer is 1 we just store the
value 1 in this array called fib if our
entered number is 2 we store 1 and 1 in
the array fib all of these are different
sets of fibonacci sequences this
obviously an empty an empty array shows
that well there is no numbers to be
generated in this sequence if we have
one we just print the first number of
the fibonacci sequence which is one
itself if it is two we print the first
two numbers which is one and one now the
actual calculations happen when we say
we want a fibonacci sequence for more
than two numbers now in that case we
move on to this block in this statement
block we initialize the fib variable
with the first two fibonacci numbers one
and one and we store in this very in
this array now we are going to do a
while loop within this and in this while
loop uh we are going to keep executing
this statement block as long as this
condition is met or this condition is
true and what this condition is is it's
checking this variable i which we have
initialized as 1 over here and we're
going to check whether that is lesser
than count minus 1 count being the
number that we have been asked to input
if the statement is true and as long as
the statement is true we will be
executing the statement block which is
basically us appending this expression
into the
array fib now what this expression is
is basically it's going to keep adding
uh each subsequent numbers and we're
going to store each subsequent numbers
back into the
array fib so in this case if you see the
what the first step will do is it will
take the value at the first position of
the array film and it will add it to the
value at the zeroth position of the
array fib and both of these values since
they are one and one when we add them we
get two and we append that to fib so now
our fib will look like one comma one
comma two then we increment this by one
and what we do is we uh do the same
process again so in the next step what
would be what we would do is we would do
two plus one so we would get three now
this would keep going on until this
condition is met or basically until uh
the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many fibonacci numbers i
would like to generate and i will say i
want the first let's say six fibonacci
numbers so i execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is one and one and
then two which is basically one plus one
and then three which is one plus two and
then five which is two plus three eight
which is three plus five so if we wanted
more numbers we would just enter over
here like say if we wanted the first 10
numbers it would give us
the first 10 numbers in the sequence as
you can see here now in our next example
what we are going to do is we are going
to write a program which takes two
digits that represent the dimensions of
an array for example if we want a three
by three array we will enter three comma
three and we are going to generate a two
dimensional array in which each of the
elements of the array are basically the
row times the column position of that
particular element and what i mean by
this is say we have a position i comma j
on the array the value of the
element at that position would be i
times j so for example if i'm looking at
something at the third row and the fifth
column or say the third row and the
third column for example the value of
the element would be three times three
and if i'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column i am
going to do two times four so let's uh
let's see how we can do this using code
so if you look to the right over here i
have a piece of code where i'm going to
in where it asks me to input two numbers
two integers to represent the dimensions
of my uh example my sample array now
once we have done this we are going to
store these uh
these uh
dimensions in the
inputs
in a variable called input string so
obviously when we enter say five comma
five that will be stored as an in in
this particular string or this variable
what we want is we want
five say we entered five comma five we
want five as a separate integer and the
other five as another separate integer
and that is what we do in this
particular statement where we're going
to split up our input string
based on the comma separator and we're
going to store the first part of that
string into the zeroth position of
dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position in
this particular array now
we are going to store the number of rows
as row number and that is the 0th
position of this array and we're going
to store the number of columns as the
first position of dimensions or whatever
we've mentioned in the input so now we
we have this um our results array called
multi-list which is basically
what what our final array is going to
look like and we're going to store into
multi-list and
in this example we will be using for
loops to
do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
uh we have initialized our multi-list
saying that um we're going to have only
zeros in our sample array so initially
once we have initialized this array all
multi-list will contain is a say for
example we have inputted a five by five
array it will have basically a five by
five array with all elements as zero and
that's what this line does once we have
done this we are going to move on to the
for loop portion where we are actually
going to create our
array that we want so as you can see we
are our first for loop is going to say
for row in range row number so obviously
a range will generate a
an iterator which can be iterated over
um and since it says range row number
and say our the number of rows that we
entered were five what it's going to do
is it's going to create an iterator
containing the value 0 1 2 3 and 4. so
for row and range it will basically
basically row will take the value 0 1 2
3 and 4. and a similar thing is going to
happen in this nested for loop which is
within this where we're going to again
uh create a an iterator using this range
function and for the column number once
we have this we're going to do the
simple process of um multiplying the uh
the value of the element based on its
position so if it's at the position
three comma four we're going to store
the value three times four into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for loops we're going to first go by
uh each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example now i'm going to say
i want a 3 by let's say a 2 by 4 matrix
so let's see what the results will be
when i give this as a so what i'm saying
is i want two rows and four columns now
as you can see here it might not be very
clear to you right now but what you can
see here is this is the first row and
this is the second row and each row
contains four columns so these are the
this is the my final array that i get so
what you can see here is this is the
zeroth position and the uh or you can
say this is the first row first column
first row second column and since python
is zero based so this is actually the
zeroth row and this is the first row so
as you can see uh this this value
basically is zero times one this value
is zero times two zero times three zero
times four and over here it is one times
zero one times one one times two one
times three so similarly if i did for
example a five by five matrix what you
will get is five rows now five rows and
five columns and for example like this
particular value is uh one two three or
zero one two three so zero one two three
and the first column so this is three
times one um if i took this value this
is like the fourth row for example
fourth row times the um zero one two
three third column so this would be four
times three which is twelve so and uh
each value of this has been generated in
the similar process so this is an
example of how we can use for loops um
for a particular exercise that i have
shown you right now so this was it for
uh these particular examples into
violent for loops uh i hope you found
the two examples on while loops and this
one example on for loops uh helpful to
you and um i hope it gave you further
insight into how we can use these types
of loops in
different projects in this video we will
be covering the topic of definite
iterations uh using for loops in python
so starting off we know that there are
two types of iterations in programming
definite and indefinite we have already
covered indefinite iterations in the
form of while loops definite iterations
on the other hand are done using the
keyword for
and the basic syntax or the standard
syntax for a basic for loop in python is
as you can see over here we have this
four keyword we have some variable we
have the in keyword and we have this
iterable and
we of course define this control
structure with the colon and then
indented we have this statement block so
once this for loop has started we
execute all of these uh statements
within the statement block as part of
the follow-up iteration so yeah let's uh
now let's to understand like how for
loops work uh exactly let's
look at the concept or meaning behind
what we call iterables and iterators so
so think of it in a stepwise manner all
right so we in python we have different
objects that can be used as iterables
and an iterable is basically some object
that it's it's a collection of other
objects so you know think of your lists
uh think of dictionaries and sets so all
of these are essentially collections of
objects so once we have these collection
of objects
we can create an iterator out of it
how do we do that is we use the iter
function so for example if i passed this
list a if i pass this list a through the
iter function and i store it in some
variable iter underscore a
and i see what is iter underscore a it
is actually a list iterator at some
random memory location which we don't
really care about similarly if i gave a
tuple and i did the same thing i will
create a tuple iterator and in the left
if you can see over here i've done the
exact same
functions with sets and dictionaries as
well so i'm creating iterators out of
these
iterables so as to speak
now what is an iterator well an iterator
is
an object that
yields
values successively so
if my list contained five values or five
objects an iterator of this list will
yield these values
one after the other and that is kind of
how or that is the basis for which we do
we create loops let's see what we
exactly mean using this uh
using another function that we call the
next function so the next function keeps
moving from object to object within an
iterator so since i've created this list
iterator let's just do it once again so
as you can see i've created this listed
iterator iter underscore a now with this
item underscore a what i'm going to do
is i'm going to use this next function
what next function does is starting from
the leftmost object within this iterator
i will keep yielding or keep producing
the values so let's let's just see what
happens when i do next either when i do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when i do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if i did it again it gives me third now
if i kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now i get fourth now i get
fifth now a natural question is now that
i've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if i perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens i get a
an error or and this error is the stop
iteration function error which basically
is telling me
look you have
exhausted all of the objects that were
initially present in this list a and you
cannot you cannot keep doing the next in
the next function anymore you cannot go
you keep going further so yeah so this
is uh what the next function does when
it comes to the concept of iterators all
right so now we've learned two things
what is an iterator and what is the how
do we create an iterator out of
different collections of objects like a
list or a tuple and we've also learned
how to use the next function now let's
uh move or let's come back to our for
loop that we
started off this video with so our for
loop again let's consider our for loop
over here
as you can see some for loop with
objects again one two three four and
five all right this is a list now i'm
going to do for x in a print x and let's
try to see
what happens when we do this okay as you
can see when i have executed this it
gives me 1 2 3 4 and five so i have
first of all let's look at this for loop
i in this for loop i define a new
variable x and then i say for x in a
print x and what's happening well in
each iteration i am printing whatever
the value of x is
at present so in the first iteration it
is the first object one in the second
iteration it is the second object two
then three four five and then finally uh
on its own like uh this for loop knows
that okay now once i have exhausted all
of the objects within my iterator i can
stop doing this for loop and i can move
on with the rest of the code all right
so think of it like a three-step process
a for loop in python the first step is
it calls an iter function to obtain an
iterator for whatever we pass over here
this iterable second step it calls the
next function repeatedly in each
iteration all right to keep getting the
next item from the iterator so it gets 1
then it calls next then it gets two then
it calls next and it gets three and then
four and then five and so on and then
finally the third step is the
termination step is when after we do the
text where we get this
error as you can see the stock iteration
error or exception finally this does the
for loop function or the for loop that
um okay we have reached the end of our
definite iteration or the end of our
definite for loop and this is where we
must terminate our loop and then
continue with the rest of the code all
right so this is how a for loop works in
python now it's very important to note
that whatever we have discussed when it
came to while loops such as nesting of
while loops and nesting of other control
structures is also applicable in the
case of for loops so if i had a for loop
within another for loop that is
perfectly fine if i had a while within a
for loop that is perfectly fine so all
of these are valid statement blocks that
we can do
and again for loop is another control
structure and so we must follow the
concept of
indentation when it comes to writing our
statement blocks within a for loop okay
so now i'm going to speak about in
specific i'm going to speak about the
this uh something called the range
function that is uh quite
you could say it's used definitely it's
used in other areas of programming but
it's widely used in python uh i mean i
mean the for loop in python now
what i mean by this is that um
range this range function is very
important for the for loop and we will
see why okay so let's look at um one of
the examples of using the range function
so what does the range function do is if
i give range 5 let's see what it does it
gives me range 0 to 5. what this
basically tells me is that this will
create an iterator that contains
integers from 0 to 5 so it will contain
the object zero one two three four and
five and we can use this as an iterator
so let's let's look at this uh i have
range five uh let's store this in x okay
now let's do a type just to see what
happens when we do type x it should give
me the type of range as you can see and
this is a type of an iterator in python
now let's see what happens when i do 4 i
in x
print i okay let's see what happens as
you can see it prints the number 0 1 2 3
4. an important caveat when it comes to
the range function is when we say range
5 it creates an iterator from 0 to 5 but
it contains the objects 0 1 2 3 and 4
only it does not contain the object 5
itself okay this is something that is
very important to so
once again i created
i use this range function to create an
iterator from
iterator of 5 objects from 0 to 4 0 1 2
3 and 4
i use that in my for loop and that's
what that is what you are seeing here
now let's use this range function in the
context of something else for example
let's see so i had my earlier list a
right look at my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay uh let's use the range
function on top of the length of this
list a and this is uh like i can't show
you an example right now without any
context but this uh this form of using a
for loop is used is widely used in uh
python programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and ai i cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of uh for loop
expression so you have four
let's say i
in
range
len
a let's see what's going on here first i
create first i do length of a that gives
me five then i do range of five that
creates an iterator between zero and
four right when you do range five it
gives you an iterator of zero one two
three and four as we saw earlier and
this is what we're doing over here we
have created an iterator out of the
length of a list
now when i do print i it should give me
again 1 2 3 4 0 1 2 3 4 of course so as
you can see here it will give me 0 1 2 3
4. and this is a very neat way of using
the range function on top of the length
of a particular collection of objects in
this case we're using the list a this is
something that you will use a lot so i i
would recommend that you get used to
this form of creating a for loop as well
using the range function
also of course um there are
the you can use break and continue
statements as you have in the case of
while loops uh exactly this it works
exactly the same in the case of for
loops wherein the break statement will
abruptly stop the for loop completely
and we will move on to the next piece of
code whereas the continue statement will
break that particular iteration and then
we will resume with the next iteration
so yeah that was breaking continue
statements and for loops uh finally i
would like to show you something about
uh how to use dictionaries as an
iterator or as an iterable when it comes
to for loops so let's create our
dictionary let's go we have a dictionary
already here in fact create this
dictionary again restored in a okay so i
created this dictionary a all right so i
have dictionary a uh what i'm going to
do is i'm going to pass it through the
iterator function as you can see and now
i'm going to just for the sake of
showing you it will show i'll show you
that it is actually an iterator of type
of a specific dict key iterator type all
right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary i
have the key first that has the value
one i have the key second that has the
value two i have the key third that has
a value three and then fourth for four
fifth for five now
a good question would be when i do
iteration or when i do a for loop on top
of this a well what is it going to pick
up is it going to pick up first uh is it
going to pick up the keys like these or
is it going to pick up the values or is
it going to go one by one key and then
value and then key in the subsequent
value
let's see what actually happens let's do
for i in
uh iter underscore a print i let's see
what what is the iterations happening
upon using this so as you can see we're
using the keys
so by default when we do this when we
perform when we create an iterator out
of a dictionary we use only the keys as
our
iterator elements or at iterator values
but of course like if you wanted to use
values all you would have to do is pass
a dot values over here and if you
remember from a dictionary video this uh
a dot values gives us a a list of
or it by it gives us the essentially a
list of
the values in our dictionary so when we
pass this to the iterator uh iter
function and we create an iterator out
of it let's see what happens over here
now let's see what is it underscore a
you can actually see it's now the dict
value iterator at a particular memory
location so it's not the dict key as we
saw earlier it's a dict value iterator
so now that we have this dictiva
dictionary value iterator now let's
print what are our iterator elements and
as you can see now we are printing
values and not
the keys so this is how to these this is
basically two different ways of
iterating through a dictionary one
through keys and one through values so
this concludes it for our video on
definite iterations in python i hope in
this video you understood and you
learned about the concept of iterables
and iterators and the different
functions associated with it and how
exactly the for loop function works
in python in this video we're going to
learn about the topic called file
handling now file handling is basically
needed because so most of the times when
we're handling large and different types
of data in python or in general we
cannot store everything into a variable
and we will have to use files now there
are two types of files that we are going
to deal with they are binary and text
files so binary files are some of the
files that we most of the files that we
commonly encounter like document files
image files video files etc now all
binary files are encoded in a particular
format and they cannot be read by a
normal text editor and we would be
needing certain specific softwares for
specific files text files on the other
hand do not have any specific encoding
and they can be opened in the normal
text editor itself and they are like xml
css html files and so on now there are
four main operations that we can do on
pi in python on files they are open read
write and close
there are certain other operations as
well like rename delete so some of the
most basic operation that we can do is
obviously creating and opening a file
and the syntax is as you can see here
where we store where we use the open
command and we give a file name and we
give a mode and we store that in a
particular variable now a mode is uh
basically telling python how to handle
this opening so we can have a read only
mode which is done by this letter r a
write only mode which is done by letter
w and for there are a bunch of other
modes such as read or write mode which
is done by r plus and we are going to
see them as we encounter them now that
is important to note that what i just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do
for binary files we're going to do this
file handling then we would be using the
letter b in front of whatever we were
using in the case of text files so if we
were doing a read-only mode for opening
a binary file
we would be using rb and if we were
doing read and write mode read or write
only mode for a binary file we would be
using rb plus um so basically just
adding the b in the case of binary files
let's look at a basic example when we
want to open a particular file we are
going to like in this example i'm going
to open some file called
filehandling.txt in a read and write
mode read or write mode and i'm going to
store it in fo so this is as simple as
it gets similarly if i wanted to do it
for the binary file since i'm using a
binary file i will use the letter b as
well in the mode and that's how you do
it here now let's look at different ways
in which we can read from a file and
there are three commands that we can use
we can use the read command followed by
optional number of characters we can use
the read line command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters is denoted by n over here um
and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of
where i'm going to print something
called
so i'm going to take this and i'm going
to do a print on top of this so i have
done first i've opened it and i've
stored it in my file and then i'm going
to do a
a method or a function called read and
i'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that i have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically but now what if i wanted
to open only the first five characters
of this file which is basically this
well in that case let's open this once
again now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and uh try to read the whole
thing again and you will notice
something very interesting now when i do
the read command you can see it's kind
of picked up from where we left off in
our from our previous command and that
is the nature of how
python handles files so if i wanted to
again take the cursor back in such an
example i will have to open this again
and then i use this read command once
again to get back to where i started
from as you can see here now another
command that we can use is the read line
command so let's uh once again open this
over here and now we're going to use the
read line command
over here so what redline command is
going to do is going to each time we use
this command it's going to go one by one
and read each particular line from this
file so in first case it will take
artificial intelligence then data
science big data and so on so as you can
see if i execute this it first takes
artificial intelligence now if i did
this command again
it will say data science next time if i
do it it should say big data as you can
see here okay so this is the read line
command now within the read line command
also we can enter uh characters and that
will tell us basically um that we want
these number of characters from the next
line so if i want the first six
characters of the next line i will say
six i will enter six here and it will
give me the first six characters of this
particular line which is the next line
that is to come as you can see here now
another way in which we can
print whatever is there in our file line
by line is by using a for loop so again
i'm going to open this file i'm going to
store it here now i'm going to use a for
loop saying that well uh for line in my
file and what this does is basically at
each each iteration it's going to take
each line and store it in this variable
that we end over here which is called
line itself and we're going to print
that at the end of the loop what we'll
have is all of the lines have been
printed one by one and another thing
that we can do right now is um say we
want to read a particular line say i
wanted you to read the
fifth line of my file i can use this
technique where um i just say okay i'm
gonna store five in this variable called
line number and i have this um another
variable called current line which i'm
going to initialize with one and i'm
going to any i'm gonna what i'm going to
do is i'm going to
do the same loop where i'm going to say
4 line in my line but i'm going to add a
condition saying that only if current
line when it's equal to line number am i
going to print the line and then i'm
going to break out of this whole thing
and at the end of each
loop i'm going to say current line is
going to be incremented by 1 until
basically these two variables are equal
so when i do this i get my result which
is machine learning which is the fifth
line of
my which is the fifth line of whatever
file i had now we're going to move on to
the topic of
image file handling so we we saw how we
handled and we we saw certain operations
around
text files um and text files obviously
something that we're going to use a lot
but we are also going to be using files
such as images a lot and let's uh look
at certain examples and certain
use cases around image file handling so
my first step is going to be importing a
bunch of modules and packages now the
details of these modules and these
packages are not important as of right
now because they will be covered in a
future video
but just keep a note of some of these
packages such as
they say numpy and
image the image
package so once i've done this let's
move on to my example so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to store certain file
locations in two variables so it's
basically two strings uh i've attached
the of this prefix r to say that this is
a read-only
sort of a prefix so the next topic that
we're going to be handling is image file
handling now we have already seen many
examples pertaining to text files so
text files are obviously something that
we're going to be using a lot but image
file handling is something
very important as well and we're going
to see certain operations that we can do
around image file handling so starting
off i'm going to import a bunch of
packages and modules what these packages
exactly are and what these modules
exactly are are right now not of that
important i'm not not that important to
you right now but it's something that
will be covered in a future or in future
videos uh it's important to just keep
note of what these are such as numpy and
image so once i've done that what i'm
going to store is i'm going to store two
particular file locations into variables
location one and location two and i've
prefixed them with r just to say that
these are raw strings so once i've done
that i'm going to use the image
from the image package i'm going to say
open and i'm going to say open from this
particular location in this particular
location and i'm going to store these
image images in im1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file
opening now once we have done this
we can access certain properties of this
image using say format which tells us
the format of the file
it attributes the it identifies the
source of an image and if the image is
not read from a file it is set to none
we can also see the size of the file
using the size attribute and we can see
the mode which basically defines the
number and names of the bands in the
image and also contains the pixel type
and depth certain common modes are like
l for luminescence rgb for true color
images and cmyk for prepress images so
let's look at them so when i
access this you can see my first file is
of jpeg of this size and an rgb format
image and my second image is another
jpeg slightly bigger image and again rgb
now we uh can also of course display
these images and to do that we can use
the plt um again plts the is supposed to
stand for a matplotlib dot pi plot it's
a particular for a particular package
that again you don't need to know the
details of right now but this is how we
would um do this so
i'm going to use a bunch of
commands and methods such as figure and
subplot and then i am sure
so once i have done this as you can see
both of my images with this being im1
this being im2 have
been produced on the screen as you can
see i can also use display this display
function followed by the name of the
file and this will simply display my
image as you can see here now
i can obviously
save a particular
image using the save function which is
as simple as doing this so i'm going to
save the image as
i am underscore save dot jpg over here
now if i wanted to crop an image i can
do that as well so i initially i stored
the dimensions that i want cropped in
the form of a tuple as you can see here
and i'm going to pass that tuple to the
crop function and i'm going to apply
that on top of im1 and i'm going to
store that to region once i've done that
as you can see so basically what i've
done is i've cropped this image based on
whatever i've passed here and i've
stored it into region and now if i
wanted to see what was actually in that
crop i can just
do the i am show function and i am going
to pass the particular cropped image
which is denoted by region as you can
see here and you can see my cropped
image is basically a certain a left
portion of this whole image has been
cropped out and i have produced it over
here now i can also use the copy
function using it's a simple basically
copy base you use the copy function and
it copies an image onto another variable
that you have assigned and when i use
the i am show function i am going to
show you the copied image which is
basically the same now we can do the
transpose operation as well so let's see
some of the let's see what we have done
here so in this transpose opposite
operation so in this uh basically i've
done a bunch of
operations such as rotating by 90
degrees rotating by 180 rotating by 7
270 and finally once i'm done with all
of these multiple operations i am going
to show you the final output which is
basically a certain transposed image
like this which is basically the result
of whatever i have done before this so
this is it for this video on file
handling i have shown you two slightly
more comprehensive examples on
text files and
even certain examples on image files
however we can use file handling in
different libraries pertaining to file
handling for audio files and even for
like stuff like pdf files and uh this is
like this is just only the beginning and
i'm sure you will encounter a lot of
different use cases different examples
as you continue learning
python programming this video is going
to be the first of a part of a series on
object oriented programming so to start
off with let's try to understand and get
an introduction into what is object
oriented programming well as the name
suggests object oriented programming is
all about creating objects an object is
a group of interrelated variables and
functions variables can be referred to
as the properties of the object whereas
the functions can be referred to as the
behavior of an object so if we were to
treat say for example a car as an object
its properties would be its color its
model its price and its brand whereas
its behavior or functions for that
matter would be like accelerating gear
change breaking similarly if i give you
an example of a dog as an object we
could consider the properties of the dog
as its weight or its name its breed its
color whereas its functions could be say
barking playing eating walking etc
objects provide a better and a clear
structure for a program now let's move
on to what is a class and an instance
now a class is like a blueprint or a
template of certain functions and
entities whereas an instance is a
particular realization of a class
classes are used to create user-defined
data structures and define certain
functions called methods within the
class whereas instances are realizations
of these classes and when we are
speaking of classes and instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates instances on
the other hand contain real data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance think of
a class like a empty form or a
questionnaire now an empty format
questionnaire does not have any
information but it does have a template
to it it tells you to fill in certain
information and based on who is filling
in the information that information or
the data on a particular form will be
different so an instance is like a
filled out form with its own
unique set of information that is one
way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and an instance now for our first
example on classes i will be taking you
through a class where i've defined based
on the circle object so
this class is going to define basically
information about your
general circle such as its radius and
its area so let's go through it now
obviously to define a class we need a
keyword well in the case of classes we
use the class keyword followed by a name
for that class so in this case my name
is circle now after the
colon every every information that is
part of the class has to be obviously
indented as is typical for python now
you can see over here a bunch of def
keywords followed by so something that
you might not be familiar with and i
will try to get you through this so if
you see here you have a def keyword
followed by init and this init is
prefixed by a double underscore and it's
suffixed by a double underscore and you
can see the same thing for str and repr
well this double underscore is called a
dunder and any method these are of
course methods this is a method this is
a method this is a method this is a
method now any method that is prefixed
and suffixed by double underscores are
called dunder methods um these dunder
methods are or can be thought of like
predefined or built in methods for
any class that you define so these we
have like a three dunder methods over
here and we have one user defined method
that we will get to so this first method
that you see here is the init method or
the initialization method and this is
invoked or called whenever we create an
instance of this class circle and what
we do here is basically we pass um when
we create this instant circle
we are what what happens is that we are
we get an option to pass an a value for
a
w what is this
keyword or variable radius so if i pass
so you will see me later on creating an
instance where um i will be passing a
value and that value is basically stored
as the radius and by default the radius
that will be passed whenever we create
an instance for this
class is one um the str method is
basically used to return a descriptive
string for the the instance of
class um repr is not something that you
have to bother with right now and uh now
get area is something that you should
follow because if you see here i have
not used any double underscores so this
is a user
user defined method um user defined
methods are so method that we define and
these are like tasks that we define on
our own so in my user defined method
called get area i will be returning the
area of the circle based on the radius
that i pass to it now if you notice here
the before every
in every method i have the self keyword
before any other attribute so
like this herself this herself even the
get area herself now what this means
self is like an optional keyword that is
used to improve readability of a program
first of all and it's also the function
of the self keyword is basically um
telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking in this
class or the instance of this class has
to refer to attributes and variables
within that instance of that class so if
i'm going to use get area function i am
going to get values and attribute values
and variable values based on only the
current instance of
that particular class self is obviously
optional we don't really need it but
basically the first attribute of any
method is
is basically the is basically what the
mel is is the instance that um the
method is invoked upon so if i say self
i'm telling uh this particular function
that okay all the value that you're
going to get for
performing whatever task you want is
going to be found in that particular
instance where you have been invoked
itself now don't worry if all this is
very confusing
this might be in the beginning but just
try to understand that this is something
that we do for good practice and you
will understand
when 20 yourself when not to yourself as
you learn about object oriented
programming so if you see here my get
area function is supposed to return the
value radius times radius self dot
radius is basically telling um whatever
value i've passed for radius for that
particular instance you can read this as
radius times radius times pi as well so
obviously this is pi r squared which is
the area of a particular circle now let
me show you an example where i am going
to perform some of these functions so if
you see this first line i have created
an instance of the class circle where i
have passed 2.1 for the radius of the
circle so now the value of the variable
radius in this particular instance is
going to be stored as 2.1 and this
particular instance is going to be
stored in the variable c1 now the print
c1 function invokes the str self-defined
or predefined function now if you
remember str was it's basically used to
return a particular string that
describes like what the class will do
and this is something that we define on
our own in our example str will return
the
string saying this is a circle with
radius off and then it will return the
radius that we passed so in this case it
should say this is the circle of radius
2.1 as you can see over here so if i
execute this you can notice this line
this is a circle with radius 2.1 and
this is invoked by the print function
the print basically invokes the dunder
str function which does all of this now
in the next line we say print c1 dot get
area so this is going to print the value
of the what what gets returned when we
invoke the method get area for this
particular instance c1 so obviously in
this particular instance our radius is
2.1 so the get area function should do
pi times 2.1 square and the value is as
you can see here is some 13.85 so that
is the area that we got now if we want
to print a particular radius um we just
say print c1 dot radius so this will
print the value of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance c1 now you might
notice me using a dot whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well anytime that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name c1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the get area
function we say c1 dot get area if we
want to find out what is there in the
radius
key radius variable of a particular
instance we say c1 dot radius now before
we move on let's talk about some of the
naming conventions class names are
initial capitalized so if our class name
is
for example um
like for example if it's camel case well
each word that is part of this class
has its first letter capitalized
variables and method names are in lower
class so if my class was called circle
we say class circle with c being in
capital now moving on let's talk about
how we initialize or define instance
variables now instance variables are
declared within the init method if you
remember from the earlier example of
circle init is a dunder method it's
followed and it's preceded by double
underscore as you can see here now if
you see in this particular
case i have again used the self keyword
and as i mentioned earlier the self
keyword is the first parameter of all
member methods
and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
the init function basically initializes
each and every new instance of um
whatever of our class so we can give
init any number of parameters but the
first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the instance
is automatically passed to the self
parameter in init so that new attributes
can be defined on the object inside the
init method the self.radius basically
means that we want the value of radius
based on the current instance itself so
as you can see radius defines an
instance variable radius and we're going
to use the particular instance and its
value uh of for radius in our variable
radius now instance uh the i mean the
init function is not a constructor but
it is an initializer to create instance
variables the init function also will
never return a value and it is optional
and can be omitted if there are no
instance variables now let's move on to
um class variables so now as we
mentioned earlier all the attributes
that are created inside the init
function are instance specific
attributes and the instance attributes
are obviously specific to a particular
instance of the class for example all
dog objects now if we have a class
called dog then all dog objects have a
name and age but the values for the name
and age will vary depending on which dog
we are talking talking about or
basically which instance of the dog are
we talking about now class attributes
are attributes that have the same value
for all class instances and we define a
class attribute by assigning a value
value to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called circle and we have this
initializer again where we have a class
specific variable called radius which
whose value will change depending on
whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init
init function or the initializer
function if you see here we have another
variable called shape object which
stores the string circle and this
variable is going to be the same and
constant for every instance of
the class circle and unlike the
variable radius we will not have
different values depending on a
particular instance okay now let's talk
about instantiating an object and let's
see what happens when we create two
different instances of the same class so
as you can see here i've created an
instance c1 for class circle and i'm
going to check its id well if you see
the id is something like this now if i
created another instance over here
called c2 and if i check its id well
it's something different now so if you
see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our
memory um and each instance is this is
how each instance is different each time
we create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on the
introduction into oop let's talk about
class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are
usually declared are actually declared
with the
at class method operator or decorator as
you can see here it accepts the class as
its first argument so in this case i am
going to say i'm going to define a class
called my class i'm going to use this at
class method decorator to say that
whatever follows here is going to be a
class method and i've defined a class
method called hello that takes in a um
that uses again self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
um whatever i have
passed to it in the form of hello from
uh self.name now what this this is going
to do is basically it's going to give
out a string saying hello from uh name
of the whatever class we have and um
whatever we pass the attribute name so
oh in this my particular in this case
i'm going to invoke this method using
the class name itself i'm not going to
use an instance name because i have no
instance um in this particular example
and since this is a class method it can
be invoked using the class name itself
so i'm going to pass rakesh and let's
see what happens when we do this as you
can see the first print will basically
give us the information of the class
itself it's saying that the class is
called my class and the second print
statement is basically a string saying
hello from the string name my class with
a
comma and then whatever we passed
initially which was rakesh next is then
instance methods and these are the most
common types of methods these are
invoked by an instance object so we have
to create an instance to actually use an
instance method and it takes the
instance or the keyword itself as its
first argument so if i say class dot
class uh if i define a class myclass in
this example um and i'm going to define
another function called hello as you can
see i have not used any decorator like
at uh class method so this is going to
be an instance method and it's going to
be invoked by the particular instance so
in this case it's going to print hello
from and it's going to basically say the
name of the class again so i create my
instance called my instance1 and it's an
instance of this class and then i'm
going to invoke the instance method by
using this.operator and the instance
name and the result will be basically
this string over here as you can see now
finally we have another type of method
called the static method which is
declared using the add static method
decorator so a static method does not
know its class and is just attached to
the class for convenience it does not
depend on the state of the object and
could be from a separate function of a
module a static method can be invoked
via a class object or an instance object
so if you look at this example over here
i have defined a static method
i've defined hello and it basically says
print hello world so it's going to
basically just print this so if you can
see here i've created my instance and
i'm going to say dot hello it should
basically print print hello world that's
all so
guys this was um this was it for the
introduction on oop in this video we
will continue our discussion on object
oriented programming in an earlier video
you might have gone through the
introduction into oop in this video we
will continue that discussion on oop
with inheritance inheritance is used to
describe the relationship between two
classes wherein one class takes the
methods and properties from another
class in this relationship we have
something called the base class or the
parent class from which we will derive
all our sum of the properties and
methods and the class which actually
derives these properties and methods is
known as the derived class so you can
think of the derived class as a
specialized version of a base class to
explain what inheritance is in a basic
way i will show you an example where i'm
creating a cylinder class which is going
to be a subclass of the circle class
that you might have encountered in the
earlier video on op so what we're going
to do is create a cylinder class that is
a subclass of circle where we're going
to get the attributes radius and get
area from circle class and we're going
to add the attributes height and get
volume to the cylinder so right off the
start you can see we have our class
circle that you might have seen in the
earlier video so this class circle has
the familiar initialization where we are
supposed to enter a value for a radius
that gets stored in self.radius now we
also have a description string which
basically is a uh down to a method that
returns a string when we invoke the
print command on a particular instance
and we have the get area method as well
now if we move on to the cylinder class
you can see that i'm defining this class
with the class keyword with the cylinder
name but you can see that i have added a
parenthesis and within it i have
mentioned the name of the superclass
that i want the cylinder class to be a
subclass of so this is how we actually
define a subclass in the most basic way
you enter the name that you want and you
enter the name of the superclass that
you want the subclass to be if a
subclass of in parenthesis right after
the name now next if you move on to the
dunder initialization um the
initialization is very familiar familiar
except now we have another attribute for
height which has a deep default value of
1 just like the radius so this basically
means that we have an option of entering
two different attributes for our
cylinder instances now if you see here
there's a line which says super dot init
now this is like um this is a command
which we use to invoke the super classes
initializer so anytime we create an
instance for cylinder we also want an
initialization for the circle method as
well as a part of our cylinder instance
next you can see that um much like how
we stored self uh i mean the radius
attribute in self.radius we're also
storing the height attribute in
self.height now even this uh cylinder
class has an str method to return a
particular string if we use this print
function and finally we get on to a more
a new method that we have defined only
for this render class called get volume
now
if you see the get volume it returns as
basically the volume of
the cylinder that is being described in
the particular instance for which we
enter the height and the radius so if
you can see here
what we basically added extra is an a
height attribute and another method
called get volume and the other parts of
the circle superclass such as radius and
gate area are also going to be a part of
cylinder even though you do not
explicitly see them anywhere here and we
will see how in the form of an example
that's coming up so let me just execute
these classes now that that's done i'm
going to create an instance for cylinder
i'm going to store it in cy1 and i'm
going to pass 1.1 for the radius and 2.2
for the height and once that is done
let's just print um to invoke the hdr
method and as you can see the sdi method
basically tells us the information that
is a cylinder with radius 1.1 and height
2.2 so now let's print what is the value
we get when we use the get area method
now it's important to note get area was
not explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle superclass and we can
see that we can actually access methods
that are part of the superclass simply
by
accessing any other method so if you use
the dot get area you can see that we get
a value for the area of the cylinder so
this basically this area is basically
the area of the circle face of the
cylinder uh the top or the bottom now
let's use now let's invoke
the subclass specific method which is
the get volume method in a similar
manner as you can see just by
doing invoking this method we get the
volume as well now
if we want to see what is the radius and
the height we can just do a simple print
statement followed by cy1 dot radius
c11.height and it gives us both of these
values as you can see here now over here
what i'm going to do is create another
instance of cylinder but i'm not going
to pass anything for radius or height so
basically it's going to take the default
values for radius and height which was
one and one respectively so once i print
um this is this statement is basically
going to print the sdr method or
whatever we stored in the str which is
basically the description of the object
followed by what is its radius and
height uh this method will give us the
area and this method will give us the
volume so once i execute this as you can
see here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so now in this
example what i'm going to show you is uh
now i'm going to go back and i am going
to create another instance for circle
now this is the super class of course
and i'm going to give it and since the
super class has only one option uh one
attribute that we can enter which is for
the radius so i pass 3.3 and i'm going
to print what what happens when i just
print uh this instance it's going to
basically give us whatever was uh a part
of the htr method uh after that i'm
going to print is instance this is
basically a check on whether c1 is an
instance of this class circle and x i'm
going to check if c1 is an instance of
its subclass cylinder now when i execute
this you can see that well this is what
we
this is the str method that gets printed
but if you see here um you can see that
it says c1 is indeed a an instance of
circle when it says true over here but
when we look at the next line is c1 in
instance of cylinder it says false and
this is obviously because um a
superclass object is never
an instance of a subclass object well as
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and hybrid
inheritance so we will go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one base class and
one derived class from that base class
so this is a simple
single inheritance and in this example
you can see i have a class called
country where i have a method that i've
defined called show country which is
basically going to say print this is
india it's basically going to print this
every time we invoke this show country
method then we have a class called state
which derives
from the
super class called country where we have
a method called show state which is
going to say print this state every time
so you can see i created an instance of
the class state and i'm through that
instance i can access the super class
and the subclass methods over here next
we have the multi-level uh sorry
multiple inheritance and this is when a
derived class contains more than one
base class so let's look at an example
to understand this so if you can see
here i have a class called student with
the two methods defined called method
one and method two in method one we can
pass uh two attributes sn s o or i think
is this this is supposed to be like uh
an id i guess like s number and we have
s name so this is basically two
attributes we can pass um that are
probably descriptors for a student and
um in the next method you have basically
two print statements which says student
number and then they will print the
student number and uh it will also print
the student name um next we have a class
called marks this is also um so these
these two classes are basically what our
super classes are going to be and we're
going to derive a third class from these
two so this second class is a class
called marks and we have two uh methods
again one method is called set marks
which has um the option of putting in
two attributes m1 and m2 both are
representative of the two marks and we
store them in self dot mark 1 self talk
mark 2. the second method is put marks
which is going to print the marks
namely mark 1 and then it's going to
tell us how much marks are there in the
first subject for example and another
print statement doing the same thing for
the second subject or mark two finally
we have a third class called a result
which derives from two classes marx and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis i've passed in marks and
student both are super classes and our
class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result i have
two methods specific to this derived
class called calc
wherein i'm going to basically calculate
the two the total marks of um
uh the the total marks which is
basically the addition of mark one plus
mark two and i'm then i'm going to have
another method called put total which is
going to print me what is the total so
if you can see here i have created an
instance of this derived class called a
result and i'm storing it in r then i'm
going to access method one which is
obviously a method from the first
superclass called student um and i'm
going to store okay so that his
name is i guess lucky and he has 60
marks uh secondly then i'm going to do
our set marks which is the method from
the second super class which is going to
set the marks uh respectively so you
have lucky student and his id is 60 and
he has got 50 and 60 marks respectively
in say the first two subjects and
finally i'm going to access the derived
class method called calc so this is
going to do the sum uh finally i'm going
to also do our method 2 which is going
to print our student number and student
name next we're going to have put marks
which is going to tell us the um what
are the individual marks for mark 1 and
mark 2 and then finally we're going to
print the total marks with the put total
so once i execute this you can see here
it says student number 60 student name
lucky marks one is 50 as i had written
here marks 260 as i passed here and then
total is 110 which is basically 50 plus
60. our next type of inheritance is
called multi-level inheritance now
multi-level inheritance can be assumed
as where you take a super class let's
call it a and you derive a class b from
that class a now what if we derived a
class c from b and we kept doing this so
until say our class e now each of these
steps is uh in its own an inheritance
but this whole relationship can be
described as a multi-level inheritance
so let's take an example again so i've
got this this time i've defined a class
called student where i have defined two
methods called set stud and put stud or
you can call it set student and put
student in my first method i have two
options of adding two attributes again
this is the student number this is the
student name in my second method i am
going to print what is the student
number and what is the student name
finally uh so sorry next we have another
class called marx which derives from the
first
class called student this has two
methods called set marks where i'm going
to again get the option of adding two
integers for m1 and m2
which is going to represent mark 1 and
mark 2 and finally i have put marks the
method which is going to print mark 1
and mark 2.
finally i have another class called
result and this if you see
this derives from marks now if you see
this relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and uh
even as a part of this third class we
have its own uh methods called calc and
put total um calc will calculate the
total as we had seen earlier and put
total will basically print that total
and we're going to do a very similar
operation we're going to create an
instance of this third class uh result
and store it in r um then we're going to
do basically we're going to set the
student details uh his uh student number
and his name we're going to give him his
marks 50 and 60. we're going to
calculate what are the total we're going
to say okay now put the details of what
is the student's number and name we're
going to also store enter i mean display
his marks mark 1 and mark 2 and finally
we're going to display the total marks
so let's execute this and if you see
it's basically the similar operation
that we did earlier but the only
difference is in the earlier example our
our third class result was derived from
marx and student together so this was an
example of multiple inheritance whereas
in this example the result class derives
from marks and marks itself derives from
students so this is an example of
multi-level inheritance finally we have
um sorry not finally penultimately we
have as our fourth example of uh
inheritance called a hierarchical
inheritance apart in my mispronunciation
it's hierarchical inheritance so in this
case a base class basically will contain
more than one derived class so let's see
a look at an example of what we mean
here so i have a class called one where
i have defined a method called display
where what i'm going to do is i'm going
to store self.x is equal to 1000 and
self.y is equal to 2000. then what i'm
going to do is i'm going to print a
statement saying this is the method in
class 1 and i'm going to say
after that i'm going to print another
statement saying value of x is a self.x
which is going to be 1000. uh then i'm
going to have another print statement
saying value of y is self.y which is
going to be 2000. finally um i mean next
i have another class called 2 this this
is going to derive from class 1 as you
can see here and in this class 2 i have
defined another method called add and in
this method add what i'm going to do is
i'm going to first print a statement
saying this is the method in class 2 and
then i'm going to actually print the
result of x plus y which is 1000 plus 2
000. finally i have another class called
3 and this is also deriving from 1. so
if you notice we have one parent class
called one and from this one parent
class we're going to derive two
different subclasses called two and
three so this is an example of
hierarchical inheritance now in this
class three what i've done is i've
defined a multiplication method what i'm
going to do is print first of all i'm
going to print this when i invoke this
method that this is the method in class
3 finally i'm going to say uh i'm going
to print the result of x times y which
is 1000 times 2000 so if you see i am
going to create an instance of 2 and i
am going to create an instance of 3 and
i am going to store them in t1 and t2
now since uh t2 i mean t1 is an instance
of 2 so i can access its methods add and
i can access this methods display so i
am going to use t1.display and even in 2
t2 i mean since it's a class
it's an instance of class 3 and this
also derives from class 1 i can also
access its method display but now i
cannot access add but i can access
multiply so if you see here i access add
through t1 instance since add is a part
of class 2 whereas multiply
is a method in class 3 so i access it in
its respective instance which is t2 so
if you see here now once i execute this
what you will get is basically
the results so first of all it will
basically display the method from
class 1 which is the display method it
will display the values of x and y and
since i've done this twice from two
different instances it will basically
show a repetition over here finally i've
done the addition and since this is a
method in class 2 it is going to say as
much that is a method in class 2 and
then it's going to say x 5 is 3 000. and
now multiply is a method in the third
class so it's going to say this is a
method in class 3 and it's going to tell
me what is the multiplication result
finally we have what is called hybrid
inheritance and this is a combination of
multiple plus multi-level inheritance
that you saw earlier so let's again
understand this through this example so
we have a class called student where we
have a method called set student um
again two attributes we can pass here
for student number and student name next
we have a another method part of the
class student called put student so this
will print us the student number and
student name next we have a class called
marks and this marks inherits from
student so
we have a method in class marks called
cell set marks where we can pass two
attributes for mark 1 and mark 2
respectively and as we had saw seen
earlier we also have a put marks which
will display the marks for marks one and
marks two we have a class called
practical
the spectacle is basically a another
super class if you see here since this
does not derive from anything it is
super class on its own and what it does
is it uh it has two methods get
practical
and we can uh pass an attribute for p1
here and we store that in self.p1 and
then we have an attribute for
put practical which will print us the
practical mark whatever we passed for
this attribute in p1 finally if you see
we have a class called result now in
this result we have we are going to
derive from marks and practical but if
you notice here marx itself is a
subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result derives from marks
and practical both it is also an example
of multiple inheritance so if you see
notice here this is an example of
multiple and multiple level inheritance
which is basically what we call hybrid
inheritance and as we had seen earlier
this result class will have a calc
method to
do a total of the marks um in this case
mark one plus mark two plus the
practical mark p1 and we have a put
total method which is basically going to
print us the total so now we're going to
create an instance of this result and
through this instance of result we're
going to first invoke the parent class
method called set student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student the student class
said student method so we're going to
set student here we're going to say 60
is a student id and name is ash then we
have set marks which is again the
the second level parent which is a
student class where we set the marks
finally we access this get practical now
if you notice get practical is part of
the practical super class so in this we
store the third subject or the the
practical marks hundred then we
calculate the total and we put uh first
the student details then we put the
individual marks then we put the
practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number is 60 student name and
all the basically whatever details we
wanted um is shown over here in this
video we will continue our discussion on
object oriented programming with the
topic of polymorphism now the term
polymorphism in oop refers to the
ability of an object to adapt the code
to the type of data it is processing
polymorphism is one of the key concepts
of python and it is also a built-in
feature of python an example to get us
started on polymorphism would be how we
use the plus operator we use the plus
operator not only for arithmetic
additions but we also use the plus
operator for stuff like string
concatenations or joining two lists
together this example where we are able
to use the plus operator for different
different operations is an example of
polymorphism to show you what i mean i
have basically done a simple addition
operation here where i'm adding two
variables number one and number two when
i do it on integers it basically adds
one plus two now when i use it on two
strings str1 and str2 which contains
python and programming two separate uh
strings and when i use the plus operator
on these you can see what it does here
it forms um one string containing both
of these individual strings so this is
basically the plus operator showing
polymorphism and is one of the simplest
occurrences and yet most common
occurrences of polymorphism in python
another example of polymorphism would be
through the lens function the lens
function in python is something that we
use a lot and over multiple data types
depending on the data type that we use
the length function for we get a
different value or a different
sort of information from the length
function now if you see here from this
diagram when we use the length function
on a string it gives us the length of
the string when we use the length
function on a list it gives us the
number of items whereas if we use the
length function on a dictionary it gives
us the number of keys so this is well
another example of how we have
polymorphism in a function now what we
are going to do is look at the different
techniques through which we can enable
polymorphisms in our code our first
example that we are going to look at is
through method overloading now method
overloading in its traditional sense
where we can have a method with the same
name
more than one method with the same name
in the same class is
not exactly possible in python so if we
have multiple methods with the same name
in a class in python which may differ in
uh in types and number of arguments are
not allowed and not supported in python
in fact if we did something like this
where we created a method with
different uh with different say types
and number and arguments but having the
same name
in the same class then what python will
do is it will only recognize the the
last defined method and it will
not recognize any of the earlier methods
with the same name but we can simulate
polymorphism through method over
overloading by using default arguments
in a method now for example what i'm
going to show you here is an example
where i have a method called sum now by
default uh it has three attributes that
you can pass through this method a
does not have a default value b does not
have a default value but if you notice c
has a default value zero so this is a
simple example where i'm going to show
you that the sum method is
going to be used in two different cases
in one case we're going to simply add
two digits uh i mean two numbers and in
another case we're going to use the sum
method to add three different numbers so
we have this class overload demo within
it a method sum and i have three
attributes a and b are
have are supposed to be given by the
user since they don't have a since they
do not have any default values whereas c
has a default value of zero so if you
see here in my first case i have uh i
first of all created an instance called
over an instance called od for the class
overload demo and i have uh what i'm
going to do is i'm going to store the
value of the sum of 7 and 8 in the
variable sum now if you see here i have
not passed a third argument so what this
method is going to do is it's going to
take the value of c as 0 by default so
it's basically going to do
seven plus eight and it's going to give
us the sum for seven plus eight and in
the next instance i'm going to give
three arguments seven eight and nine so
now c will be replaced by nine instead
of zero and then i'm going to get the
sum of seven eight and nine so in this
this is not a very use
not a very commonly used thing uh but
it's basically a method just to show you
that we can actually simulate method
overloading in python uh by using
default arguments so i've basically
shown you how the same how the same
method sum has been used to
do the addition of two digits and in
another instance is doing the addition
of three digits it might look very
similar but
you'll basically notice that by having
this third attribute c i have a default
value of zero i have induced some form
of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already
in one of its superclasses now if there
is a method in a superclass the method
having the same name and same number of
arguments in a child class
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
chat class will be executed and executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate
overridden method is called
is called based on the object type which
is an example of polymorphism so let's
look at an example to understand this so
we have a class called person and we
have defined uh what we're going to
define the initializer is two attributes
which we have to pass called name and
age and we're going to store them in
self self.name and self.h now we have a
user defined method called displaydata
where we are going to print if this
display data has been called through the
parent called person um if it's going to
be called through the parent class
object then we're going to print in
parent class display method and then
we're going to print the name and age
that we have entered now we have another
uh class called employee which is going
to be a derived class 1 person so it's
going to um so it's also going to have
an a an initializer and this constructor
will basically um what what this
initializer will have is it'll have an
uh constructor for the superclass where
we're going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the
superclass but we're also going to store
another attribute called id in self dot
employee id and if you see here we also
have another method called display data
which is the same name method from
person but now if you see in display
data i have every i have all the same
almost the same information i'm going to
print the name i'm going to print the
age but if you see the first statement
i'm going to say if i'm going to call
this method from the employee object
then i'm going to say in child class
display data method instead of in parent
class display data method to say that
basically i'm invoking this method from
the child class object and i'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
i'm printing before i'm also going to
print the employee id so if you see here
i have created an object called person
which is
an object of the class person with the
information of name john and age 40 and
then i'm going to display this now next
i'm going to create an object called emp
which is the child class employee object
which is going to now have the same
information of john for the name and age
40 but now is going to have an employee
id and then i'm going to store this uh
in amp and i'm going to display the data
for this child class object and we will
see the difference in how the display
data is differing from the earlier
earlier case so when i execute this you
see the in the first case it says in
parent class display data method so this
display data has been called through the
parent class object and i'm only going
to show the information of name and age
whereas when i invoke this method from
the employee class object it's going to
say it's going to specifically say that
it's a in child class display method and
then i'm going to say the name age and
also the employee id over here so this
is the difference between how display
data has been used in its parent and its
child class and this is basically the
example of method overriding now our
next example of polymorphism uh is going
to be through operator overloading and
operator overloading is the ability to
overload the operator to provide extra
functionality in additional to its real
or core operation and operator
overloading is also an example of
polymorphism as the same operator can
perform different actions the earlier
example of where we use the plus
operator for different operations is an
example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when um when when is
operator overloading required well
anytime you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects you would basically do
operator overloading now an example of
this would be what i'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point it has an initializer where i'm
going to store two attributes x and y in
sub dot x and y and septa uh instead dot
x and self dot y now i'm going to create
one object called p1 where i'm going to
create point one and two so you can
think of this object as basically like a
coordinate x coordinate one y coordinate
two this is one point and another point
called uh x coordinate three x one four
i'm going to call that p two now i want
to print p one plus p two all right now
if i try to execute this you will notice
an error it says unsupported operand
types for plus point and point this
basically means that plus does not know
what to do when it's given an object of
this type it has no idea what to do
whereas what we wanted to do is add the
the the x coordinate from this point and
the x coordinate from this point so we
wanted to do one plus three and we also
wanted to do this y coordinate plus this
y coordinate or two plus four and then
we want to print basically like
something like four comma six or the
addition of the two points
or the the vector addition of these two
points so this is what we want this plus
operator to do but the python does not
have any inbuilt feature for the plus
operator and we are going to have to
basically do some operator overloading
to create a polymorphism on this so
let's see how we can do that so to do
that first of all we have to understand
that all operators in python have
internally defined methods to provide
functionality for these operators the
operator or the special method to
provide functionality for the plus
operator in python is the add method and
whenever the plus operator is used we
are basically internally internally
invoking the add method so uh these
these sort of internal methods that
provide functionality for the operators
are part of a bigger class of methods
known as magic methods and these magic
methods are automatically invoked
whenever its corresponding operators are
used so we want to change the or the
operation for
the plus operator in this example we are
going to have to use the the add method
in this case and since it's a magic
method uh magic methods are also
are basically what we saw earlier in the
in the form of dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double underscore uh a prefix and suffix
to it so similarly to how we defined an
init of an init method or an hdr method
we're going to also invoke the add
method using the same double underscore
before and after its name so now let's
see how we're going to do this so if you
see this class i have now my class point
and i have the same uh initializer where
i'm going to store x and y now i am
going to define on uh these this add
magic method i am going to override the
the normal functionality of plus and i'm
going to give it a very specific
function where i'm going to say um for
two two different objects you're going
to add it's
the first part the first part or its so
called x coordinate with the other x
coordinate and it the y coordinate with
the other y coordinate and you need to
return return this to me in the form of
a similar object so now when i pass one
and two and three and four it should
return me four and six as you can see
here i have basically done what i wanted
to do by operator overloading i have
changed or i have overloaded this add
this plus operator using this add magic
method and i have created a new
functionality for this add function for
these two points one and two three and
four now i'm able to add one comma two
three comma four in the way i want it to
so now that you saw how we did operator
overloading i'm just going to show you
um a list of uh similar magic methods
for different operators that we are
familiar with so the plus operator
already we've seen has the add method
then we have the minus operator with the
sub method and similarly we have for all
of these operations such as
multiplication division we have its
respective magic methods these magic
methods are again prefixed with two
underscores and suffix with two
underscores and they are basically they
are also called uh dunder's in python so
this is how we would do operator
overloading in python for whatever
operator we want uh similarly we can do
this for like comparison operators and
for urinary operators as well so look at
this example now where i'm going to
overload the multiplication or the
asterisk operator so i've again defined
a point i mean a class called point i'm
going to define an initializer when i'm
going to store some attribute x and
self.x now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to overload the multiplication
operator where i'm going to basically
allow the uh this asterisk operator to
multiply two objects uh from like for
example 12 and five usually i can just
do a normal 12 times five but in this
case my object is slightly different my
12 is being passed through an object of
a class called point and five as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when i want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we define um
or we overload the multiplication
operator within our class it's now able
to understand what to do um using the
attributes of these classes in its
respective
class instances so it's able to say okay
so i want this attribute from this
particular instance p1 12 and i'm going
to multiply it with the attribute 5 from
instance p2 whenever i say p1 times p2
or p1 astrix p2 so when i execute it it
will give me 12 times 5. similarly i can
also do this for the greater than
operator over here so i have a class
called person where i'm going to define
an initializer where i'm going to pass
name and salary and store them in
sub.name server.salary the
gt method is basically the greater than
method uh magic method and it's going to
uh we're going to use this to overload
the greater than operator and now again
using this greater than operator i'm
able to basically say object one greater
than object two and i'm basically able
to check through this and if object one
is greater than object two it will
basically tell us if it is true or false
or uh basically whatever like we want to
know so basically the print statement
will check for uh object one dot name
and it will say earns more than object
two dot name if in case object one is
indeed greater than object two so when i
execute this you can see here my first
information says john has is earning
4500 some units natasha is earning six
thousand of some units so it will say uh
john earns more than natasha well it's
false because object one is not greater
than object two so uh since 4500 is not
actually greater than 6000 and this is
the check that i'm doing by overloading
the gt operator over here where i'm so
where i'm returning the boolean value of
what is greater self.salary or other dot
salary self being the first
object in any comparison so in the if
i'm basically any comparison if i'm
doing say if i'm doing 5 greater than 5
greater than six so what the gt will do
is this will be the self object and this
will be the other object so this is what
i'm doing over here i'm checking
self.salary with other dot salary in in
the form of these objects and it's
basically the same same way that we we
are able to do five plus five through
these class instance objects that you
saw earlier or twelve times five that
you saw earlier so this is all examples
of operator overloading in python in
this video we will be learning about
exceptions exceptions uh errors that are
raised during the execution of a program
when an
error occurs python generates this
exception that can be handled uh which
avoids our program from crashing python
has many built-in exceptions
however we can create many uh user
defined errors or exceptions as well to
catch whatever errors we're looking for
in our program so when an error occurs
python interpreter raises an
exception and stops the current process
and it passes it to a calling process
until the exception is handled and if
it's not handled the program will crash
um some of the
built-in exceptions are like i o error
in the case when a file cannot be opened
or import error python cannot find the
particular module being imported and
there are so many similar uh so many uh
exceptions that are built in python for
the appropriate cases now before we move
on and see how we raise these exceptions
um let's look at the difference between
an exception and a syntax error so for
that i will be using an example where i
will be dividing something by the number
zero of course this is not possible so
let's see how python handles this
particular problem well it raises
something that it raises what we call a
zero division error and this is an
exception that is built in in python
whenever we try to divide something by
zero now let's look at the difference
between this exception and a syntax
error so this is the same statement
except i'm going to add this extra
bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if i try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error and it says unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma
that basically makes the line unreadable
to the interpreter in the first place so
the the interpreter doesn't even get to
the point where it needs to figure out
uh that there's something being divided
by zero it doesn't even get to that
point because it finds this extra
bracket and it's uh cannot execute this
line at all so that is like the
difference between an uh an exception
and a syntax error all right now for our
first case of how we raise or how we
handle exceptions let's look at
the keyword raise so for this example
what i will be doing is i'm going to
take this variable x all right and i'm
going to store a value 10 and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to check for a
condition if x is greater than 5 then
i'm going to raise this exception using
the raised keyword like this and in case
this condition is met if x is actually
greater than 5 i want this particular
message to play out in my
exception so let's see what happens when
i execute this as you can see the
exception is raised because x is indeed
greater than 5 its value is 10 and the
mirror message says as so that x should
not exceed 5 the value of x was 10. so
this is an example of how we can raise
an exception and as you can see when a
condition was met the program comes to a
halt and an exception was raised now
let's look at another type of handling
exception where we use the assert
statement so when we use the raise
command we waited until an error
occurred and our program crashed midway
right what if we want to check if a
condition is met and if this condition
is met then then the program can
continue but if the condition turns out
to be false then we want a particular
error namely the assertion error
exception to be thrown to us so we can
use the assert command in such a case so
in our example we will be checking um
whether the system that we are working
on is actually linux or windows 32 so
let's see first of all let's import a
library called sys this is the it's a
library which where we can access system
information one of the modules and that
is uh one of the functions and that is
the platform it basically tells us what
system are we working on so we're
working on a win32 system okay so um
let's now let's use the assert keyword
all right now we're going to check if
linux is what we are working on and in
case it is not then we want an error
message and this will be the error the
editor will obviously be an assertion
error because we're using the assert
keyword
so this is how we use the assert
statement and if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systole platform contains win32
and not linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for windows system we won't have
any error when we execute this as you
can see so this is the example where we
use the assert statement
another way of handling exceptions is by
using the try and accept block so this
is probably one of the most common ways
of handling exceptions in python
where we
use a try keyword and an accept keyword
now within the try keyword as you can
see here we have a chunk of code which
we're going to check and if everything
is fine in the try keyword then this is
perfect so we don't need to move on to
what we call the accept part of the try
and accept block but if say there was an
error in the try block then we move on
to the accept block where we're going to
run the part of the code in the case we
find an error in the try block so first
we check the
part of the code that is under the try
block and if if there is an error we
move on to the accept block and we run
that part of the code over there and
where we and in the accept block where
we that is where we handle our whatever
error that might get thrown our way in
the try block okay let's look at an
example and how to uh use this technique
so i have a basic function out here all
right it's defining a function called
linux interaction what this is uh
basically doing is that when i call this
function i want to do an assert check
i'm going to check if linux is the
system i'm working on and if it is not
then i want this error to be thrown okay
and
so yeah let's see what happens in the
case and if if this search statement is
actually passed then we will move on to
this statement so you could look at it
like this if whenever i mean when i call
this function it will first check for
this assert statement in case something
wrong happens and we get an assert error
then we do not move on to this line so
we only get this printed but if this
assert statement passes then we move on
to this line and we get print doing
something okay so let's see i'm going to
call this function out here let's see
what happens here as you can see i get
an assertion error because obviously
this is a window system and not a linux
system and i get this message okay now
let's see what happens when we use it in
a try and accept block all right so now
i have a try block over here in which i
am going to try the same this function
linux underscore interaction if in case
i find an error i immediately jump from
the dry block into the accept block now
you see the slight difference in how we
handle this like what happens so as you
can see when we use the function
explicitly we directly went to what we
call an assertion error but when we use
a try and accept block we will not use
the assertion error because we are
leaving the try block immediately and
we're going to go into the accept block
where the only thing we're doing is
printing the statement as you can see we
are not on linux found some error okay
now what if we wanted to catch the error
within uh this function itself which was
the assertion error and we can do that
explicitly like this so now what i'm
doing is i'm going to try all right and
it's going to catch an error in this
right so now in the accept block i'm
going to say the assertion error that we
found in this function in the try block
we're going to use that in our accept
block so as you can see we're going to
print that assertion error it'll
basically print this statement function
can only run in linux systems as you can
see here function can only run on linux
systems function can only run on linux
systems and the next part of the thing
was the linux interaction function was
not executed okay so this is um a very
this is like um this is a key there's a
key uh something very important
happening here when we use this assert
statement the whole program is actually
getting executed right uh but when we're
using the try and accept block we are
immediately jumping on like the moment
we catch an error we are immediately
jumping onto the accept statement and uh
however and all the handling of the
exception is done in the accept block
and not in the try block anymore so we
do uh think of it like this that the try
block is only to check if a particular
piece of code is
like does it have any errors or not and
in case it does then every like all the
handling that we do is uh in the accept
block of this particular statement now
let's look at another example in this
example i'm going to try opening a
particular file now this file does not
exist so i will be i will get a file not
found error and this is a built-in
exception and i'm going to catch that
and i'm going to print that error over
here in the accept block all right so as
you can see file not found and whatever
like error i have i printed over here
all right so this is another like this
is
a file not found error that we are going
to that we we caught in our try block
and we are handling it in the except
block now let's use let's combine both
of the examples where we use this linux
interaction and we also try to
open a particular file and we try to do
both things in the try block and since
both of these contain errors let's see
what happens when we try to what happens
when we have like multiple errors in a
try block so as you can see in my try
block i'm not only doing this linux
interaction i'm also trying to open a
particular file that does not exist
obviously so now you might think will i
get two exceptions well let's see what
happens when we try to uh execute this
so
it's important to note that in our
accept we have an except for
catching a file not found error and we
also have an except for finding um
the assertion error that that is part of
this linux interaction function so so
since both of these
are erroneous statements or they will
throw exceptions so now the question is
will we get both of these except blocks
or will we get both of these exceptions
will we get only one of them we get the
first one so let's see what happens so
as you can see my error statement is is
very much like the assertion error that
i had that we had done as part of this
linux underscore interaction function
function can only run on linux systems
the linux function was not executed as
you can see that that is the one that
has been caught and for some reason the
file not found error has not been caught
and this is because this is a very
important feature of the try block the
moment we find the first error in our
try block we immediately leave and we do
not execute any of the further
statements and we jump into the
exceptions and we handle it using the
accept blocks so the moment an error was
found in this function we did not
execute this part of the statement and
we directly jumped into the respective
exception that was the assertion error
exception so this is a key takeaway so
some of the some of the other key
takeaways when it comes to exceptions is
a try clause is executed up until the
point where the first exception is
encountered and in the accept clause or
the exception handler we determine how
the program responds to this exception
we can have multiple exceptions and we
can differentiate how the program uh
responds to each of these and it's also
very important to not use uh accept
clause on its own it's very important
not to use a bear accept clause now
finally before we conclude this uh topic
of exceptions let's look at the else and
the finale clause so the else clause is
used when we want to execute a
particular piece of code
in the case uh where we have no
exceptions or no errors found so let's
look at this just like we had the linux
interaction function i'm going to define
a win under underscore interaction and
this is going to check whether our
system is windows or not in case it is
not then we get this error message all
right and in case it is a windows of
inter it is a windows system we print
this in the case of when we call this
function so let's again use our try and
accept statement only in this case we
will be using an extra else clause so we
first try this function in case there's
an error we catch it as an assertion
error and we print that error but if
there is no exception then we move on to
the else statement and we print this so
as you can see our
we have actually moved on to the else
statement and we print this line
executing the else clause and that is
because we have found no exceptions over
here so again it's key to remember that
the else clause is used whenever we want
to execute a particular statement in the
case where we do not find any exceptions
in the try block the final clause is
used when we want to execute something
regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens i mean is raised or if it's not
raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so i have this block where
i'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that i'm doing is i'm going to
check for this linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linux system or
not this is i'm doing the try block now
if i catch an error i want to be i want
to handle it by simply printing the
error over here and in the event that uh
there is no error then i will move on to
the else statement and i will try
this particular block of my statement
which is again that
when i'm trying to read a particular
file that does not exist and it's very
it's very important
that you note that within the else block
i have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and it's
perfectly valid in our program we can do
this so think of it like this i'm first
trying this if i have an error then i do
this and i don't
execute this but if i don't have an
error then i execute this whole
statement which contains its own try and
accept block all right but regardless of
whether i get an error here or not
i will always execute this portion of my
statement or under the finally clause
let's execute this as you can see of
course the error is raised in this try
this try block so we move on to the
exception and that is what is printed
over here and after the exception is
done we move on to the finally we of
course skip this else block because the
exception was actually raised so after
that is done we move on to the final
block where we print this
particular statement well that was it
for an introduction into exceptions in
python i hope you learned something from
this and
of course this is just the beginning
exceptions are something that you will
be that you would probably encounter a
lot especially when you're beginning and
it's something that you will
learn to extensively work with and that
will also help you improve in your
programming in this video we will be
taking a brief introduction into what is
a function so a function in python is a
group of related statements that
performs a specific task or tasks now
functions help break our program into
smaller and modular pieces of code and
it's very good and very
convenient to use functions to make
our code organized and manageable
especially as our overall program grows
larger it also helps us to avoid
repetition and makes the code reusable
so let's look at the basic way of
defining a function so this is a basic
function that i'm calling fun
underscored name all right
now the rest of the function or whatever
the task is going to be performed by
this function will be written over here
within indent of course as a standard
when it comes to python so i'm going to
define this one
something in triple uh double quotes so
don't worry about what this is right now
this is
a dot string don't worry about what this
means and i'll explain it to you just in
a short bit all right
now now the rest of the statement the
rest of it uh will obviously be what
this function will do let's include a
simple print statement
all right let's uh it's done here and
let's call this
so of course now once you define the
statement function to call the function
you just have to use its name like this
this is how you call a function so as
you can see when i call this function it
should print the statement hello now
let's go let's uh look at some of the
like what happened over here so we've
used the keyword def to define a
function we give it a unique name which
makes it uh which with which we uniquely
identify this function
and also once we've done this we
um we can give it we can give this
function a particular header uh it's
called a dot string so what this
docsting is basically something that we
include in triple quotes over here just
after the def keyword and um this is
like a brief we can use this to give a
brief uh info give brief information
into whatever function is doing so we
can say this is
this function performs addition this
performs
subtraction or whatever like some basic
information as to what our function does
so we can use a dog string for that um
of course this is an optional thing this
does not have to be we don't have to
include this as well all right but for
the sake of this let's just keep it here
after that of course the rest of the
function
will contain whatever task we want to do
with it and that will be indented
finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is
at any point you find the returned
keyword in a function you immediately
leave the function you go back to where
this function was called okay so
now let's see um now there's also one
more important
component of defining a function and
that's parameter now if you noticed over
here within these parentheses i did not
include anything this is like an empty
path this is opening and closing what if
i said a if i included some a and b over
here so what this means is whenever i
call this function i need to pass two
parameters a and b these can be like
strings or numbers or whatever um but
now it becomes almost mandatory that i
pass these two things for my function to
uh to work so let's define a function
where i'm going to add a and b so
instead of this print statement let's do
this i create a variable c and in that
i'm storing a plus b all right and then
i return c so you can use a return and
you can you can return certain like
variables along with the return
statement so i'm saying not only return
from this function but also given output
or return an output called c which is
the addition of a and b now how do we
use this well now instead of just
calling the function like this i'm going
to add better i'm going to include
parameters so i'm saying pass 2 and 3 to
function name where 2 will take the
place of a and 3 will take the place of
b all right what will happen now is
addition will take place and we will get
return the result so let's see what
happens now as you can see two plus
three and i got the data the addition of
two plus three and it returned me five
so yeah this was like a basic uh usage
of a function and parameters so
of course um we can if you want to know
like what a what the
doc string of a particular function does
or or says uh you can use this uh
particular you can use this like
statement so let's say
so uh it's very important to like just
keep a note in your uh
while you're going through this so while
you're learning that uh whenever we use
some sort of a function which has double
underscore right this is like a built-in
a built-in command provided by python
within the python library itself so
these are like built-in commands to
check certain details so i want to check
what is the docs string and this is how
i do it so let's do print let's print
what is the docs string over here this
is a doc string so this is basically
what i wrote over here i can change this
to this
like this does
addition for example all right now this
will say this does addition when i
execute this line so this is the way to
check what is a dog string anyways so
now that you have seen a basic
basic function or two basic functions
that i defined for you and how we use
them what a parameter is let's look at
another concept that we call scope and
lifetime of variables so scope of
variable is the portion of the program
where the variable is recognized all
right now a parameter and a variable
that are
defined inside a function are not
visible from outside the function this
is a very key thing
so if you define something within the
function we can only use it within this
function and we cannot
like we cannot use it once the function
has already been executed so as to speak
um
these variables and these parameters uh
have what we call as local scope since
they are only
recognized within a particular function
now the lifetime of a variable is the
period throughout which the variable
exists in the memory itself and it's
very important to note that lifetime of
variables that are defined inside a
function
are as long as the function executes
once we return from a function
whatever we have defined within it are
destroyed so
when we use a function um it will not
remember the values of a variable from a
a previous iteration of a function call
so let's uh try to understand this
example or this concept using certain
examples so
out here i have defined a function where
i'm going to create a variable my
underscore var my variable and i am
going to store the value 10 in this and
then i'm going to print so whenever i
call this function i will always create
this variable i will store 10 and i will
print the value of this all right now
what i'm going to do is i'm not only
going to create this myvar inside this
function i'm also going to create a
variable outside so you'll see there now
you you might be confused as to okay how
is the behavior going to be because
outside the function i have created my
var with a value 20 but inside the
function i will always define my virus
10 okay now i'm going to print so my
first what i'm going to first do is i'm
going to execute this function that i
created initially where i store the
value of 10 in my bar and then i'm going
to pray and print the value of my wire
that was present outside the function
let's see what happens you can see two
different things happening so when i
execute this function it prints the
value inside the function as 10 but when
i print the next line which says um okay
now get the value of my bar
it actually prints a value of 20 and
this is a very key concept because
what's happening here is when i
initially call my function within this
function it creates a variable called
myvar and it prints the value as 10. and
the moment my function has been executed
it destroys this variable and
the variable which contain the value 10
is of course now destroyed and all we
have is the my wire that contains 20
from the outside and when we print that
we get its respective value as 20. so
you can also think of it like this the
my wire that is present inside this
function is different to the my wire
that we create outside so the scope of
the mywire within this function is local
only to this function and once the
function is executed that variable is
destroyed all right now let's look at a
another case or the other side of this
case where
say we're dealing with variables that
have a global scope how do we deal with
them so let's create a variable called
mywear all right and i say i store 100
in this all right now if i define a
function i've stored my let's say i
define a function define underscore say
again same name
where what i'm going to do in this is i
am going to print the value of whatever
is there in my where okay so let's do
print um
value of variable is value stored in
variable
is
okay that's
my where so let's see what happens when
we do this let's call this function
underscore name see what happens here so
as you can see the value i stored a
value 100 in y where and i've called it
inside the function and this is because
since i've defined it outside i can use
it inside as well now what if i try to
change the value of um this variable
inside the function though so let's see
if i did this and now if i try to print
let's see do is this allowed no it's not
allowed in fact i get an error it says
local variable myvar reference before
assignment
and without going too much into detail
what it's saying is that the variable
inside over here is still local to this
function and i have not defined this
myware as a global variable so i cannot
make changes to it within this function
right now and uh to change that i can
use the global keyword what if i did
global over here so if i did global
and now if i said okay global mywear and
i declare this variable as a global
variable now if i do this now if i do
the same incrementation now let's see
what happens when i'm trying to do this
you see i get the value of 101 this is
exactly what i wanted and that is
because i've defined my variable to be a
global variable within this function so
i can in fact make changes to it within
this function so this is how we use the
global keyword and global variable also
just to make a quick note
there are three types of functions uh
the three types of categories in which
we can divide functions first one being
built in functions these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user defined
function that is the ones which we
define ourselves and the third type is
called anonymous functions they're also
known as lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user defined functions can take
first one being default other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say um if i
define the function where underscore
sorry fun undiscovered name and i'm
saying a comma b right but what if um
the user has not um like save i i want a
default value of a and b each time when
i use this function so in the case where
if say i don't pass a value for a and b
like this will always be used so i can
just say a is equal to 2 by default and
b is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function i will say c is
equal to a plus b and then return c
so
i do this and if i say found underscore
name and in case i don't pass any
arguments here let's see what happens by
default i get the answer 5 because by
default a is 2 and b is 3 but this is
not fixed and i can always change this
by passing my own values here 5 and 6
and in this case i should get 11 as you
can see here now the next type is
required arguments and when we are
defining a required argument we just
simply do not use the equal to sign for
the parameters over here and this
basically um it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here so now if i try
to pass like this i won't get a oops
yeah i won't get a default value then
that's because um
that's because well there's no default
value and it needs an a and b so i have
to pass it a three and say four now it
should give me seven as you can see the
next type of argument that we'll be
talking about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what i'm doing in this
particular example is i'm defining a
function called my sum where i'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
i'm doing something out here and what
this does is
it will take the values of a particular
like collection of objects and that's
called my integers and each value i'm
going to keep adding it to each other
and i'm going to result a particular sum
i'm just going to resolve the sum of
whatever is there so
in this case what happens is i'm
creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then i'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me six now the problem in
this case is that each time when i'm
going to perform this function i have to
create a separate list where i'm going
to store these objects but what if i did
i do not know like what exactly i'm
going to pass here what if i don't know
if it's going to be a list of objects or
like what is it going to be exactly well
in that case i can use a variable uh
variable key variable number of
arguments so it's like a variable
keyword argument so what we use here is
um
a specific way of passing um keywords
and we do it like this so i say define
my under underscore name and i use an
asterisk now i give it any name this can
be args this can be integers it doesn't
really matter what this is but it's just
this is the key the asterisk here and
this tells us that whatever we pass here
is now we were supposed to create an
iterable out of this and then we can
perform whatever task we want so let's
just uh since i have already created one
here let's see how i'm going to use it
in this case so as you can see i'm doing
i'm creating a particular
variable argument function over here and
i'm doing the same task i'm just going
to keep performing edit
i'm going to add whatever i pass over
here but now when i'm calling this
function i don't need to create a
separate list as i did over here i'm
just passing all the numbers that i want
to in the form of like it's pretty much
like a tuple so i'm just passing these
numbers here and what this function is
going to do is it's going to create an
iterable out of this and then we're
going to iterate over it as you can see
that's happening over here and i can
keep uh i don't need i i can just keep
like so since i've done it for 1 2 3 and
7 the summation should be 13 in this
case i can add another number here just
explicitly just like this and you can
see the value will change and that's
because this is a variable uh this is a
variable argument
method of
performance creating a function now the
fourth type of function arguments is the
variable keyword
argument so let's look at what is the
keyword argument now so i have defined a
function here called the concatenate
function and let's see what i'm going to
do with this so in this i have passed a
keyword argument i've said that okay
this is going to be a keyword argument
function and what i'm going to do in
this is i'm going to create a blank
string and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to add
or i'm going to concatenate certain
strings that i'm going to pass to this
function so i
in this example i have passed python and
is and cool and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what i'm going to
do in this function is i'm going to join
them together um and i'm going to create
one whole string out of it let's see
what's the result python is cool so this
is so of course like uh if i had to add
some something else like python is say
cool and say i just wanted to say
hello and say one more string i can add
i can add it just like this i don't have
to like define a fixed number of
arguments i can pass any number of
arguments i want and this works exactly
the same as variable and
only differences instead of positional
arguments we're using keyword arguments
over here hello bye like this it doesn't
really make sense but just to show you
as you can see so this is how we use
keyword arguments well this is it for um
this introductory video into functions
in python i hope you uh learned a bit
about defining functions and so the
keywords and the components that
are part of function definitions such as
keywords and
i mean arguments and
dog string for example you also saw the
different types of arguments that we can
pass in this video we will be learning
about the concept of lambda functions
now a lambda function in python is an
anonymous function without a name we
usually use lambda functions whenever we
want to create a
function type object for for a short
period of time a lambda function is
defined using the lambda keyword like a
normal function is defined using the def
keyword we define a lambda function
using the lambda keyword also the lambda
function can take any number of
arguments but it can only accept one
expression as a part of it so think of a
lambda function like um a sort of a a
temporary function object that you
create whenever you want to perform a
particular task or object but you don't
want to give it a name or you don't want
to define a full a full-blown function
and give it a name
so over here i'm going to give you an
example of a lambda function let's say
that this lambda function takes in
let's call it x
and
so you define the function let's call it
x let's call it a lambda function using
this keyword
now we won't say two parameters right
we're saying say a and b or two
arguments a and b so we're going to pass
two arguments a and b whenever we call
use this function and we're going to
perform some sort of an expression now
let's uh write down a simple arithmetic
expression for this once you've defined
your arguments
just use the colon now over here we have
our expression so let's call it a plus b
so now we've created a lambda function
called x
where uh we will pass two arguments and
the result will be the expression a plus
b a plus a and b being the arguments we
pass
so now let's print
the result
of
let's say we pass one and three so now
we should get the result four right
because a plus b is equal to four so we
passed a as one b is bs3 now let's
execute this as you can see the result
is 4. similarly you can pass any number
of arguments so we want to call some
function x
may say lambda function
maybe say
a
b and c this time and we want to do the
product of these three arguments
so now when we do
uh when we check the result let's say
we're doing the product of two four and
six
so this should be 48
and
when you execute this
you get 48 as you can see here so these
are two simple examples of a lambda
function
now i could have done this
in a different way where i could have
defined some function x
and over here i defined that it takes in
three parameters and then you can define
some say return the function basically
returns your a product b product c but
many a times you don't need to define a
full function called x you don't you
don't want to
assign some function with this name you
just want to create a temporary or
a short time anonymous function with
some name just to perform a simple
expression and in that case we can use
under functions that's an example by the
way you can use lambda functions in
multiple places so let's move on now
now for the
sake of this video what i'm going to do
is i'm going to show you how the sorted
function works and we're going to learn
how the lambda function uses this sorted
function how they work together so this
will give you a clearer understanding of
how we use the lambda function in our
code so to start off a sorted function
returns a sorted list from the items in
an interval so you can have a bunch of
for example numbers and the sorted
function by default will give you uh
will return you the list of numbers in
an ascending order of course you can
also
using a parameter called reverse you can
you can you can return a list of numbers
in the descending order um you can also
do this for strings uh i mean characters
so if you give it a bunch of characters
say a e f g in the in the alphabet it
will give you if you use a sorted
function it will give you the characters
it will return it in an ascending or
descending order depending on the
parameter you give so basically this uh
the sorted function the syntax is uh you
use the keyword sorted then you pass the
iterable which is basically some some
list or some
tuple then you give it a key so this key
sometimes we don't need to give by
default if the iterable is does not
contain
multiple uh multiple items per object
for like if it's not a tuple of multiple
objects um if it's not a list of tuples
for example you don't need to give it a
key if it's a simple list of numbers you
don't necessarily need to give a key if
you want to sort it but yeah a key is
basically the parameter which we use to
tell the sorted function that we want to
sort based on something which is going
to be the key in this case
finally the third parameter is reverse
which basically just tells us that if
you want to sort in the default
ascending order or if we say reverse
true then we will sort in the descending
order now let's look at some examples so
i have this list over here
and
i'm going to print this list
so uh this list is obviously a bunch of
vowels
e a u o i and this is not in the
ascending order of the
the alphabet right like we we know it as
a e i o u if i print the sorted form of
this list it should give me a e i o a
list with aeio in the ascending order
sorry yeah
so as you can see
um it's given me this list as you can
see here similarly if um i gave it a
string a string as you know is an
iterable it's a collection of characters
so if i use a sorted function on this
interestingly it will give me a list of
these um individual characters like p y
d h o and n but in the order that we
want it to be in
which is the ascending order of course
so
if i print this you can see it returns
me the list with each character in the
order that we wanted it to be in
now you might notice why does p come
before h that's because this is in
uppercase so what this does is first it
sorts all the uppercase characters um
since there's only one so it just places
in the first
object of this list and then it sorts
all the lowercase characters that you
see here so yeah moving on now now what
if we wanted to say um sort this in
descending order so
we have this list and now we want to
sort this in a descending order so in
that case we have to give the parameter
reverse and we have to assign the value
true
so once we do this now when we execute
this you can see we have the return as
the same list but in the opposite order
so that's how the reverse parameter
works now let's uh try to understand how
we use the key function or the key
parameter in the sorted function
now of course if you if we want to sort
something based on some key that we want
to define
we use the key parameter so let's take
an example now
so in this example what we have done is
i've defined this function
called take second so what this does is
it it simply
it takes the second element of a list of
tuples so what is this list of tuples
well this is random you can see this
random this is a list of tuples so this
is one tuple this is the next tuple and
what i'm going to do is in this example
i'm going to create a key out of every
second element
in
each tuple so i'm going to create a key
out of 20
10 and 13 and based on these in an
ascending order i will sort this whole
list so my what my
result should be is that since the
smallest of the uh every second object
in these tuples is 10 so this will be my
first object in the my sorted list then
it should be the one with 13 because
this is the next highest number so then
this will be the next object similarly
this will be the next object then this
will be the whole next object so you see
i'm using every second element of the
tuple as my key and for that to create a
key basically
i'm creating this function which will
basically return every um
it will iterate through all of these and
return
each of these second elements
so
let's actually uh let's actually do this
now so what i have here is i am going to
create a sorted list which is going to
use a sorted function on this iterable
which is a bunch which is a list of
tuples it's called random now my key is
going to be take second so this sorted
function is actually very dynamic in the
sense um i don't i don't exactly have to
create a list directly each of these
objects present in the tuples i just
have to define if i can even pass a
function in the parameter for key and it
will apply this function on the interval
that we bias over here which is random
namely and it will use this function to
generate keys
generate a key out of each second
element and based on that it will do the
sorted it will perform the sorted
function so now
if i check
what's my
sorted list
you will see
that as i had mentioned now it's using
these second objects or the second uh
each each second object of the tuple as
the key so since 10 is the smallest this
whole object is the first object then 13
so we have this object here and then so
on and so forth so this is how we have
used a key to do the sorting function a
key that we've defined on our on our own
now similarly we can use multiple keys
as well so just to quickly go over
through this uh we have this um some
some list where a bunch of names a bunch
of tuples you can see right tuples with
three objects each within it each first
one is always a string denoting
someone's name some students name
the second is the marks out of 100 and
the third is their age so
what we have here is what we want to do
is we want to sort this these tuples
in the order of first marks and in case
the marks are clashing or they are the
same basically um we will sort by the
age so um what we want to do is we want
to first sort by these marks as you can
see here but in case they clash for
example like say this 75 and 75 they're
the same marks in that case we want to
sort it by the age which is 12 and 20
which is different so in this case we're
going to use two keys one for first key
will be given the highest priority and
then if there is a clash then we use the
second key so how do we do this
now let's define some function like uh
how we define this take second function
here this will be our function that we
will pass to the key this function
basically what it does is it gives us
who has the highest marks now since we
are creating and since the key works in
an ascending order so um the smallest
object in a key is the first object that
we gets returned right so what we're
going to do is we're going to return the
error which is basically the difference
between
100 which is the total marks and the
marks that student gets so this is how
we obtain a ascending order in our list
which is what we which which basically
is what we want because we want um the
highest marks to be first
so we do 100 minus item one item one is
basically the first object of whatever
iterable we pass in this case it would
be the the first objects of each tuple
which is the marks secondly we found age
age is the item two which is the
yeah each second object of each tuple
now
what we return in this function is uh
like this is going to be our key now a
list of errors and there is list of age
error being the marks error the
difference between 100 and the marks you
obtain so now what it's going to do is
it's going to take the marks as the
first key and the age as the second key
when we pass this to a sorting function
so if you skip this you don't have to
look at this but if you look at this now
we have the sorted list which is going
to be the result of the sorted function
on top of what we pass which is the
participant list now we're going to use
the key we're going to use the key as
the sorter function so we're going to
use this order function as a key and
when we print
if you see
we get
let me just execute all of this
so if you see here in this section what
you can see is we have the highest marks
first then the second and the third but
if you see here there's a clash this guy
and this guy have the same mark 75 so
now what we want to do is the guy who
has a younger age should be in the first
in the object so that is how this has
happened because we've passed two keys
error and the age so when the clash in
error key happened we went to the h key
and then we did ascending order on that
and then finally the rest of the objects
that you can see here so now that we
have seen how the sorted function works
now let's look at how the lambda
function works using this sorted
function which was the main goal of this
video right so let's see
so it now some of you might have figured
out where this lambda function will be
used right so
whenever we were using the key
in the sorted function we had to define
a function and then we would pass that
function as the key so as some of you
may have figured this out um what we're
going to do using the lambda function is
we're going to skip that process of
defining a function with a new name and
all that and we're going to pass a
lambda function or going to use a lambda
function as the key so let's see how we
do it so initially what we've done is
we've created this list this list is a
list of dictionaries that you can see so
this first object is a dictionary second
object to the dictionary each dictionary
contains two keys um the name and the
age and the values are something like
nandini the
values for age is like 20 20 and 19 so
we have three dictionaries in a list
so what we're going to do is we want to
print what we what we want to do with
this we want to print
the these objects or these dictionaries
in an ascending order of age so we want
obviously we want this to be first and
then this and this because 19 is smaller
than 20.
so let's see how we do this
so if you go here
what we're going to do is we're going to
print the sorted the sorted function or
the uh the result of the sorted function
being applied on this list so this is
our iterable now if you see here in the
key the key parameter we don't we don't
predefine a function and pass it over
here instead we use the lambda and this
lambda function is defined in such a way
so we say lambda
it will take one argument i
and then it will return basically the
age
index
for some i and this i is we're going to
presume an i to be some sort of an
iterable which has an index called age
and which is uh which is the case in our
case right we have a bunch of
dictionaries where there is a key in
each of these dictionaries called age so
we're going to use that and now you're
going to ask like what is i well when we
use the lambda function in the sorted
function this i will basically be each
object that we get when we iterate upon
this list so if we're going to iterate
first on this so it's going to take this
dictionary and it's going to search for
the age then it's going to take this
it's going to search for the age then
it's going to take this and it's going
to search for the age and each of the
time it will pull out what is the value
for each of these age keywords or these
age indexes or age keys and out of these
objects so 20 20 and 19 or these values
we're going to create a key with which
we're going to sort each object in this
whole list
okay so this is how the lambda function
will work here so let's do it
so as you can see
our sorted list now contains this object
first
because a 19 is smallest edge and then
this and this now you might see that
there are two 20s so how do we control
which one comes first well by default it
will um
that it will just uh give us the result
in the way we passed it in the original
list so since nandini came before manjit
in the result also nandini will come
before manjeet but what if we wanted to
sort it even more what if we want to
sort it in such a way that first we go
by age and the second key will tell us
that if there is a clash in ages we have
to go alphabetically by the name so in
this case we will create a second key
and how we do that
well if you go to this step
over here what we're doing is we're
doing the same sorted function but now
the lambda will again take one parameter
which is i which is going to be each
itera which which is going to be each
object in this
iterable list and we're going to take
two keys so the first key will be the h
key
and the second key will be the name so
it will first sort on age and then on
name so now if you see
the result should be that manjit will
come before nandini even though the ages
are 20 because m comes before n in the
alphabet
as you can see this is the result
now if we wanted to do the same thing
but in a descending order all we have to
do is after this key parameter we have
to give another parameter called reverse
and we have to give it true
so if we did this now you see this this
uh or if we do it on this one
to be more clear
now if i execute this basically this
whole uh whatever result we get will be
backwards now
oh wait i did not enter it in the sorted
function
so this should come within the sorted
function over here
so now if we
execute this you will see nandhani comes
first manjit comes second and then
nikhil comes third
because we've done the reverse
we use the reverse keyword as true
reverse parameter is true
so this was a brief lesson on lambda
functions in this video we will be
covering a sort of a project side type
of scenario which is basically going to
be a problem case for you and uh
it's going to be slightly slightly
difficult slightly tricky um
but what we're going to do is we're
going to tackle a particular problem and
we're going to uh what i'm going to do
is also um show you a solution to that
problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is um we have this
program
that we have to write where we compute
the frequency of words that uh exist in
some input okay uh the program should
output after sorting the key alpha
numerically
now
this input can be any it's basically a
block of text right so in our example we
have um for example if this was our
input right uh what we want to see is
um
an output which is basically saying that
the word python has appeared say well in
this example it's appear times and then
the word read has appeared one time and
so on and so forth like for each of
these words we want to see
how many times have they appeared in
this particular block of text so
let's look at
a particular example now where we have
done this so let's um let's see here
so first of all i'm going to create a
dictionary so why am i creating a
dictionary is because i'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in
a block of text as the value to that key
so
i'm going to use a sample
string which is basically this long
string that you can see here which is
stored in line so this large chunk of
text is what we're going to be analyzing
um
so how are we going to do this it's
pretty simple so
we have this now what we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here
is
we want to
um check word by word um first of all we
want to see if it's a unique word and if
this word is
um before i encountered it for the first
time then we need to store a new key in
our dictionary called frequent table or
frequency table
um and if it has already if there is a
key already with that
particular name then we just want to
increment the count or the value by one
so let's see how we do this over here
so if you can see in my this the
solution is as simple as this but if you
see what's happening it's basically what
uh what it's doing is we're splitting up
this string
using the split function what this will
do is it will split up the string at
every white space so it will take this
as one part and take this part as
another part it will create an iterable
with each word as the um each iterable
object in that
container so
it's going to be a list of words like
python is one so on and so forth and
we're going to go one by one so we're
going to say forward in line dot split
now if this word is if it exists in
frequency table as a key then
what we're going to do is we're just
going to increase the count of
uh the value of that key by one but if
it does not exist then we're going to
actually create a key
with the word as that unique word and
we're going to create its value um
initialize its value to one
so when we execute this
now
if we
want to once we've done this we can sort
it by the count of the words so what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a another tuple called sporty
tuples where we're going to use the
lambda function out here uh to
sort the
the dictionary
in terms of its values so what we're
going to do is we're going to take the
key
uh the key being the lambda item item
with index one index one is basically
the value um so a particular uh key has
a value so the word python appears so
many times the per the word
say scientist appears so many times so
we're going to check which words have
the highest number of uh occurrences and
we're going to sort it in a descending
order so that that is basically what the
reverse is equal to true does so when
we're going to sort this when we're
going to use the sorted function when we
say reverse true uh it tells the sorting
function to sort this dictionary um this
dictionary frequency table uh in terms
of value
by the the descending order so whichever
um
word appears highest that would be the
first word in our
sorted tuple so that's what we do in
this line and once we execute this we're
also going to print so if you see the
result
of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine
um
appears six times learning appears six
times then python appears five times and
so on and so forth so we've created a
sorted tuple where the first object of
the tuple uh
we've created a list of sorted tuples
where the first object of the tube each
tuple is the unique word and then now
the second one is the number of times it
has appeared in this
particular example or this particular
string
so yeah this was
the first basic project that we have
tackled in this video we will continue
with what we started in terms of our
project number one what we're going to
do is um we're going to tackle another
slightly complicated a question or a
situation
we're going to try to arrive at a
solution so in this what we have is some
sort of a robot a moving robot which
moves on a cartesian plane a two
coordinate plane um is going to move in
terms of up down left and right okay and
each each time it moves up or down or
left or right it takes a certain number
of steps in that direction um integral
steps of course so what we need to do is
from a starting position whatever its
starting position is which we are going
to take as 0 comma 0 in this example
we're going to make it move to a
particular location with the commands up
down left and right followed by certain
steps
um and we're going to
ask what we're going to do is we're
going to calculate the distance between
these two points and we're going to
calculate different types of distances
so you might be introduced to new
concepts
new distance concepts in this video as
well
so
what we're going to be using for
distance calculation is the minkowski
distance and that is um we're going to
take
so the minkowski distance between two
variables is basically the absolute
difference between these two variables
of these two points
and
we take it to the power of something so
if we want to say uh calculate the
minkowski distance with um
in terms of the quadratic main cause
distance with basically p2 so we are
going to do x i minus y i absolute
difference to the power 2 and then we're
going to take the second root of it
after summing each and every point
um
so when we take p is equal to 2 we we
say the minkowski distance behaves like
the euclidean distance so this is
probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done
basic
cartesian geometry when you're asked to
find the distance between two points on
a plane um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the
absolute distances between each point um
no roots no powers nothing basically p
is equal to one and we call that the
manhattan distance so we're going to
take p is equal to one two and three in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points uh based on
these
measures
so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the euclidean distance
basically the
estimate of the value between these two
points if um the synthesis is a two
coordinate system whereas the manhattan
distance would be the absolute distance
in terms of um if we go up and then we
go right between these two like save
this first and this was another point
um so yeah
let's uh move on to the problem
so what we're in this in this particular
example we're going to start from the
starting position 0 and 0 on a on a
graph and we are going to give the
commands of up 5 down 3 left 3 and right
2. so first of all what we want to do is
um we initialize the starting position
as zero and zero and we also just for
the sake of this example we um
initialize the end position as zero and
zero
so what we're going to do first of all
is
let's execute this much now we have this
list list of tuples um it's we're going
to call this actions and this is the
actions that we're performing so the the
each tuple contains an action and the
number of steps in that direction so it
contains four actions
up by five steps down by three steps
left by three steps right by two steps
so now we're going to iterate over this
each tuple and we're going to get the
direction first of all in this line
um for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by this line and
we're going to find out the number of
steps in that direction which is
stored in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to update the end position right
so what happens is if you go up
by a particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the uh the y axis so we're going to
change end position and the first index
which is basically this part of the
end position coordinate point so we're
going to say if it's moving by up then
we're going to uh update
by adding
uh
the y axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction was down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y y-axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x-axis right so we take n
position in the first index so we take
the x-axis and if you're moving left
it's a negative uh it's a decrement and
if you're moving right it's an increment
so
if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid
actions that we can pass is um up down
left and right otherwise we we
just skip that particular action so this
is what the this particular loop will do
it will update our final position
so once we've done this
um
if we if i execute this what will get
stored in the end position is basically
my end position so
now that i have my starting position and
my end position um just to show you what
the end position will look like right
now
let's
just do this so if you see here after
i've moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two um my start
position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be zero and
zero
it is zero and zero so now we're going
to find the distance between zero and
zero and minus one and two so we're
going to first of all create a function
called minkowski distance which which
does a basic function of just calculate
the uh
the difference between the
what do you say
the end position x coordinate and the n
position y coordinate times uh or to the
power of a root and we're basically
going to do this operation that
you saw here we're going to do this
and um
we're going to uh
we're going to
use this root variable to
specify to like p is equal to one two or
three like what p value we want to take
for this minkowski distance so once
we've done this what this function will
do is basically store uh this much and
it will wait for us to uh it will
basically wait for us to give us a root
so when we give root one it will create
these it will check the distance between
the end and starting points um with the
p value of one if we give it two it will
calculate euclidean distance with p
value two similarly for three and we can
calculate for any roots so we're going
to calculate for one two and three roots
um and we're going to see what values we
get in each case
so when root is equal to one i print a
statement saying minkowski distance with
root one is something and then root two
it's something root three something
let's see what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the um
the cubic minkowski distance with
basically the with root 3 is 1.91 so you
see these three different uh distance
measures for the same distance between
two points so in this video you
basically so in this basically by doing
this activity you might must have you
will learn how to
basically how to iterate through loops
um and perform these distance
calculations which you'll find pretty
handy in
many activities related to data science
and machine learning so yeah this was on
the project too in this video we will be
continuing tackling different
problems and
problem cases in terms of a project
called project 3 where we're going to be
using regular expressions to
validate whether
[Music]
certain passwords that have been entered
or do they match certain criterias or
not
so let's look into
our particular question
we have a website that requires users to
input username and password to register
now we have to write a program to check
the validity of passwords input by the
users now the criterias that the
passwords have to follow are that
there's at least one number between a
and z um and this is at least one number
between is at least one letter between a
and z and one number between zero and
nine uh the third criteria is that uh
there's at least one letter between
capital a and capital z so this first
and third point basically is saying that
there should be one lowercase letter and
there should be one uppercase letter um
now there should be at least one
character from dollar sign hash or the
at simple um it should have a minimum
length of 6 and the maximum length of
12.
so when we whatever passwords that we
enter into our
example they must be commas separated so
if we're going to have an input they're
going to ask us for an input where we're
going to have to input the different
passwords in a comma separated way so
let's look let's look at
how do we tackle this so for my example
i'm going to use these
examples in terms of these are my
password examples if you're going to
check if these are valid passwords or
not so let's copy this first of all
and now let's import the re this import
rd is basically the regular expression
module
now in this step is going to ask us to
input the passwords as you can see here
so i will just control v so since this
is comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these
by the comma and it will store them in a
list so it will take this as one
password this has another password this
has another password and this has
another password once i press enter
now if i want to check what's in list i
mean what's in items what i can do is
just check over here what's in items
it's a list of whatever passwords i had
entered
each object is separately treated now in
this list
now i'm going to create a an empty list
called value first for store once i've
done that i'm going to move on to the
next step
so once i've created my list called
value what i'm going to do is now i'm
going to search and i'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have
initially so
if you see here what i'm going to do is
first iterate by each item in this to
check for each password now my first
check will be a basic check
for the length of the password if it's
lesser than 6 or greater than 12 then
our uh
our basically our password is illegal so
we can't be using this and we will just
continue and we won't check for anything
else but if it is within 6 and 12 the
length
6 and 12 then we can uh continue with
our check so we can do we'll do an
statement for pass which basically moves
on to this uh next block
now once we've done this
what we will do is
this this first statement what this is
going to do is it's going to do an re
dot search and re dot search as you know
is going to look for at least one
instance of
a letter occurring between
a and z so this ire.search
followed by this now this is the regular
expression that we have passed and what
this tells us is basically the square in
the square brackets we're looking for
anything between
a and z in terms of small letters so if
this is if this condition is not met
then again we continue and we leave this
uh particular search because one of our
criterias is not met
all right but if it is met then uh this
if not statement will not uh like we
won't enter this block and we can move
on to the next check so
now now we move to l if not now again
we're using if not statement so this is
basically checking for uh a negative
case so anytime one of these cases have
been met it basically means that our
password has been invalid because these
conditions are not being met so we're
trying to eliminate all
conditions all of these conditions so
that we get a valid password so again we
move on to the next statement which is
basically going to do the search for
numbers once again if we find a case a
password without any numbers
we continue and we don't um
check this password no more because we
already know it's a it's a
an illegal password now next check will
be for capital letters a to z
and the next check again will be for
these particular symbols the dollar the
hash and the at one of these three
symbols
finally we have a a search for
we're going to search for a white space
character so if we actually do find a
white space character in our password um
that's an illegal password and we're not
going to continue checking for those
cases
so
um so this is basically all our cases
lower case letters
numbers capital letters these one of
these three symbols and the existence of
a white space so once we've done all
these checks
um if if none of these have been passed
we move on to this else statement where
we just pass and uh what we can do is we
append the value
we append the value to uh we we append p
to the uh
the i the list called value
so basically what happens is um just to
go through it again um if this condition
is not met
uh and this condition is not met this is
not met this is not meant this is not
met and if this is
also not met
then we're fine so basically as long as
we have small letters as long as we have
a number as long as we have a capital
letter as long as we have one of these
three symbols and as long as we don't
have
any uh white space characters we can
append e to this otherwise it will
continue and it will break out of this
for loop completely that's what the
continue thing the continue statement at
the end of each of these blocks checks
anytime this condition is met
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this uh
whole for loop and we don't append p to
the value but uh if we actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append uh p
to value now finally what we are going
to do is uh we're going to print out all
the valid all the valid passwords so
just by a quick look you can see here
this is a valid password right so let's
execute this and let's see
what we get if you see here we only get
one valid password and let's look at why
um some of these did not turn out to be
valid so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number and it has one of the
symbols either dollar sign or the hash
sign or the add sign
in this case we have two white spaces
one over here and one over here so this
is an illegal password similarly in this
case also we have an illegal password
because it begins with a space
in this case it's the same thing we
begin with a space and also it does not
have any of those uh symbols that we
were looking for the dollar or the hash
or the ad so again so these three are
illegal passwords and they do not get
appended to value however this does get
appended to value and that's why we get
the result for only one password which
is the only legal password in this video
we will be covering the topic of
iterators now an iterator in python is
an object that contains a countable
number of values or it's a larger object
that contains a countable number of
sub-objects an iterator is an object
that can be iterated upon and what that
means is we can traverse from each value
and we can manipulate or perform certain
functions or operations and tasks using
each of the
sub-objects or values within this larger
collection called iterator now
when we're looking at it technically an
iterator is an object which implements
the iterator protocol in python which
consists of the methods eter and the
method next so to begin with let's look
at a simple iterator we're going to see
the example of a list where we're going
to traverse through
the objects of a list using the for loop
so we have objects one two three four
and i'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here
another example of
an iterable in python is
the dictionary so let's say i have a
dictionary where i have two values two
key value pairs uh key x which contains
a value one and key y which corresponds
to value two now when i'm going to do a
for loop through this by default i will
be traversing through the keys x and y
as you can see over here and of course
uh the other types of weight trebles in
python are like sets and tuples as well
all right now let's look at um
what this iterating protocol is in
python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects that
contain sub objects and when we use the
eater function it uh creates an iterator
out of it so we can one by one we can
traverse through
each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or traversed through each of
the sub objects we encounter the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or
iterated upon so and as an example i
will create a list
where i will store the values
some simple values integers one two
three four one three four five okay
i'm going to create an iterator out of
this where i will use it function and
i'm going to say this is let's say this
is called
my
my editor okay
and
i'm going to use it function as i had
mentioned and i'm going to pass my list
in this
now if you see what is my iter
it should say it should be a list
iterator at a particular memory location
now let's use the next function to keep
going through whatever is there in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see
now when i look at the next it should be
three then i should get four and now i
should get five as i use the next uh
successively now since i've reached the
last of my uh objects in this collection
now the next time i use this next
function i should get a stop uh stop
iteration exception that is raised as
you can see here so this is the basic um
iteration protocol in python now you
might have uh already gone through the
for loop video and in that i have spoken
in quite a bit of detail as to how a for
loop performs this
this iterator protocol and how it
creates an iterative iterable object out
of say a list or a
tuple and how we how it internally
performs the next function and it um
breaks out of the for loop once it
encounters the stop iteration exception
so
um for loops are like they're very very
uh similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now um let's do a
basic comparison of what is a a basic
comparison between a generator and an
iterator in python so in generator um we
use a function we use like we define it
using the def keyword and we define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function
the generator makes use of the yield
keyword whereas the python iterator does
not um in generators we save the states
of the local variables each time we use
the yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any trouble like a list
to iterate upon
we may use any number of yield
statements in generators and we do not
use yield statements initiators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas
iterators are very memory efficient so
this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules in python
now a module in python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot by extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files or several modules
now my modular programming is the
process of breaking a large
a large event or task into smaller and
more manageable sub tasks and we call
these subtasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger optic application there are
several advantages to modulizing code uh
in a large application and we will be
going through them right now first of
all there is simplicity because instead
of focusing on a big big problem a big
task we can break down the problem into
smaller smaller portions or modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through modules because they are
designed to create these sort of
boundaries or
clear demarcations between different
problem domains
there is usability usability in the
sense that once we create a module we
can use it in different parts of the
code or even different different
applications itself um there is also
scoping and what this means is modules
typically define a separate name space
and this helps us avoid collisions
between identifiers in different areas
of a program functions modules and
packages are basically all constructs in
python that promote code module
modularization
you might have already come across
a gordon intro into functions in this
video we will be going through modules
in another video we will also cover the
topic of packages to import a module we
use the import keyword and in this
example what i'm going to show you is a
simple function or a simple operation of
importing the os module
this is short for operating system and
as the name suggests we can perform
system tasks through the functions and
methods that are part of this os module
so simply executing the statement will
import this module onto our program for
us to use now if we wanted to see all
the functions that are present in a
module what we have to do is use the dir
function so if we print the dir os
function it will print us basically a
directory of all the functions that are
present in the os module as you can see
here
like all of these are basically uh names
to different functions that are part of
the os module finally moving on another
function commonly used with modules is
the get cwd function and what this does
is it will give us the current working
uh directory that we are working upon
right now so if i execute this it will
tell me what is the directory that i am
currently working upon right now as you
can see seed notebook dir slash 10. if
we wanted to see all the files in a
particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the parenthesis it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temp so if i were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that i am
currently working upon now a basic step
is um creating a python module the
simplest way to create a python module
is basically creating a python script
with whatever functions and tasks that
we want and methods that we want inside
uh whatever module and saving it with a
dot py extension um so in in my example
what i'm going to do is i have already
created a script in notepad and i've
stored it with a dot py extension that
contains these four functions add
subtract
product and division um i have basically
copied i basically use this code and
i've stored it in a dot py script and
i'm going to be using this as my uh as
as a test module for this particular
example now how do we import a module
now once that i have created a script uh
in my example will be called my calc or
py uh and we've stated stored it in our
directory to import the module all we
have to do is use the import statement
so if i have to import my calc all i
have to do is say import my underscore
calc and now my calc has been imported
um so we can use the import statement or
if we want to import something
particular from mycalc we can do from my
calc import now we can whatever like for
example if we wanted the add uh the add
function we can basically just say only
add or if we wanted add and subtract we
can say add and subtract uh for example
so this is basically by using from we
can say that we want something from
something but only parts of it we don't
want everything uh we can also use from
mycalc import and we can say asterix to
basically say uh import everything that
exists in my calc
right now so this is another way of
importing something from a module now to
access contents in a module we have to
use the dot operator and i will show you
how right now so what i'm going to do is
in my example i'm going to import my
calc as calc so now what this since this
is the original folder or the original
module but i'm going to give it a
shorthand name so that i can easily use
it in my code and i don't have to type
out my underscore card every time so now
i'm going to import this as calc so
anytime i have to refer to a particular
method or function inside the script or
this module i will just use this uh this
placeholder this variable name so now i
have two variables a and b and i'm
storing 20 and 30 in them so my first
func what i'm going to do is basically
four operations i'm going to print the
addition of a and b then the subtraction
multiplication and the division of these
two numbers and each time to do this
operation i am going to use the add
function that is present in the my calc
module so to do that i have already
imported my characters calc all i am
going to do now is invoke these
functions using the dot operator that we
are already familiar with so i'm going
to say calc dot add and then i'm going
to pass these two arguments or these two
variables to say that i want to add
these two and similarly i'm going to do
it for subtraction
multiplication and division as you can
see these are the results of my tasks
now if i had to do a directory uh
operation on the module calc it will
basically give me a bunch of inbuilt or
dunder methods that are already a part
of any
python script by default such as
built-ins so if i execute this just to
show you what happens when i use the dir
function it will basically give me all
the functions that are part of this
python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
denoting magic methods or dunder methods
and these are like inbuilt methods as a
part of the script and if you see here
add division fraud and sub these are the
methods that we have defined earlier on
in our script ourselves now to go
slightly deeper or in more detail into
what happens when we do a module search
um let's let's actually look at what
happens so what happens is when for
example we execute the statement import
my calc as calc as we did over here so
the first the steps that actually take
place are the interpreter executes the
above statement and it searches for this
python script in a list of directories
assembled from these following sources
that you see here so it takes the
directory from which the input script
was run or the current directory if the
interpreter is being run interactively
which is the case right now uh secondly
it will list all the directories
contained in the python path environment
that you set up
that you can set up or you can change
later on as well and this format for
python path is os dependent of course
but it should mimic the path environment
variable that we see in
windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search path that is accessible in the
python variable system.path
and this is basically obtained from a
module named sys so if i imported this
and i did sys.path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for when we want to search for any
particular module so if i am doing uh
import my kayak or import os it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that i am working on it's also
going to look at all of these uh
directories that have been set up as
you could say directories or
paths in the
system.path in this video we will be
covering the topic of packages now what
if we developed a very large application
in python that contains many different
modules and we have so many different
modules that have similar names and
functionalities and they're all kept in
like or dumped in the same location that
it becomes very difficult to track these
modules what if there was a way to
organize and access these in a much
simpler and more organized manner well
packages allow us to do just that
packages are a hierarchical structuring
of the module namespace using dot
notation and this is the same dot
notation that we use when we want to
access methods or functions that are
part of other classes or modules so
let's try to
let's look at certain examples to
understand what we mean so i have a
directory called pkg this can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod one dot py and mod two dot p
by and what we're going to store in mod
one and mod two dot py are the follows
so i'm going to define a function called
foo and i'm gonna print uh this
particular statement mod one and then
i'm gonna basically say foo
and then i'm going to say in class four
i'm gonna
have an empty pass command similarly i'm
going to define a function called bar in
mod 2 dot py where i'm going to print
this statement so basically mod1 dot py
has a simple function where i'm going to
print this statement and mod 2 dot py
has a simple function then i'm going to
print this statement
i'm going to store them in mod 1 and mod
2. py respectively and these two modules
i'm going to store in the directory pkg
in my local folder now i've already done
this so we can already get
to working with this now if i wanted to
access these particular modules from the
pkg folder i can simply use the import
command and use the dot notation so i
can say pkg dot mod 1. so this will
inward this will
import the mod 1 module from pkg folder
similarly i can do the same thing for
the mod 2
module from the pkg folder in the same
line so now that it's been imported just
simply execute this and this imports
whatever you needed now if we wanted to
perform a function that was a part of
mod1 or py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly i can invoke the
function that was part of the mod 2
module
by extending the dot notation to it in
the same way now another way that i can
invoke
i can import a package is by directly
importing the package itself by using
import pkg and
not accessing any of the specific
modules within it now let's see what
happens when we do this so just for this
example what i'm going to do is i'm
going to restart the kernel so that uh
the pkg modules that were already
imported uh get cleaned away so we see
what happens when we execute this on its
own now if you see i haven't imported
this now let's see if i can access
my mod 1 and mod 2. now if you see here
it's throwing me an error and this is
because using simply using the import
command on a particular package only
imports um you could say the package
name space but it does not actually
import any of the modules and files that
were part of this package so if i wanted
mod 1
from this package i would have to
actually say import pkg.mod pkg.mod1
directly
and i cannot simply say import pkg and
python will not import everything that
is part of a package on its own i have
to specify it myself
specifically now i'm going to create and
i'm going to i mean i'm going to show
you another type of importing from a
package using the star operator so i
have this package pkg once again now i'm
going to store um three i mean four
different modules within this package
mod one one one dot py mod two two two
dot p by and i've already done this so
you don't need to bother about um
seeing me doing it right now because
i've already created these files and
what i've done is within mod one one one
dot py i've defined
i've written this statement and i've
stored it in the python script similarly
i've created another python script
script called mod 222 dot py and i have
basically written this in the code and
i've simply done this for mod 333 dot py
and i've done another for mod 4 dot py
now once i have done this i've stored
these python scripts into my uh into my
package or pkg
package so now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create i'm going to execute
this command if you see this from pkg
dot mod 333 import start so once i
execute this now i'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if i change
this and
if i imported mod111 and if i did the
same thing you will see foo has now been
added as a part of this direction
directory and these are all uh functions
that were part of these different
modules where i'm importing from and
that is what the star function does what
the star function will do is it will
basically tell python okay so the
statement is synced from pkg.mod mod111
so it's saying that
okay look into this directory or this
package and find this module and in this
module import everything that exists
inside it up until this point so this is
another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically a an organized way of
storing many different modules that we
might have created in a very large
application
and these modules can be accessed using
the familiar.note notation that we have
used in other examples such as methods
when we were working with classes and
objects in this video we will be taking
an introduction into the concept of
generators so python provides a
generator which is like a function
where we can create our own iterator in
a generator function we use the yield
statement instead of the return
statement that we use for standard
functions
so let's look at a simple generator
first of all so out here i have defined
a generator called my generator where
i'm doing uh like there are three uh
like three
functions or three tasks that i'm doing
first one is when i'm printing the first
item and i'm yielding a value 10 then
i'm printing second item yielding 20
then i'm printing last item using 30. so
let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword
every time we use the next keyword we
will keep getting what is next in this
function so let's store
um the generator in my gene
so now
we
have stored the iterator in this
function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first
um task is performed or the first
iteration is performed where we get this
the first yield command is done
all right let's see what happens when we
do next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20.
let's do it for the next let's do it
once more since there is one more task
there's one more iterable inside
you can see this now a valid question is
what will happen if we do next gen again
since
there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is another uh
built-in exception
that happens when we
have
like reached the last
object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so now a key difference between a
generator and a function is that when we
execute a function the moment we hit the
return statement in a function or any
execute a function like whatever
variables that were stored inside are
lost and they're destroyed unless they
were defined as global
and the function is completely done
executing and we leave the function
completely whereas when it comes to a
generator
when we hit the yield function we don't
actually completely leave this function
so the first time the yield is found we
get 10
but
the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next iterable so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python or create
iterators in python
so to understand a what the difference
between the yield
command and the return command does
let's take the same function
all right
and let's put a return over here
after this particular
the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to
my
generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what's there
so the first deal will be standard first
item 10
the next one is again is going to say
second item and then 20 but now if you
notice there was a return i put over
here
so
technically when i did the second next
it's not only yielded 20 but it's also
executed this return function
or this return statement so let's see
what happens if i do next again
as you see i have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than i did
before and that's because i have used
the return function and determine
statement and what that's done is that
um
if we've completely left this function
so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between yield and return
now in the next example i'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for loop or for a for
loop so let's take this whatever over
here and i have defined a function
called get sequence up to x and
what this will do is basically
it will keep printing the
printing numbers
up until whatever we have entered in
place of x over here so if i said
say sequence is equal to
let's uh
copy this
all right
and say i want um i want sequentially i
want every number up until 10 but not
including 10 of course because python
starts with 0 right
so let's do this
and
now let's see so the first number will
yield 0
and now if i
did this again
it should give me 1
2 and i can keep going
until
i
will stop at the value 9
as you can see here
so 8
9.
now i should get the stop iteration
error because that we have reached the
end of our iteration so this is a way of
using generator functions for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator
is
in the case of fibonacci numbers so
let's use it
let's uh see how we can generate a
fibonacci series using um generator so
i've defined a fibonacci function called
fibonacci where i'm passing max so max
is basically the max value that i want
um
like up until where i want the sequence
right so
this is basically the code which will
give return me the subsequent values of
my fibonacci sequence
so
let's
pass this to fib
and say i want all the fibonacci numbers
until 10.
so and i will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero
then when we do this again we get 1
then we do 0 plus 1 it should be 1
next number should be 1 plus 1 which is
2 then we should have 2 plus 1
and then 3 plus 2 5 then 3 plus 5 should
be 8. now 8 plus 5 is 13 and since 13 is
greater than what we passed for our max
value here
now when we try this
we should get the stop iteration error
as you can see in this video we will be
learning about the concept of list
comprehension now list comprehension is
it's a neat way of creating a new list
based on values that are already there
in an existing list so you can think of
it like
creating a new list
using a much shorter and cleaner syntax
compared to what you might traditionally
be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes
creating these new this much simpler and
much easier for us so in our first
example we will be creating a new list
which will contain fruits that contain
the letter a and their name so we
already have a list of
fruits over here as you can see
it has apple it has banana cherry kiwi
and mango now we want to create a new
list which has only the fruits that have
the letter a inside them so apple would
be one of them banana would be one of
them and mango would be one of them so
traditionally if you look at this piece
of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few
extra lines
but yeah it does it does do what we want
to do now what if there was a way of
doing the same thing by just writing one
simple line of code and that exists as
you can see here
so i take the same
list
now
this is where you need to follow so now
my new list is equal to so i'm creating
a list over here as you can see now
within this list you have this line this
is what we call a list comprehension so
as you can see it says each fruit for
each fruit in fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a
inside
each fruit and what this each fruit is
that we're checking each
object in this list one by one so first
in the first iteration each fruit will
contain the string apple then in the
next iteration it will contain banana
and in each
uh each iteration we're going to check
if it contains the character a and if it
does then we store that each fruit in
the new list
as you can see here
so if i execute this line you see
my my result is the same i have my
whatever i wanted and this was a much
cleaner way of writing
or creating this new list let's look at
some other examples now
so my next example what i'm going to do
is i am going to iterate through a
string so i have a string it can be
anything in this case i am using a
string called human
all right so i have a string called
human right now i want to store each
character of this string into a
list that we call h underscore letters
so if i use the for loop this is how we
would do it if i execute this as you can
see the list contains h and then u m a
and then n now what if i wanted to do
the same thing but
by using list comprehension
so what i would do is
let's create
a list over here let's underscore
letters
and
um
so as we know let's com so a list
comprehension will uh it's it's a
you just basically need one line in this
case it will just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when i check what's in
edge letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see i have
the output as what i needed so this is a
much cleaner way let's go through some
more examples now
now we can do more list comprehensions
um we can even use so we have already
seen uh
one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
uh went through where we we did a sort
of a loop through a string we can also
use this comprehensions in conditionals
so let's look at an example where we use
the
this comprehension with an if statement
so what if i wanted to store say the
first
10 even numbers so this would so this is
an example that i'll be using
so in my list i want to store the first
10 even numbers so this would be a way
to do it
so i have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is x is going to take the
value of 1 2 3 4 and so on until 98 that
actually take it from 0 1 2 3 4 until
19. so when we do range 20 we're
creating an iterate in iterable
where uh
we're going to
loop through our iterate through the
value of 0 to 19. so
if i if i do this and this what this
statement does is basically it checks if
it's divisible by 2.
so
if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number
and if this condition is met if this
condition is met that means we store
the x into our number list so let's see
what happens when we execute this
this should contain
0 2 4 6 until 18. so this is the first
and even numbers as you can see
so this is an 8 way of using if
statement we can also use an if else
statement
so what if five i'm checking um
each
okay so i'm going to create another list
and in this list i'm going to basically
see if um
each of my uh num numbers are the even
or odd the first let's say 10 natural
numbers
so let's write this statement down
so i want it to be even
in case
the i that i'm checking
i being every number between so like say
the first 10 natural numbers as i said
let's check if um
if it is divisible by 2
well if it is divisible by 2 of course
it's going to be even right
else
we say that it is odd
and then we check for i in say the first
let's say the first 20
okay
so now when we do this let me check
oh we check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even orders basically saying the number
uh zero is even then the number one is
odd then number two is even and so on
and so forth so this is a an example
where we used the list comprehension
with ifs statements
so another neat thing that we can do
with the
list comprehensions is that we can use
it along with functions so let's look at
this function in this example we have a
function called double x where we define
this double x uh this double function to
take an input uh to take an argument x
and what we return is the square of the
uh argument so
let's use this in our lifts this
comprehension so what we do over here is
that we are we're checking what we're
doing is for every x um bet in range 10.
so we're taking the value of 0 1 2 3
until 9 and we're passing it to this
function double x
and
we're going to get the square of them
and we're going to store that in a in a
list as you can see here let's call this
list
uh x let's just call this list uh let's
call it y so now let's see what's in y
and we check
uh it should be 0 1 4 9 and so on so
wait this let's check again does this
square no this is actually two times so
let's make it square
as you can see
so you can see 0 1 4 9 for the first
10 numbers 10 natural numbers now what
i've shown you is obviously list
comprehension um but we can also do set
and dictionary comprehensions in fact
set comprehensions work exactly the same
way as list comprehensions
the only difference is the
set comprehension will make sure that
there are no duplicates inside the set
so you can't have like duplicate items
which you can in the case of list
comprehensions so let's uh let's just
take a look at an example so here in
this example what we're doing is
we're going to check so we have this
string that we're storing in the
variable text
and the string is
something like life finds a way so
whatever this is now what we're going to
do is we're going to
uh
iterate through this string
character by character and we're going
to check if
uh there are we're going to check for
vowels essentially so
uh we're going to see if the character a
e i o or u is present in the string and
if it is we will pass it into our set
now if you if you look you will find
there are multiple eyes right and there
are multiple a's as well so if we did
this through a list comprehension each
time that we
found find a vowel it would be added to
our list but since this is a set and
sets do not allow duplicates so you will
only have one copy or one particular
object for each of the vowels so
uh of course now uh set comprehension is
defined using curly braces so let's keep
that in mind so now if i check what's in
this i will see a e i and u even though
there are multiple a's or multiple e's
or i's and u's since this is a set we
don't have duplicate copies of any
copies of any of these
so this was just a small example for
showing you set comprehensions similarly
we can do the same thing uh this this
comprehension uh for dictionaries and
they will call it dictionary
comprehensions the only thing that we
have to worry about when it comes to
dictionary comprehensions is that we
have to define a key when it comes to
this
so let's let's look at an example
in this what we're doing is again
dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except
in this case we will define a key and
that separates it from a set
comprehension
so in this case what we're doing is that
i'm checking uh i'm going through the a
list of numbers from zero to nine right
this is what the range stand function
does
and
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create a key which is going
to be like 0 1 2 3 and the value of each
key would be a square as you can see
here
i'm doing i times i
or just to
make a little more clearer
as you can see i'm doing i square over
here for every value from 0 to 9 so what
i should get is like a dictionary where
the first key is zero and the value of
that key should be zero as well because
zero uh square is zero then for one it
will be one and then for two four and
then three nine four sixteen so let's
see what happens
as you can see here
this is the
the result that i wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to
list comprehensions um so it's obviously
an elegant way uh to define and create
lists based on
existing lists
it's more compact and faster than normal
functions and loops but we should also
keep in mind that we shouldn't write
like very complicated
list comprehensions because
the idea of a less comprehension is to
be user friendly and also it's important
to note that every list comprehension
can be written in the form of a loop but
every loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember so
yeah that's it uh this for this video on
list comprehension set comprehension
dictionary comprehensions i hope you
learned a new
a neat new technique or trick
when it comes to creating your new list
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of regular expressions now a
regular expression is simply a sequence
of characters that defines a search
pattern for example
if you see this example here you can see
a symbol called the carrot followed by p
and then five periods
then an n and a dollar sign and what
this regex pattern does is it's
searching for a seven letter string that
starts with p ends with n and has five
characters in between
let's look at this example now this is a
regex pattern that is looking for a five
character string that starts with a ends
with s and has three characters in
between now if we had to match this with
this tree with these strings as in as
test strings the first one would not
match because it's a three letter string
and we're looking for a five character
string the second one would match
because it's a five character string
that ends with an s starts with an a and
has three characters in between this
will not match because whatever pattern
would do is it would find the first s
and it would find that it the string
itself starts with an a and it would say
okay there are only two characters
between this first s
and this a and it would assume that this
is actually just a four character string
to actually
identify two consecutive ss we would
have to do something special and what we
would have to do is what we will see
later on
so again this is the same example since
this is case insensitive capital a uh is
perfectly fine when we're searching for
this and it will also match this is um
this is obviously two words and it's not
a five character string so this will not
be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in python can be
imported using this statement import re
now once we've done this we can actually
use the our regular expression tools and
methods to do
pattern recognition character
recognitions and to identify different
sequence of characters in our strings
let's try to understand
a bit more in depth about regular
expressions now so what you're seeing
here is one variable called pattern
which stores
something that looks like a regex
and another variable that stores our
test string called abyss
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use the match method of this
module re and we're going to check
whether this pattern
um or whatever we are trying to search
using this regex
is in fact does it match with our test
string and what we're trying to look for
is if you see here very similar to what
i just showed you a five character
string that starts with a and ends with
s
so if you see our test string it indeed
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that
search is successful if i execute this
and this is what it does
now if i change the test string to this
now
you will see that now this is no longer
what we're looking for a five character
string with uh a and starting with a and
ending with s
and you will see that the search will be
unsuccessful
as you can see here
now let's try to understand what exactly
do we mean by uh when we use these
different certain these special symbols
like for example this carrot or this
dollar symbol
these are by the way known as meta
characters and now we're going to look
into all the
or most of the different meta characters
that are used in wreck x
so to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way by the regex search
engine now here's a list of meta
characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets square bracket
simply specifies the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match
some combination of a b and c it can be
one a two a's three b's four c's we are
not looking at a specific pattern we
just want to know if a b and c exists in
any form in our string so if we used it
on a
the string a simply we would find one
match because the letter a is found here
ac would match twice because we have a
and c
present here in this string hey jude we
will have no matches because a b and c
none of them are found here and in this
weird string we will have actually one
two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a b or c
now let's use re.match to
do
to actually search for this and to see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string um i'm going to test this
i'm going to match whether my pattern
that um
any of a b and c is it actually found in
this so let's see what happens when i
use re.match for this
so the the format the syntax is simply
the regex pattern and then comma
whatever test string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this
as you can see it's none even though you
might be wondering like i can see an a
over here i can see a c over here
re.match actually gives us the result
none
now
if i
try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film titanic was at least 1998 what
i'm saying here is all film titanic was
released in 1998. now let's see if the r
match
works or not
as you can see it actually does return
when i execute this it returns us an
object called re.match object with a
span01 the span01 is basically telling
us that we have found a match between
the zeroth and the first character which
is basically this character a which is
what it has found and it's saying that
the match is indeed the character a
from amongst these options
so what this is basically telling us and
uh what this means actually is that the
re.match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space in
in our bigger string it will not search
for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter a
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re.search
as you can see here the re.search method
will actually check the whole string and
it will return us the first instance
where it finds a match now let's see
this is the test string now and if we're
searching again for
our we're searching for a b and c any
any of these um in our test string but
we're going to use re.search and not
match so now if you see it returns us
when i execute this it returns us a
match object again but this time it's
saying the span of 9 and 10. now the
span panel 9 and 10 actually exists over
here this is the ninth character and a
itself is the tenth character over here
so what this basically is telling us
that the tenth character is where we
found a match
which was the letter a which was the
first instance of either a or b or c in
this whole string and this is basically
how re dot search works it will not only
search the beginning of the string but
it will search the whole string and
return us the first instance or wherever
we find now what if we wanted to find
out all the instances wherever a b and c
were found and not just the first
instance but in that case we would be
using the method find all over here so
when we use find all it will actually
return us each and every case where it
found a b or c and uh you might not it
won't tell you the exact position but it
will tell you like um so if i execute
this you can see it gives us a a list
with a c a and a and what this basically
means is it was looking for the
characters a or b or c and it found a
first and hence this for the first item
the list and then it found a c and then
it found two is successfully so this is
exact this is actually how find all
works where it will actually find all
the instances of our regex pattern now
that you've seen how the square brackets
work and how the re.search and
re.match and re.find all methods work
now we're going to go through all the
other meta characters that we saw above
so the period now period matches any
single character except the new line new
line is basically slash n or a break now
if you look at this picture what it's
going to do is um
this expression basically saying that uh
do we have
two characters like sets of two
characters in our string so this is a
single character string and obviously a
single character string is not a double
character string and this expression
this double dot is basically uh asking
us do we have two characters present in
our string
so if i had to match it with this a it
will obviously be a no match because a
is one character if we checked it with
ac it is a match because a and c are two
characters a c and d will also give us
only one match because it will find a c
and then it will leave d as a single
character but when we check a c d and e
or this string in particular it will
find two matches because it will
consider a and c as one of the matches
and d and e as one of the matches so
below is basically what we're doing
basically the same thing we're just
using rd.search for each of these
different examples
so if i if you see when i use find all
on acde and when i'm searching for a two
character match you will see that it
will return me ac and de as you can see
here and similarly for something like
this it will return me again
uh whatever like two character patterns
it finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier then the character
symbol is basically used to check if a
string starts with a certain character
so if you look at these two this picture
if you have two two expressions that
we're going to check over here one is
the one is checking if a
is the beginning of a string and the
other one will check if a
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first string will be a match
because it's only the character a and it
will match here as well because this
string starts with a but it will not
match here because this string starts
with b
now if i look at this
particular expression
you can see that um
this is going to search for if the
string starts with a and is followed by
a b so it will match in this case
because a does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
a because it's not followed by a b
so out here is basically us using the
ie.search to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol so the dollar
symbol that you can see here is used to
check if a string ends with a certain
character and we have already seen how
this is used in one of the uh one of the
earlier examples
so this is going to check basically if
so this expression will check if the
string ends with a so this this string
is basically the character a so it will
match this also ends with a so it will
match and this particular string does
not end with a so it will not match and
we are going to do that using the re dot
search over here so as you can see it
finds a match
in the first character itself here in
this case it finds a match in the last
character but in cab there is no match
so it returns us a none another example
is
of the meta characters is star so this
is the symbol for star and this what the
star basically is used is for checking
if there are zero or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it so now if
you see here what this will check for is
um is there any form of
m and a
that occurs before n and it's very
important to note that
the n has to follow the a in this case
so let's look at these examples and what
will happen so if i checked it with m
and n this is actually a match because
n is followed by zero occurrences of m
and a which is if it might seem a little
weird but it is technically the truth
because
uh the the star symbol checks for not
doesn't check for the existence it just
checks for if n occurs it must occur
after an a
or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the n occurs after an m and it's
fine because there is no a
now you will see when it will not work
so m a and n is obviously fine m a uh m
triple a n is also fine because n
follows an a and there's an m here
this however main will not match now why
even though we have m and a and we have
an n you see the n is immediately
followed by an i
is n follows an i immediately or the n
is preceded by an i immediately and this
is a no match because our the strict
condition in the search is that n
must
uh proceed then a if the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here we're just going
to use the id dot search for these
examples that we saw over here in terms
of code using the re dot search
as you can see here finally we have the
next meta character which is the plus
symbol yes so the plus symbol matches
one or more occurrences of the pattern
left to it now this is very similar to
what we saw earlier in terms of the star
except now in the plus the key
difference is we're looking for one or
more occurrences instead of
zero or more occurrences that we were
looking for in the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now we need what is there to the left of
the plus sign at zero uh no occurrence
of it will not be allowed or will not
cause a match
so let's see now what we're going to do
here we're going to use the same
expression except we're going to replace
the star with the plus sign so now what
we're going to say is okay we need m and
a at least one occurrence followed by an
n the all of these conditions have to be
met so again if you took the first
example m and n this time it will be a
no match because there is no occurrence
of an a over here for preceding the n so
it's a no match m a and n is a match
because well this is this is perfectly
fine m triple a and n is also perfectly
fine but if you look at m a i and n much
like earlier the n
is uh preceded by an i and not an a so
there is no match and again women is
perfectly fine and we basically execute
the same thing through the search
function in this piece of code the next
meta character is the question mark the
question mark symbol matches 0 or 1
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it
so let's see what this does so now
we saw the star
the star which was 0 or more occurrences
of the pattern to the left of it we saw
the plus which is one or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it now we will see the question mark
which is zero or one only zero or only
one and not zero or more of one or more
which was the previous cases only zero
and one or one occurrences of the
pattern to the left of it again we're
going to see the same expression except
we're going to replace the meta
character with the question mark so now
let's see what what happens when we
match
so if you see here m and n is a match
because there is zero occurrence of a
and one occurrence of m preceding n so
this is fine
this is also fine because there is one
recurrence of a and m and then it's
followed by an n
this will not be fine because now we
have three occurrences of a
which is followed by an n we're only
looking for 0 or 1.
this again main will be a no match for
the same reasons that we have already
gone through and women will be a match
again for the same reasons
and we do the same things using the
search function in this piece of code
the next meta character is the braces
character now the braces character is
interesting because what we're going to
do is we're going to see if there are
so uh that is the typical syntax for the
braces is an uh brace followed by some
integer n comma integer m and then close
braces so what this means is we're
looking for at least n and at most m
repetitions
of the pattern left of the braces let's
see through an example
if you see this expression we're looking
for at least two
and at most three occurrences of this
the character a in our test strings so
let's see what happens in the first case
we have no matches in this case because
this part of the string contains only
one a and even this part of the string
only contains one a we're looking for at
least two and at most three
this part will contain one match the
second the second example because the
second part of the string actually
contains
two is for one
two uh repetitions of ace con
consecutively
but this uh in the end and in the third
example you can see both the strings
actually contain matches so we get two
matches because as you can see here
there's two a's here followed by three
a's here
now when we look at this particular
string let's look at what happens now so
what we're going to find is that this
thing is perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a but now we have four
occurrences of a but what the
search engine is going to recognize is
this first three is and is going to see
okay so there are three occurrences of a
and i already have a match it's not
going to consider this fourth a and the
search it will just look at the first
three and i say okay there are uh three
a's and my my match is fine so again
there are two matches in this case
again we're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case now let's see the find all option
and see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all so when we use find
all it basically gives us each of the
instances where the match has occurred
in each of these lists
now let's try to use a slightly more
complicated example where we combine
different
let's say different meta characters and
we create a a more sophisticated
expression that we want to search in our
test strings so if you look at this
expression what we're looking for is
0-9 now a dash symbol is valid in python
using regex because what this basically
tells it is that it's looking for either
0 1 2 3 4 so on until 9 basically any of
the digits you're looking for any of the
digits from 0 to 9 and we are going to
check if at least two and at most four
occurrences of digits if they are there
or not in our particular code so let's
see what are the matches that happens
when we use it on test strings so if you
use it on this string you can see it
will find one match this basically this
particular part of the string where it
says one two three so this is uh three
occurrences of digits so it's fine
now when we look at this whole string 12
and whatever this is
you will see this will not find a match
here this obviously will not because
these are characters but if you look at
over at this part it will find matches
in the in terms of the first four and
then seven and three the next two
one and two again there are no matches
because there's only single occurrences
of digits we're looking for it at at
least two and at most four so if i use
the find all
you will see like what all it will
return so for the first test string what
is going to return me is it's going to
determine 1 2 and 3 as you can see here
but now if you look at this test string
it's going to return me 12 is going to
return me 3 4 5 and 6 is going to return
me 3 4 1 and 2 but not 7 because we are
looking for at least 2 and then it's
going to return me 4 5 6 and 7 followed
by 8 and 8 as you can see in this list
over here
now if we use curly braces with only one
digit it's basically telling the search
engine that uh we want exactly so many
repetitions of the preceding uh whatever
kind of expression that we have
so when we do this example for uh for
example we're basically saying that we
want
x
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times
in our particular expression and then it
should be followed by an x again which
will not match in this case because
there are only two dashes and it will
match in this case because there are
exactly three dashes and it will again
not not match in this case because there
are four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object match followed by none
next we move on to the alternation um
the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of a and b so a should be followed
by a b and uh basically this pattern has
to keep going on so in the first string
over here this pattern will not match in
the second string over here uh we will
have a match because we at least find an
a even though there is no b
but this is still considered match
because we did find an a at least over
here we'll have three matches because we
have a followed by a b followed by an a
again so if we did a reg expression for
this we would basically find these many
matches for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis is basically used to group
sub patterns
so let's look at an example to
understand what we mean now if you look
at this complicated expression what this
means is that i want some form of x and
z the x and z have to occur together but
before that what i want is some form of
a following b following c
some sort of alternation between a b and
c so this part as you can see here is
kept in a parenthesis because i want
this whole condition to basically occur
before i find an x and z so let's look
at what happens here
in the first case we don't have a match
because uh there this basically this
parenthesis condition is not being met
the x and z is preceded by a space
or basically the a and b is preceded is
followed by a space so if this space
didn't occur we would actually find a
match as you can see in the next example
here you can see a and b occur basically
this uh initial condition is met
followed by x and z so there is a one
match so it's fine for us now if you
look at this slightly more a trickier
one what you can see is we have two
matches in this case first in a followed
by x and z and then we have
c a and b now
this is perfectly fine because we we are
looking for a b
followed by an x and z we're looking for
either of these things we're looking for
some form of alternation of these things
followed by an x and z and we can get
that over here we get b followed by an x
and z so you'll get two matches in this
case now let's go through the concept of
grouping constructs now that you've seen
many meta characters you've seen how
parenthesis works let's look at grouping
constructs so grouping constructs break
up a regex in python into sub
expressions or groups and this serves
two purposes one is a grouping part
which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity and
any additional meta characters apply to
the entire group as a unit and then
there's the capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group you can retrieve
captured matches later through several
different mechanisms so let's look at
basically what we mean by this example
over here so if you see this this
expression has a plus sign so we're
looking for a as you know a plus looks
for one or more occurrence so this will
basically check for one or more
occurrence of the character r only
because there's no parentheses as in
this example so this plus is
next to an r and it's going to check for
basically
whether one or more occurrence of r
happens uh preceding b and a but if we
actually put b a and r in a parent
thesis followed by plus it will actually
check for the entire string bar and it
will check one or more occurrences of
bar together so if you look at the these
two examples when we use this uh on
these examples you can see that these
are fine like these matches are fine but
if i used this
parenthesis then these would be the
acceptable matches and like ba triple r
would not be a match if i use
parenthesis
as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parent thesis work
so let's look at some other examples so
what this will do is f-o-o has to be
optionally followed by
b-a-r and b-a-r must exist together
and
this is because we have a question mark
here this question mark symbol tells us
that there should be zero or one
occurrences
similarly this particular complicated
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences of whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing
is followed by a plus so we're looking
for this whole sequence for one or more
occurrences of it cow is simply just cow
we're looking for this pattern and this
is going to check for
zero or one occurrence of cow
because of the existence of the question
mark for uh preceded by the parenthesis
in this video we're going to continue
our discussion on regular expressions
now that you know the basics of regular
expressions
let's continue our discussion with
special sequences now in an earlier
video on strings you might have
encountered what is an escape sequence
and how we use the backslash character
to generate these escape sequences and
an escape sequence is basically if you
remember
something that we use to either
give certain special meaning to
characters that are otherwise ordinary
or it is used to remove the special
meaning that are inherently present in
certain characters that we call meta
characters so let's look at what special
sequences are in relation to regular
expressions
so the first one we're going to look at
is the backslash capital a which is used
to match if specified characters are at
the present are present at the start of
a string
so out here if you can see we are
checking if the word
d is present in these two strings so we
would get a match in the first case over
here because this starts with the word
the but in the second case we won't get
a match
and this is how we're going to check it
for the same thing using the find all
function
so if you see in the first case it gives
us it returns us an object because we do
find d in the beginning of the string in
the second case we get us empties list
because this string does not start with
the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash b small b now this is used to
match if specified characters at the
beginning or at the end of a word so
when you use backslash small b
and then you follow it up with whatever
you're looking for it would look for the
that particular those particular
characters or that pattern if it exists
in the beginning of a word in a string
so if you look at the first example it
starts with f double o and in the second
example you see this portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double o so it will also
match
however in this string which is very
similar to the second one we don't have
a space between a and f and it's
basically one word so this does not
start with f double o but it actually
starts with afo and it won't match as
you can see here
now similarly if we wanted to check if
something exists in the back of a string
at the end of a string we type what we
want to search for first and then we
follow it with a backslash small b and
then if you see here it will match in
this first case it will match in the
second case because this part of the
string ends with f double o but it will
not match in this case because well we
remove the space so now this whole thing
becomes a uh the string that we're
looking for and it does not end with fw
anymore and this is basically us just
checking it through the find all
function
now the next scale the next special
sequence that we will be looking at is
the slash capital b which is basically
the opposite of what we just saw this
matches only if the specified characters
are not at the beginning or the end of a
word so if you see here this is checking
if f double o is not at the beginning of
these strings so in this case there will
be a no match in this case also it'll be
a no match and this third case there
will be a match similarly if we wanted
to see if something does not end with a
particular string we would type that
whatever pattern we're looking for
followed by a backslash capital b
and then we can use the find all
function to generate us lists wherever
we find such objects
find such matches in our particular test
strings like we have done over here so
the next one that we're going to look at
is the backslash small d and this
matches any decimal digit which is
equivalent to doing a square brackets
0-9
as you've seen you must have seen
earlier so if we did a square bracket
0-9 and if we did a search or a find all
or a match it would look for any of the
digits between 0 and 9 so a similar
thing can be done using a special
sequence backslash small d so as you can
see there will be three matches in this
case because one two and three digits
exist whereas in this case for the word
python there will be no matches
so these are certain examples where we
are doing the same thing using the
backslash d
now we have another one which is the
backslash capital d and this is just
basically the opposite it matches for
any non-decimal digits it's also
equivalent to typing a carrot inside
square brackets with 0-9 which if you
remember from the previous video is
basically asking us to check for
anything that is not
the digit 0 to 9.
so this basically we're going to check
in these two strings if there is no
digits and no non-decimal digits so if
you see here we will we will find three
matches a b and the
double double inverted commas and in the
second string we will find no matches
because this is fully just digits next
we have backslash small s now this
matches where a string contains any
white space character so this is equal
to doing a
check for all of these so this is like
backslash small t is a check for tab
space backslash small n is a check for
break line and then backslash r black
slash f backslash b uh are their own uh
checks for
different sorts of white space
characters that you can see by just
looking it up honestly but yeah so if
you simply do a backslash s it would
actually be the equivalent of searching
for any of these uh white space white
space characters that we generate
so if you see here
when we do a backslash s on this string
you can see that there is one space over
here so it will match it will give us
one match because there is one white
space which is just the normal space
here and in the second example there is
no match because there is no white space
here
similarly slash capital s now as you
might have noticed is basically checking
for a string which does not matches in a
string wherever there is no white space
characters so it's basically the same as
doing carrot slash t slash n slash r
slash f slash v in a square brackets so
this is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
and a carrot symbol so if you see this
expression backslash capital s now we're
looking at uh a space b so over here if
you see it'll match for all the
non-spaces so it's going to match for a
and b so we're going to get two matches
here whereas an empty string does not
contain
well it does not contain any non-white
space character since an empty string is
basically a white space character on its
own so this would be this will give us a
no match so the next special sequence
that we're gonna look at is the
backslash small w
uh this matches any alphanumeric
character which is the equivalent of
doing a to z in small and then capital a
to z and zero to 9 for and also an
underscore check in square brackets um
it's also it's important to note that
the underscore is considered an alpha
minimum character hence why we include
it over here but yeah this is this uh
backslash w uh small w which basically
checks for any alphanumeric character
and matches it in a string so if you see
in this first case
it will find three matches at one two
and also at the letter c these others
are not alphanumeric characters uh
whereas in this string none of these are
alphanumeric characters we will get no
match again much like the other examples
there is a capital there's a backslash
capital w which will check for any
non-alphanumeric character and it's the
equivalent of doing whatever we did
before in uh in the square brackets just
with a preceded by a carrot sign so if
you see here we have this string where
we have a bunch of characters well yeah
only one of them this uh percentage
symbol is a non-alphanumeric character
so we will get one match over here but
in this case in the string python we
will get no matches because they are all
alphanumeric characters which is doing
the same thing here with a bunch of
different examples using the find all
function now the backslash capital z
matches if the specified characters are
at the end of a string now don't confuse
this with
backslash
small b plus the backslash small b
checks for a string and it checks each
and every word in the string
individually and checks if so if any of
the words ends with a particular thing
or or starts with a particular thing but
it checks each word individually but in
this case the backslash capital z will
check the string only and not each word
so if you see the difference here in an
um when you use capital backslash
capital z um it will match in this first
example but it won't match for the next
two but if you used a
backslash small b over here it would
actually match not only the first
example here but it will also match in
the second example because it would
check this word individually and it will
find out that yeah there is a match here
as well so it would actually match in
the second example as well in this video
we will be covering the topic of
serialization in python now object
serialization is very simply put when we
want to convert a data structure or an
object type uh and we want to translate
this into
a form that is that can be stored in in
in a memory such as a a file or a memory
buffer
uh
later we could uh deserialize this
particular file and reconstruct the
original object out of it now in python
this is done object serialization is
done by converting the state of any
object into a byte string this byte
stream can be further stored in any file
like objects such as addis file or
memory stream it can also be transmitted
via sockets deserialization as i
mentioned earlier is the process of
reconstructing the object from the byte
stream now in python we refer to the
serialization and deserialization by the
terms pickling and unpickling so the
pickle module which is which is a module
that is a part of the standard library
of python um it provides functions for
serialization such as the dump and the
dumps function and also for d
serialization with load and loads
the data format of piccolo module is
specific to is very python specific and
so programs that are not written in
python may not be able to deserialize
the
pixel data properly
and it's also considered unsecured to
unpickle data from
unauthenticated sources
so in this example here what i'm going
to do is
i'm going to the i'm going to take the
dictionary object
which is uh represented by dct and its
byte representation will be stored in a
file called pickled.txt
and uh
we will also gonna enable the write and
binary mode preemptively so if you can
see here first i'm importing the pickle
package and then i'm opening
my file pickle.txt and write in binary
mode
then i create this dictionary and i'm
going to dump this dictionary into that
particular file and then i'm going to
basically close the file so this uh
executing this would do this now it's
important to note apical file cannot is
not a human
readable file
a computer can understand this but it's
uh some so the byte representation of
any object or data type cannot be
read by a human in plain sight
so this next part is where i'm going to
deserialize or i'm going to unpickle the
file.txt so again i'm importing pickle
i'm opening opening this file in
read in binary mode and what i'm going
to do is i'm going to load this into d
um this will basically in a way
deserialize whatever was there in
pixel.txt and once i have unloaded it in
d i'm going to print what's the content
of d which should be my original
dictionary itself so when i execute this
you can see that printing d prints my
original dictionary that we had before
and it's important to note since
dictionaries are unordered so dictionary
objects don't retain the order of
insertion of keys so in the way so the
way we enter the keys inside the
dictionary
when we create it is not maybe the same
way that we will see the
the order of the key the key value pairs
when we actually unload it
now there exists a dumps function inside
the pickle module that pickles python
data to a string representation so we're
going to do that in this next piece of
code so i'm importing the dumps function
from the pickle module and i have my
same dictionary what i'm going to do is
i'm going to dump this dictionary into
dct string and i'm going to print tct
string
to show you like what exactly
a string representation of this
dictionary would typically look like so
when you execute this um you see this
something very cryptic so this is
basically
what we mean by string representation um
of course we can use the loads function
again to unpick up whatever we just did
and get the original dictionary
representation of this particular string
so that's what we're doing in this piece
of code and as you can see we get back
our dictionary over here so now in our
second example what we're going to do is
um we're going to create slightly more
complex data structures and we're going
to do some uh serialization
deserialization on them so we have this
function called store data where uh we
initialize two dictionaries called omkar
and jagdish with some certain key value
pairs
now we create another
another dictionary empty dictionary
called db which will be like a database
and now this db has two keys again
called omkar and jagdish once again and
now if you notice
my keys my new keys are omkar and
jagdish but their values are
these new dictionaries again so um we're
basically storing a dictionary within a
dictionary so as to speak so once we
have done that what we're going to do is
we're going to create a another file
called
example pickle and we're going to create
it in binary mode now once we've done
that we're going to dump this this
dictionary db into
this
this file called
db file where we have opened basically
where we're going to store the the
serialized representation of this
dictionary called db and then we're
going to close so this is what store
data will do when we call this function
and in load data what we're going to do
is we're going to print out um what each
key and what uh what it represents so um
we're going to basically deserialize in
the load data function we're going to
deserialize whatever we just serialized
in the previous function so when we
execute this we should basically get
something like ohm card followed by this
sort of an arrow sign and whatever the
dictionary that we have assigned to ohm
cut is similarly for jagdish as well so
when we do store data it will basically
do the serialization process um and when
we do load data it should do the
deserialization and print out the
original the db dictionary that we
created in store data over here
so let's execute these two
oops i did not execute the load data
so now it should work
yeah so if you see now when i when i
have executed load data i get back um so
basically from store data i first
serialized my whole file into a
particular file called db file and once
i have done that i have deserialized it
using the load data function over here
in this video we will be covering the
topic of python partial functions
now partial functions allow us to fix a
certain number of arguments for a
function and generate a new function
uh the funct tools or partial module
helps us achieve this now let's say we
want to create a function that
explicitly performs exponentiation so we
can get squares cubes and other power
power operations on any number
so let's look at an example so we create
this function called power where we have
a base and an exponent so what this does
is it will basically print some number
which is the base to the power of some
exponent and the result which will be
returned over here so let's define let's
see now what if we want to create a
dedicated square in cube functions that
leverages this so we can define a square
function called with an argument called
base where we return the power of the
same base to the power of two so we're
basically we're doing for we're defining
a square function
with the help of this function that we
defined already called power
for cube we will basically do the same
power function but the exponent will be
3 so now when we do square 10 we are
going to say if we executed all of this
so now if we say square 10
what this will do is it would say 10 to
the power of 2 is 100 and
if you see the next one cube 5 5 to the
power 3 should be 125 as you can see
here now this works but what if we want
to create
say 15 to 20 variations of our power
functions and what about say 1 000 of
them writing a
defining a function for each case is
obviously very repetitive it's annoying
and this is where we will find partials
coming into play so as an example let's
do the same thing now what we're going
to do is we're going to import partial
from the module called func tools we
have a
what we're going to define is this
function called square which is
basically going to use the partial
functions
operation for the power function with
the exponent of two so what we're doing
is basically we're going to use the
power we're going to reference the power
function that we defined earlier but
we're going to pass the uh the argument
for exponent s2 and for cube we're going
to do the same thing but exponent is 3.
so once you've defined this if you do
square 2 you get the result as you can
see for cube 2 you get the result as you
can see here let's look at another
example so we have this function where
we defined some function with
four arguments now what we're going to
do is argument a b c and x right so
we're going to return thousand times a
100 times plus 100 times b plus 10 times
c plus x now we're going to create a
partial function that calls this
function but it's going to use
a as 3 b as 1 and cs4 always
right and so that how we do that is
basically g is equal to partial like
this so once we've executed these
now if we say g10 we basically get the
value for
a thousand times
well thousand times three since a is
three plus hundred times b as one so
hundred times one plus ten times where c
is four so ten times four plus x now x
we passed is 10 so the result of all
this will be 33 31 50 as you can see
here
now let's look at the final example
where i've defined some function called
add i have three arguments a b and c
what i returned from the sat function is
100 times a plus 10 times b plus c so
let's create a partial for using partial
functions where b and b is 1 and c is 2.
so we have this fixed
we can create a partial function called
add part so what this does is it takes
the add function it creates a partial
function out of it using c is equal to 2
and b is equal to 1. so now when i print
add part 3 what happens here is
3 gets passed in the form of a so i get
3 3 times 100 and since b is fixed as 1
and c is 2 so i get 3 times 100 plus
1 times 10 plus 2 so it should give me
312 so when i execute this you can see
this here
in this video we will be covering the
topic of closures now before we
understand what a closure is we have to
understand what is a nested function and
non-local variables
now a function which is inside another
function is known as a nested function
nested functions are able to access
variables of the enclosing scope so if i
define this function called outer
function where i pass some argument
called text and i store that in a
variable called text again and if i
create a function within this call
linear function and i want to print
whatever this variable is in text
when i execute this it will be able to
access this variable because it's within
the enclosing scope so if i set outer
function hey this gets stored in the
variable text and then the inner
function will print that variable which
is basically the string here
as you can see here
now inner function can easily be
accessed inside the outer function body
but not outside of its body so here
inner function is treated as a nested
function which uses text this this
variable text as the non-local variable
now a closure is a function object that
remembers values in enclosing scopes
even if they are not present in memory
it is a record that stores a function
together with an environment it's a
mapping basically that associates each
free variable of the function which are
basically variables that are used
locally
but are defined in an enclosing scope
with the value or reference to which the
name was bound when the closure was
created a closure which is uh which
unlike a plane function allows the
function to access those captured
variables through the closures copies of
their values or references even when the
function is invoked outside the scope so
let's look at an example to emphasize on
what what was just said
so again i've created i've defined this
function outer function where i'm doing
the same thing now i've defined the same
inner function where i'm going to print
the same thing now it's very important
that when i return over here what i'm
going to return is inner function but
it's not going to be a function call
this is important to
create our closure so we return in our
function but with without
using the call as we do over here
and what this return will do is
basically to create the enclosure sorry
the closure
where the inner function
will remember the values of the
variables stored in the enclosing scope
so now i'm going to store this
outer function in an object called my in
a variable called my function now when i
call this my function
you can see there will be two things
that are happening here so once i've
defined this and i've executed this
what happens out here is this function
has already executed and then i'm
storing it to this
but because i've done return inner
function without parent thesis i have
created a closure basically and this
closure allows the inner function to
remember the values that were stored in
text at any point and at every point
even after the execution of this one
time so when i execute this again for
the second time over here it will
remember the value that was stored in
the variable text which is hey which was
which was given over here
that's why you see when i execute it for
the second time over here the first time
being in this line when i'm storing it
in my function when i execute in the
second time again it will give me the
result of hey
as you can see the closures have to
invoke functions outside the scope the
function error function has a scope only
inside the outer function but with the
user closures we can extend its scope to
invoke a function outside the scope so
now let's look at this code so this code
don't worry about what's going on here
just know that what we are doing here is
we have two functions which we defined
called add x and y which will return x
plus y and the subtract function which
will subtract x and y
so
now we're going to execute these once
we're going to execute the add over here
and add logger and we're going to
execute the
subtract function and we're going to
store it in sub logger so technically we
have already executed these two
functions but now
uh since i've created an x an enclosure
basically uh if you see here this is the
enclosure that i have created now what
happens is
when i
access this function from outside its
initial scope which is basically over
here this was the initial scope when i
access it outside you will see that it
is it still has access to these
variables x and y so if you see here i
i first of all i've allowed this uh this
the enclosing function to accept uh
arguments of any numbers so
uh i can pass xy i can pass xyz also but
if you see here i would i only have
thing for x and y so
when i want to access any value of x and
y even after the execution of this code
initially
i have access to these variables x and y
and that is because i created a closure
out of
that so if you see if i do add logger 3
and 3 over here i'm able to get the
result six if i do add logger 4 and 5
i'm able to get the result 9. similarly
for subtraction logger 10 and 5 i will
get 5 here and 20 and 10 i'll get 10
here and uh i can keep doing this i can
keep saying add logger in fact if i say
4 and 7 so if i executed this
and now i'm going to say let's say for
example add logger
if i set 4 and 7 here
so this still has access to my variables
x and y because i've created the closure
and it should give me 11. similarly if i
did sublogger say 30 and 15 it should
give me 15 because 30 minus 15 so let's
say 30 minus 16 right so it should give
me 14 because again i have created the
closure and it has access to these
variables already in this video we are
going to be learning about the topic of
decorators to start off with let's first
understand some basic concepts
now in python we know that functions are
first class objects and that means that
functions are objects and they can be
referenced to and they can be passed to
a variable and they can be returned from
other functions as well
functions can also be defined another
function and can be passed as an
argument to other functions
so decorators allow programmers to
modify the behavior of a function or
class
decorators allow us to wrap another
function in order to extend the behavior
of the wrapped function without
permanently modifying it
now any generic functionality that you
can tack on to an existing class or
functions behavior makes a great use
case for decoration some of these
include rate limiting caching logging
enforcing access control and authentic
authentication instrumentation and
timing functions now you have to
remember
that function names are references to
functions and that we can assign
multiple names to the same function so
for example if you see here
i have
defined a function called success
which does uh basically you pass an
integer and it returns one plus side
integer so if i do success 10 it should
give me 11 as you can see here
now if i'm if i'm gonna say successor is
equal to success i've basically created
another function called successor which
does the same job as a success function
so now if i pass 20 to successor it
should return 21
as you can see here so as you can see
that we have two names success and
successor for the same function
an important fact is that we can delete
either one of the any of the functions
and um you won't delete the other one so
if i said delete success and if i tried
to pass 10 to the other function called
successor
it would still execute the
whatever task the function is supposed
to do
now let's look at an example of a
function inside a function so i've
defined a function called f
in which i have defined another function
called g which has two print statements
that you can see here the function f
itself has two print statements
and
in at the end of the execution of
function f we call this function g so
let's see what happens when we actually
execute f
so
let's uh look at it on this side
so if you see here this is where i've
defined it now let's call my function f
and let's see what happens as you can
see
first when you execute function f it
will create this function
and then it will print these functions
and then it will do a call to this and
when we call this function g it's going
to do two of its own print statements as
you can see in this order over here
so this is an example of a function
within another function
let's look at another example of
something similar
if you see here i've defined a function
called temperature where i can pass
some value for t and have a i have
defined another function within this
called celsius to fahrenheit and
basically i'm doing the conversion so
when i execute this what it should
return me is
i'll pass some temperature and it and it
will return me the temperature in
degrees so for example
in this case i have passed temperature
20 so let's see what uh does it pass
what result does it give to me in
degrees
as you can see it says it's 68 degrees
now let's look at another example of a
function within a function for a very
common example for the factorial
function so if you see here i've defined
factorial n and i'm saying if the value
that is passed in n is equal to 0
returned me 1 otherwise return me the
product of that number times and i'm
going to do a recursive call back to the
same function except now i'm not going
to pass n but n minus 1. so what this
should do is if i pass 10 for example it
will basically check okay since 10 is
not equal to 0 it will go here and it
will return me 10 times factorial of 9
and that will do 10 times 9 times 8 and
then so on until we reach uh n is equal
to zero where it will just say okay
return one so what you will effectively
get is ten times nine times eight times
seven so on until one which is basic
factorial of whatever we have passed so
let's execute this
see i'm going to check what is the
factorial of 5 here and as you can see
it gives me 120.
now let's have a let's include a line
a negative says an exception
by an else statement which will
basically raise a type error and it will
tell me that
if i pass a number n which is not an int
and if it's not greater than or equal to
0 it should give me this error message
so i have included this extra statement
in this just to check so if i pass 9 as
you can see it should give me a valid
result which is three six two eight
eight zero now what if i passed minus
five so let's execute this
as you can see i get the the type error
that i have raised over here in case i
made such a condition and in this case
you cannot find the factorial of a
negative integer so that is why my type
error gets raised over here
if you actually look closely at this
program you will notice that each time i
call back my function factorial so if i
gave it five initially it will check for
the uh this this condition
and since it's it will meet the
condition we can continue but the next
time when we call factorial for four
and then for three and two each time is
going to do this check
that's kind of redundant because we know
that if we pass 5 in the beginning until
we decrement it to 0 we're going to only
get the valid numbers 5 4 3 2 and 1 so
we don't need to do this check at every
point we just need to do one check so
and a workaround for this
would be
in this code that i'm i've written over
here
and in this i've basically defined a
factorial function called n which will
where i'll pass my
integer initially and within that i've
defined the actual function where the
actual results will be calculated and
that's called inner factorial this is
where the um this is basically the
actual factorial calculating part and if
you see this if statement block this is
my check so
this will basically be the only check
that will happen so out here it will
check whether the n i have passed is a
valid integer and equal to or greater
than zero and if it is then we will
perform this inner factorial function
where we won't be doing any more
suspects we will only calculate the
factorial
and if it's not then we will raise this
exception just once
and we will exit the program in case
we've given a wrong number so let's look
at an example for three so as you can
see at each step of my calculations i'm
going to return whatever value i have at
that point so
basically if i give 3 you'll notice that
you will get 0 1 2 and 6 if you multiply
it in the right way so let's do this as
you can see factorial 3
one second so i have to execute this
now if i execute this you can see i
first get because initially it will
check um
when i move into inner factorial check
if n is equal to equal to zero it will
basically return whatever value i have
at that point so basically this is the
uh order of calculations in number in a
backward way so you can see here it will
first be
one and then 1 times 2 and then 2 times
3 which is 6 which is what we get so
don't worry about the order in which we
are
returning these values this is basically
just
a reverse way in which the the program
will fetch our values
so yeah this was basically how we reduce
the redundancy in in the check in the
check part of our function
now let's look at some examples where a
function will be returning another
function so as we know the output of a
function is also a reference to an
object and therefore functions can
return references to function objects so
out here if you see i've defined a
function called f which will take a
parameter called x and then within it
i've defined a function called g which
will have a parameter called y
and this g will basically return y plus
x plus 3 and the function f itself will
return the function g so
if i pass 10 in function so what this
will do is it will create a function
called g and you create an instance of a
function called g
and that object is going to be returned
to us because we basically return g when
we call function x right so if i execute
this you will see that when i say f10 it
will give me some
object location of a function called g
now if i want to see the result of what
i get for this function g i have to pass
something within g itself so out here
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
store this function object in a variable
called nf1 once i've done that i can
pass another parameter
for this nf1 object
and since we know this nf1 is a variable
name for the function g so when i pass
nf120 i'm basically passing this y
parameter so since now i have passed 10
for x and i have passed 20 for y oops
one second yeah so
what i will get returned is 20 plus 10
plus 3 which is 33 when i do nf1 and i
pass 20 as the parameter here as you can
see i get 33 over here
now let's look at a function where we
will implement polynomials of degree two
and then we will actually
extend that to polymer polynomials of
any degree so i have created a function
called polynomial creator
where i pass three
arguments which will represent the
coefficients so a will represent the x
square coefficient b will represent the
x coefficient and see the constant so i
have defined within this i've defined a
polynomial function called x where i
will pass my value for the variable x
and i want to get returned the um the
value for this polynomial so as you can
see here uh initially when i the first
function will return this object and
then for this object itself i'll have to
pass another
argument where i'll pass the value of x
so let's create so i'm going to create
two instances of this polynomial
function in and in the first instance my
coefficients are as you can see 2 3 and
minus 1. in the second case it'll be -1
2 and 1. so once i execute this oops let
me execute the function initially yeah
there you go so if you if i if i execute
p1 it will basically give me a object
location of the polynomial function for
p1
which is represented by this basically
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to iterate through
values between minus 2 and 2 not
including 2 at steps of 1 so i'm going
to iterate for minus 2 minus 1 0 and 1
and i'm going to say
initially print me the values of x that
i'm going to pass in this column this
first column and then i'm going to say
okay what are the results for the first
polynomial object where the coefficients
are 2 3 and minus 1 and then in this
column give me the values of the
polynomial with these coefficients minus
1 2 and 1. so when i execute this as you
can see these are my results now what if
i wanted to do the same thing for
arbitrary coefficients as in
a polynomial of nth degree you know i'm
not specifying the exact degree so this
i can do with this slightly uh slightly
more complicated program which is
actually very very simple so if you see
this function i've defined a polynomial
created function again but in this case
i have passed variable number of
arguments so this asterisk basically
means i can have any number of arguments
here
and this will be an iterable with
any n number of objects that can be
iterated upon so and that will be called
coefficients so within that again i've
defined polynomial x now what i've done
is i've initialized some variable called
res which is basically be my result
variable
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
for loop through this coefficients
interval and what this basically does is
in a backward way um this is basically
going to iterate through the uh
the array or the list or whatever we
have of coefficients in a backward way
so if i pass
6789 is going to
give me
9876 in that order and what this
enumerate function will do is um it will
assign an index to each of the values
and coefficients so for example i can
just show you over here what
this means so if i created a array
called
um
say coefficients with some some random
values over here right now if i'm going
to
perform this line
right now let's see what happens when we
do a for loop let's see what values we
get for index
and
when we do this execute this line so if
you see here now once i execute this as
you can see
what i have done is coefficients
oh i made a smelly mistake this is
taking from a different
variable so let's
fix this so as you can see
i've entered four objects uh four
integers one twenty three four and forty
five and uh when i do this for loop i
basically want to assign some index
value zero one two and three to each
value in this list but in a backwards
manner so this will be the zeroth item
this will be the first this will be the
second this will be the third
so that's what we are doing in this
function as well out here we are
basically
going to use this enumerate function
to now if you see this
this result is basically going to add
each each component of this polynomial
so if you see closely what this is going
to do is it's going to first
in the first step is going to find out
well
what is the value of this the constant
term and then in the next step is going
to find out what is the value of this
and it's going to keep summing it up
it's going to sum this part up this part
up until the end and then we will get
our final result in this variable res
and we're going to return that over here
so if you see here i will have done the
same thing i've created four function
objects
and they're called p one p two p three p
four and now i'm going to iterate
through again minus two minus one zero
and one um as my different x values and
i'm going to see what are the different
values for each of these polynomials so
if you see here my first polynomial is
basically uh it has only one coefficient
so it's a polynomial of the zeroth
degree so basically whatever i pass for
x that itself should
be my result
so actually this is the polynomial
degree so this is basically the only
result you will get so the constant is
four you will get four in every result
so if you see here what i'm printing is
the x values first and what are their
respective polynomial values for each of
these objects that we've created so this
is a constant so p1 will only have the
result four
this is p2 so this is a polynomial of
degree one so it's like saying two x
plus four and where x takes values minus
two minus one zero and one and in this
case you can see this is a polynomial of
fourth degree so it's like saying um x
to the power four plus eight x cubed
minus x squared plus three x plus two so
the when we replace x with minus two
minus one zero and one we get the
respective values in the p3 column over
here and for p4 it's a it's a it's
basically a square polynomial
so yeah this is an example of how we can
create um we can do a polynomial creator
and get our results accordingly
now interestingly enough what we've done
here is basically like for example let's
look at p3 right p3 is basically this
polynomial now this polynomial function
inside our decorator uh polynomial
creator so all these examples that i've
been showing you where functions are
within functions um if you think of it
it's it's like i'm giving some basic
function x extra
or like i'm doing something extra within
them right so we can use decorators for
this and um in our example over here
what i can do with this function is i
can implement the same operation more
efficiently by using a decorator within
our main function so we can factorize it
in a way that it does not need any
exponentiation so we can
if you if you think of it this
polynomial can be represented like this
right
if you think of it
it's basically this times x plus some
constant and then that whole thing is
again times x plus some constant since
this is a to the power 4 um this is all
we need but if you think of it if we
keep going further all you have to do is
again enclose it in another bracket and
then do times x so we can basically use
a decorator to do this
so if you look at this function over
here what i've done is i've created the
same
polynomiator with variable number of
arguments but in this inside this
function like
what i've done in the form of a
decorator is that i'm going to
implement this polynomial
in by calculating the result in this
manner where um it's going to be very
much more efficient and you don't have
to keep uh
exponentiating
like how i did in this example so that's
what i'm doing over here and if you see
that is basically implemented over here
through this so when i do the same when
i execute the same thing and if i go
through the for loop again it should
give me the same results but it's it's
much more efficient now let's look at
another example of a simple decorator so
we have a i've defined a function called
our decorator fung now this will
basically be this this is a reference to
another function itself if you see
within this but inside my decorator i
have a function wrapper where i'm going
to print this statement before actually
like calling the function x
before calling the function and i'm
going to perform a print statement again
after that and i'm going to return the
function wrapper at the end of like
executing the decorator so
let's look at what happens when we
define this function
for x so this is basically a simple
print statement where i'm saying hi 4
has been called with um whatever this is
argument
so
now let's execute what happens when i
say foo hi
so as you can see
um let's execute the whole thing so yeah
as you can see here i have executed this
it says this is the print statement that
i've basically written over here and
this is basically this is what gets
printed when i call this function here
now when i move on to the next statement
uh middle what i'm declaring is i'm
going to now decorate foo with f now
what this means is i've now created this
uh of this decorator object basically so
let's let's look at what happens when i
execute this and then i'll try to
explain to you
so when i execute the whole thing you
can see something else is happening now
so we have we call foo after decoration
then we have this before calling foo and
uh this is basically this print function
this is the print function that gets
executed here
now we have this this is the function
call this is basically the function call
um which is this which is basically this
four function
and ah this is this line is being
printed from this so if you see here i
am i'm getting some results from this
like from this decorator itself but i'm
also calling upon the function that is
being referred to by this decorator so
i'm doing two things i'm doing the main
thing which is being executed here which
is the result is here but i'm also
decorating it with these two lines which
comes from this decorator called our
decorator
so
let's look at the explanation so if you
look at the output of this previous
program we can see what's going on and
that is that the decoration for this
when we did this line which was over
here
it's a reference to the function wrapper
which is this now in this function
wrapper this function itself right like
this function that we defined here
that will be called as well but we will
also have a bunch of extra like print
statements in the form of these two
lines which you can see over here before
calling and after calling that we've
also done along with this so this is a
simple example of how we've used a
decorator to modify our basic function
now this usual syntax for decorators in
python is with the at the at symbol so
we can write the same thing like what we
did before
through this so we write at our
decorator and this will basically apply
the decorator to this function for x so
when we do add our decorator and then we
define this function and we call it it
will basically do the the same thing as
um
doing this
for example so if i execute this
you can see the same thing has happened
here
now i'm going to give you another
example of a decorator
remember the factorial function that we
did earlier
where we did a check within the
factorial function but let's see how we
can use decorators to add our case in
this so as we as we know before we
calculate the factorial of something we
want to make sure that whatever we pass
is greater than or equal to zero and
it's an integer right so let's define a
decorator which will basically do this
so this in this decorator what we're
going to do is we're going to call it a
create a function called a helper where
we're going to perform this check
and uh this is going to be our decorator
basically right
however so what this this will do what
this will do is basically this decorator
will say okay if this check is met then
you can perform you can return the value
of function of x which is the function
is what is what we pass
in this
as an argument to the decorator
so
once the check is done we can perform a
factorial so that's what we're going to
do here so we've defined our decorator
now we're going to use the decorator
here and we're going to define within it
a factorial function so when we actually
perform the factorial like for some
numbers
like we're going to do factorial of 1
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten all these are ten digits from one to
nine sorry so if you're going to do that
what it's going to do is at each step um
so for the value one it's going to first
check whether our integer passed is
actually the correct form of an integer
whether it's in integer and greater than
equal to zero so once that is done then
it will move on to the factor actual
factorial function
so when we do for i in range one and ten
since every number is valid we won't get
a like we won't nothing nothing wrong
will happen there won't be any exception
raised but what if we did factorial
minus 1 now now the factorial function
itself doesn't have a check but since we
have a decorator around this factorial
function it's first going to do this
check and if it finds an error it will
raise an exception so if i do this if
you see when my exit when i execute it
raises my exception so this is how we
have added some functionality to the
original factorial function using this
decorator in this video we will be
covering the topics of map filter and
reduce functions in python now python
provides several functions that enable
functional approach to programming and
since functional programming is all
about expressions
some of these expression oriented
functions of python are
lambda functions list comprehensions map
filter
map filter and reduce now we've already
covered the topic of lambda and list
comprehensions
now let's cover the topics of map filter
and reduce
so to start off let's look at the map
function the map function takes in two
attributes a function and a sequence
a function is basically
some defined some user defined function
or any function
a sequence is basically an iterable
object like a list or
a tuple for example or a bunch of lists
and tuples as well so let's look at an
example so one of the most common
operations that we do with something
like a list is
doing an operation on each of the
elements in the list and then
outputting a new list with
the the values as whatever we have
modified to the original items of the uh
list so if we do what if we did the
square of all of these items in this
list and we want to create a list based
on that so we can basically iterate
through it and we can do a square
function and then append those values to
a new list called squared and when we do
this
for example
over here
you can see when we print squared
we should get the list of whatever
square values we have
for the original list but this is uh
slightly a bit tedious and what if we
had a method that or a
what if we had a technique wherein we
could
basically pass a function that we have
that we want to do and a sequence on
which we want to apply this and we pass
it to a function and this function
basically takes care of
applying whatever operations we want to
do on each element of a sequence so this
is where the map function comes in use
so let's look at
how we use the map function over here
so if you look at this i've defined a
square function so the square function
basically returns uh takes an argument x
and it returns the square of it and i
have a map function which takes the
square
function as one of the arguments and the
i the list or an iterable as the second
argument so this map function creates a
map object if you see here so let's just
do it one by one so i'm creating my list
and i'm going to create my function
called square
and i'm going to
send this to the map function so i'm
sending this
the first argument as the function that
i want to do and the second argument as
the list that i want to apply it on now
let's list out all the items that are in
this map object
if you see it creates me a list with
basically the squared items and this is
exactly what we needed and another way
of doing the same thing would be just
going through a for loop in each of the
map objects and printing each which
would give me the same results so if you
see here i found a very neat way of
passing a function and then iterable and
using the map function to apply each
operation that is part of the function
or applying the function on each item in
the iterable
so as you've seen we basically passed in
a user-defined function and we applied
it to each item in the list then the map
calls the square function on each list
item and collects all the return values
into a new list and because map expects
a function to be passed in it also
happens to be one of the places where
lambda functions are
appearing a lot so let's look at the
an example where we do the same
operation using a lambda function so if
you see here i have a lambda function
where
i'm passing it as the function argument
and what this lambda function takes is
some variable x or some argument x it
does its square and it returns that x
and this x is basically going to come
from each element that is present in
this list called items and when we list
down these you will see it basically
does the same thing for us it creates a
list with squared items
now we can also pass instead of passing
an interval itself we can actually pass
a sequence
of functions and use the lambda function
to perform a sequence of functions on
particular items so let's look at a new
example a slightly different one so
we're going to use a numpy module for
this don't worry we're just using it to
use the square root function that is
present in the numpy power module um we
will be learning about number in a later
section so um we're going to import this
first and now i'm going to define three
functions for square cube and square
root
so once i've defined these basically
they're returning the square the cube
root uh the cube and the square root of
some integer x
and now i'm going to create a list of
these for functions that you've just
seen
and we're going to
use a for loop and we're going to
iterate through a range
from 0 to 4
so and we're going to pass this
and we're going to say that we want to
apply
some some function we want to apply some
function x and we want to return that
using this lambda function now what
values this x will take is based on
whatever functions we've stored in this
variable called fu ncs or funcs and in
fu ncs we have a bunch of functions
called square cube and square root that
we have defined earlier so what we're
going to do is we're going to apply each
of these functions to r and r will take
the value 0 to 4 and now let's see when
we print this what values we get so if
you see here we get a list of
square root squares cubes and square
roots for integers 0
3 and 4. so this is another way of using
the map function and lambda functions
together to apply multiple different
operations to a bunch of
intervals now for our next example what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a function that basically
what it does is it creates the upper
case of some string that we passed to it
right so that's what we've done here in
this function called two upper case so
let's define this function now we have a
print function basically which is going
to print each object in a particular um
it's going to print each element of a
particular object and it's going to at
the end of it and the end of printing
we're going to give a small space for
printing a new line basically so let's
create this also this print iterator
object now what we're going to do is
we're going to pass a string with
the letters a b and c to this function
and we're going to map and we're going
to apply the upper case function to this
string now if you remember string is
also an iterable where it's a sequence
of one character strings so this whole
string is basically a sequence of one
character string a one character string
b and c
so we're going to so we can pass a
string as a as an iterable to the map
function because it will apply the
operations on each of these characters
so let's see what happens when we do the
upper case function uh we apply the
upper case function using the map
using mapping to the string a b and c
so if you see it's created me a list
with capital a capital b and capital c
as we had expected
because we have applied the list
function to the map object
now
in the next step what we're going to do
is um we're going to do a very similar
thing we're just going to instead of
simply mapping and creating a list out
of it we're going to store the map
object in a variable called map iterator
we're going to print
what type of object it is and then we're
going to print out each of the elements
using the print iterator function that
we defined here so um let's do this now
if you see the class the type of object
is of class map and the objects elements
inside the object are a b and c
moving on let's uh let's look at now an
example where we're going to pass
multiple arguments um so instead of one
iterable we're going to pass multiple
iterables now and we're going to apply
some sort of an operation
so if you see here what we have done is
we've created two uh two two sequences
one is a list of some numbers and
another is a tuple of some numbers so
just to show you let me first copy this
here um yeah so if you see here i have a
list and a tuple and i'm passing both of
these if you see to this map function
and before that i have defined a lambda
function as the operation that i'm going
to apply and what this does is it takes
two arguments x and y and it returns the
product of both of these uh where does
it get x and y from so the x it gets
from this uh
this sequence which is a list and it
takes y from this sequence which is a
tuple so what it's going to do is going
to take x as 1 and then y is 5 in the
first step and it's going to return the
product as 5. then the next step is
going to take 2 as x and then y as 6 and
it's going to return the product of that
and we're going to get 12 and so on
we're going to get 21 and then 32
when we and this is these values are
going to be stored in the map iterator
which is a map type object and when we
use the print data function it's
basically going to print out uh whatever
results we got
through this mapping so let's execute
this and as you can see this is a result
we got 5 12 21 and 32 which is what we
wanted so the next part the next
function that we're going to discuss is
the filter function now now a filter
function is basically again it takes two
two arguments a function and a sequence
and a function
basically tests if each element of a
sequence is true or not now a sequence
the sequence so this filter function
will basically take two arguments so one
is the function and this function is
basically going to test if each element
of a sequence is true or not and it's
going to take another argument called
sequence and this argument sequence is
the list or the tuple or basically any
sequence and or iterable that needs to
be filtered and it can be
as i mentioned it can be sets list
tuples or containers of more iterators
and what this function will return is an
iterator that is already filtered um so
let's look at an example now so we have
this list r which you've generated which
is basically numbers from -5 to 4. so if
i
create this list here you can see it'll
create a list of minus 5 to 4. now if i
wanted to extract only the values that
are lesser than 0 well i can use a for
loop and use a if condition to check
this right so if i did this over here
you can see it gives me it returns me
some list called result which contains
only the values um lesser than zero
which is basically checked through this
condition what if there was a uh
neat or a more convenient or a more
organized approach to doing the same
thing instead of creating a loop
ourselves what if we defined a function
where we are going to do the test or
we're going to create the condition and
we're going to pass this to a particular
function and then apply that particular
operation on every object of some
sequence well just like mapping we have
a filter function to do this and in this
example what we're going to use is the
lambda function which takes an argument
x and it checks for some condition x
lesser than zero and where it's going to
get the x from is some sequence r
which which in our case is the numbers
from minus five to four and the filter
will basically create a filter object
type which contains uh only the objects
from r that meet this condition that is
x is lesser than zero and when we use
the list operation on top of it you will
see it creates it results in a list with
the values that have met my condition so
for a second example what we're going to
do is we're going to create
a list which
contains a bunch of letters and we're
going to only extract the vowels from
these bunch of letters so let's look at
what we have here we have some letters d
a t j k o p l and we only want the
vowels from this so we want to filter
only the vowels so we can use that using
the filter function by first of all
defining a function that returns true if
a check is met that
one of uh the letter matches one of
these letters in this list called
letters and if it doesn't it returns
false so this is our condition that
we've created once we create this
condition uh this function that checks
this we can pass this function and the
sequence into the filter function and
then we can list out whatever we get so
you can see our filtered list contains
only a and o which is basically the only
vowels that are present in our original
list
finally we have the reduce function
this reduced function is basically a
func tools it's in the functo's module
of python 3.0 and what the reduce
function does is it applies a function
of two arguments cumulatively to the
elements of an interval and it
optionally it starts with an initial
argument and it returns a single result
so let's first import this function
and once we've imported it let's use it
in this example that we have here so in
this example what we're going to do is
we have some lists called numbers right
what if we wanted to take care to get
the sum of each element in this list
well we can iterate over it and store it
in some variable called total in each
step right
this is what we would typically do and
in this step what you can see is the
loop basically iterates over every
valuable in numbers and accumulates them
in total the final result is the sum of
all the values which is the value of 10
over here in this example the variable
total is what we call an accumulator
and we can apply the reduce function to
do the same task so how do we do it
let's first of all create a function
called my add where we're going to take
two variables uh two arguments and we're
going to return the sum of it okay so
let's uh define this function
and um
now we have we have a list called
numbers right which contains one two
three and four now let's do reduce my
add to numbers
now when i do this when i use this
function what it will do is it will
apply the function of my ad
it will take basically
each and every element
uh in a sequence so it will take one and
two then add them together and then it
will create basically what it will do is
it'll take one and two add them together
then we'll have three so it will take
three and then the next element which is
three again so it will create the sum
which is six and then it will take six
and then it will take the value four and
it will give us the result ten so this
is how the reduce function would work so
this is how it will give us the result
of ten
as you can see here i've simply used
i've passed this function where i've
defined that i want two
arguments to be passed to a function and
then the return should be basically the
sum and then i passed a whole list of
like four numbers and i've used the
reduce function to basically do this
process for four numbers in a
step-by-step manner by taking two at a
time subsequently and my result is as
you can see is correct as you can see
here
so let's use the lambda function now to
to do the same topic just do the same
task so what i'm doing now is i'm going
to define a lambda function and that's
the function i'm going to pass to this
reduce so when i pass this lambda
function which basically takes
two two arguments x and y and it's going
to return the sum of that
as x plus y now where it's going to get
x and y from is in a very in a very neat
manner so it will take first the first
two elements one and two it will then do
the sum and we get three then it will
take that same three and then take the
next object which is three again and
then give us six then it will take six
and then the next element which is four
and then give us ten and then the reduce
function will output the the single
result which is 10 to us as you can see
here
so yeah this was our video um our
discussion on map filter and reduce
functions in python i hope it's a
valuable addition to what you already
know about lambda and list
comprehensions
in this video what we will be covering
is certain
abstract data such as structure concepts
and we're going to also use we're going
to implement these abstract data
structures using basic python techniques
and also we're going to get slight
introduction into object oriented
programming
to perform this
or to create these abstract data
structures so you can consider this as
an exercise or an activity in op plus
some basic python concepts so let's talk
about what stack is stack being the
abstract data structure that we are
talking about over here so the name
stack
resembles a pile of objects right it can
be a stack of papers eight hours of
blocks where adding and removing of an
item occurs only at the top of the file
so a stack is an abstract linear data
type which is a collection of objects
that supports fast lastin and first out
semantics for inserts and deletes and
like lists for arrays tags
typically don't allow for random access
to the objects they contain
so
you can't just access something by an
index in a stack you either go from the
top or the bottom of the stack so what
we are going to use is insert and delete
operations which are often called push
and pop respectively
stacks and queues are both linear
connections of collections of items
but however in a queue the least
recently added item is removed first so
it follows a first in
first out
approach on the other hand in a stack
the most recently added item is removed
in the beginning so it's like last in
and first out approach
so a real life example of a stack is a
pile of heavy and precious plates all
kept on top of each other so if you wish
to remove a plate uh if you wish to add
a plate or remove one you can only do
that from the top and if you want to
remove a plate from the lower bottom of
the stack of plates you have to remove
from the top one by one in a practical
example of course a useful real world
analogy for
asa data structures of course stack of
plates it could be a pile of clothes as
well but you typically want to
remove or put everything from on top of
the pile and not in the middle or the
bottom of the pile so yeah so this is a
visual representation of a stack where
um this this whole it's a linear
collection but whatever we do is usually
something to do with the top the the top
most item or the last entered item of
the stack now basic operations that can
be performed in a stack are mentioned
as
follows so there's a push operation
which basically adds an item to the
stack if the stack is full it is called
it is said to be in an overflow
condition there's a pop operation which
removes an item from the stack
it follows a reversed order to pop items
similar to the way when items are pushed
so
in that case we call it an underflow
condition now this peak or top operation
which basically returns the top element
of a stack and then there's the smd is
empty operation which returns true if
the stack is empty and false if it is
not
now the applications of stacks like
where do we use them they can be used to
reverse a string it can be used in
expression evaluation expression
conversion
it is used for forward and backward
features in web browsers it is used in
recursive passing in
nlpms and so many other operations are
there and applications for stacks now
let's understand stack operations so the
two most basic operations are of course
push and pop now when we want to push
what we're basically doing um let's
consider an example so let's consider
editing a python file using the undo
feature in our editor so you we have a
clear understanding of the stack
operations
so at first say a new function called
insert is added the push operation adds
the insert function into the stack so
this is a visual representation of what
we're talking about so we have this
empty list this empty stack initially
and what we're going to push on to this
is the insert
some function says it's called insert or
some some object called insert so once
we've done this this stack looks like
this it has an object called insert
right
now
a word delete is removed let's look at
the next thing now let's say i push
something called delete now onto this
right so if i push delete some object
called delete onto this it goes on top
of the insert stack right because this
is a stack everything occurs in a top
like the last thing that you have added
is the first thing that you will see
from the top so we see delete first in
terms of our example of our python
script assume the script as the whole
stack where we initially had a function
called insert and then we added a
function called delete and now in the
same script we want some comments for
each of these functions so think of it
as another object that we're going to
add on top of all of this thread
so
now we have this python script where we
have the first function called insert
the second function called delete and a
bunch of comments pertaining to these
and that's the last basically that's the
last object that we added to our python
script now let's perform some pop
operations so the first like say we did
undo now we have a python script with
all of these things now let's say we
pressed undo for something like say we
press undo
well what is the first thing that is
going to go of course it's the last
thing that we entered right and the last
thing we entered was a comment so when
we press undo
what gets popped is the topmost thing
which is the comment and the comment is
now gone and what we have left in the
script is the other two things and if we
hit undo again well the next thing that
would be removed is the next most recent
thing that was added which was the
delete function and then if we hit undo
again the insert function will get
removed so this is how the pop function
and the push function works in terms of
stack where i give you the example of
the undo operation in a python script
now let's implement a stack in python
there are some basic implementations and
they they are as follows we can use
lists we can use collections.dq
i'll show you what that is and we can
use the custom method which is basically
the oop example that we were talking
about
and there are numerous third-party
package packages which we may or may not
look into but for the the sake of this
uh particular video we're going to be
looking at these first three cases in
particular
so um let's look at the first option
which is a list built in now the list
the python's list object type already
has a decent stack data structure
approach as it supports push and pop
operations by default so let's create a
a list called s now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to append this
list with a bunch of strings so it's
first i'm going to append it with each
sleep and then code so if you see here
if i print my list
that i'm going to treat as a stack these
are my objects right now if i had to pop
from this list
your question would be well what is the
first object that comes out of this list
well um since we're going to treat this
as a stack and since pop is a stack
operation it will pop out or it will
remove
the the last most added the
the recent the most recent added object
which was
the string code right so if i had to
execute these
you will see when i do the first pop
the object that gets
popped out is the last thing that was
added which is code now if i did pop
again it would remove sleep because that
was again the next most recent one and
finally if i did pop again it will
remove eat
uh
it's importing to node uh oops one
second so if i do this then if i did pop
and then
okay so the so what happened here was
basically the pop um
okay so i'll tell you what uh so let's
look at an example where i'm going to be
using this so let's define my stack as
some list s and i'm going to append each
sleep and code to it so the first object
that gets appended is obviously eat then
sleep and then code so if i were to pop
these objects the first object that
should come out is code followed by
sleep followed by eat so let's look at
what happens when i actually try doing
it so let's print out what's in s if you
see
um this is basically
my my list my list s now my first pop
should remove code
as you can see my next pop should remove
sleep as you can see finally to remove
eat now the question is what if i did
pop again well an underflow error would
occur so if i did pop again you see this
error and it says you cannot pop from an
empty list because i have popped every
item which with three items and the
fourth pop will well there's nothing
else to remove from the list so it gives
me an error
our next option for stack implementation
is using the list uh using the
collections or dq so this is a base
it contains basically python has a
module called collections it can
comprises of the dq class which is a
double ended queue that supports
inserting and removing elements from
either ends of this of an object so
since dqs support adding and removing
from either side
they can serve both as queues and the
stacks as well so let's import this dq
class and i'm going to create an object
called q of class dq and what i'm going
to do is i'm going to do the same thing
i'm going to append each sleep and code
as you can see here let's check what's
in queue well it's a dq object type of
uh it's it's an object of class dq with
the objects each sleep and code so again
if i did the pop operations it should
remove code sleep and eat in that order
because that's the reverse order in
which i have added them in right so
let's look at it code
gets popped first then sleep and then
eat and of course if i try to pop even
further it will it should throw me an
error because um there's it's an empty
dq now there's no objects left in it
now the third object is using custom
it's using custom method uh using
classes and objects
so
this is basically our example of how
we're going to create a class and
use concepts of basic concepts of
object-oriented programming to create
our stack
so let's uh let's start working on this
the so the following stack
implementation assumes that the end of
the list will hold the top element of
the stack as the stack grows
basically as the push operations occur
new items will be added on top of the
list pop operations will manipulate that
same end so let's create our stack we
are going to create a stack class called
stack top n
it will have an initializer which will
basically initialize some
a list called items now once we've done
that we're going to
so this is basically the str function um
don't worry about this let's look at
these functions which we are
concerned about in this particular
example
so we have a um
after we defined our str function which
is basically what is going to do is it's
going to print the contents of the stack
that we have when we invoke the print
function for a particular class object
now the custom functions sorry the
custom methods that we have created are
is empty push pop peak
size and display all items they are very
similar to the predefined push pop peak
functions etc so what these will do is
the first function is empties as the
name suggests it's going to check
whether
the list call items is it empty or not
if it is
it will return true otherwise it will
return false based on this check the
push function it's going to append an
item
whatever we pass to the list items the
pop function on the other hand is going
to do the pop operation as we have
already seen the peak function what it's
going to do is um if you see here it's
going to give us the item
in the
last most index so if if a length of a
list is 10
then its last index is 9 since python is
0 based indexing right and if we want
that last index we can just do length of
that particular list minus 1 and then we
can use that as an index for our list so
this is basically what's happening here
um we're going to check for the uh last
item in the
list called items so yeah penultimately
we have another method called size this
what this will do is basically return
the length of our object of our list of
items finally we have the method called
display all items which is going to
return the list itself so let's
initialize the stack we call it s
as you can see here let's execute this
first now we initialize we call it s
now we print s
what it does is well it doesn't see it
doesn't do anything because what the
printf function should do is it should
return us the stack contents which is
nothing right now because there is we
haven't entered and we haven't added
anything to our list so we check if it's
empty
and we see hey it is true it is actually
empty so let's start pushing items into
this list so the first one that we enter
uh that we push into it will be called
will be a string called first then we
push second and then we push third so
let's do this
once we have done this now if we print
the uh this object s it should give us
the stack objects or the stack contents
which is if you see here what i've done
is actually have i've actually pushed
first second and third twice by mistake
so it basically contains a list of first
second third followed by first second
third again again this is not an issue
we can we can work with this as well now
let's look at the most recent item
inserted so since i have entered first
second third followed by first second
third again so this list contains is
basically a list containing these
objects right like first second third
followed by first second third and if i
were to peak now what was the peak
function the peak function looks into
the last most object so the peak
function should look at the object that
i added most recently which was the
string called third so if i print this
it should give me third which it does
over here now if i wanted to view the
stack it's a simple i can iterate
through all of this and print each item
as you can see since i have added uh it
twice by mistake uh what i'm going to do
or what it's going to do is it's going
to give me everything as you can see
here so it it basically what this means
is my stack contains the objects first
second third first second third
similarly i can also use the display all
items to to do the same thing to show
the same thing
as you can see here
now i can add a boolean so what this
what this push will do is it will add a
boolean object called true so
if i push this to it now this stack
contains a boolean object called true as
the last object so let's see um let's
let's uh so if i wanted to see what s
contains now what i can do is
i can do display all items
and check let's see what is there now so
if you see i have my objects here but
now since i added a true object you can
see that over here as well a boolean
object called true now let's print size
of stack so we use the size function
it should be seven as you can see here
um now let's let's push another object
so this object is a float object called
8.4 and once i pushed it and if i want
to display everything
as you can see now i have finally
another object called 8.4 in this
so if i were to pop now what will it pop
it will pop the recent most added which
was the float called 8.4
and if i did that as you can see i
should get 8.4 here finally if i were to
display whatever is left here it should
display everything
except the 8.4 which which i have popped
earlier on as you can see so in this in
this other implementation what i am
going to treat
uh the top as is the beginning of the
list so the zeroth element is going to
be my new top now for the stack so let's
look at uh how things change because of
this
so again i have initialized a list an
empty list and i'm going to have
something an is empty function to check
if the list is empty i have a push which
will basically now not insert objects
from the last it will not append objects
anymore but instead what i'm going to do
is i'm going to insert objects to the
zeroth index of the list item and when i
do pop we won't remove the item in the
last index but it will remove the item
at the zero with index
similarly peak function will also do the
same thing it will look at the
list from the left hand side so look at
the most the zeroth index object
so that's the peak and then the size is
the same thing it's going to return the
length of the list and display all items
we'll do the same thing once again so
now i have um once i have
created this let's create an
implementation called stop zero now is
stop zero initially empty it should be
true um let's push first second and
third now
once i push these let's look at what was
the most recent item that was inserted
which should be third right let's view
this uh stack like how does it look
so if you see here if i print them one
by one it prints third second and first
so even though i've added for second and
third in this order the items in which i
retrieve it is third second and first
and that is because of how i define the
stack where the top of the stack is
actually the zeroth index so if i just
do
if i did display all items it should
give me a list with third second and
first in that order so if i execute this
you can see this over here
so
again if i did uh just to see again my
peak will basically give me third now
using these concepts that we have
learned let's perform an exercise um
this exercise is going to be where we
are going to write a function where
we're going to reverse the characters in
a string so let's look at how we're
going to implement this so if you
remember this class stack top n uh from
this from this earlier earlier case over
here we're going to use this class to
create a
an instance of that class so what we're
going to do is we're going to call it my
stack and our input string that we're
going to use is called bangalore we're
going to reverse the characters of
bangalore so what we're going to do is
first of all we're going to
push each string
each character of the string into the
stack object using the push function and
then let's see uh what our
object looks like
so as you can see we have pushed each
character of bangalore into a list and
uh we've stored it right now for now so
let's initialize a uh an empty list and
an empty string
now what we're going to do out here is
basically the reversing operation
so as long as my
initial list which is called my stack
this object as long as this object is
not empty what we're going to do is the
pop operation and we're going to keep
the adding we're going to append each
item that we get from the power
population
and add it to our empty string so we're
basically going to create a new string
with letters that we pop from
this particular list which is basically
what is going to do is it's going to pop
e then r and then o and we're going to
add it uh one by one in that order to
and create a new list a new string out
of it so this is how we're going to do a
reversing string operation so
once we execute this and we're going to
print what is the reverse string is so
if you see here
the reverse string in the form of a list
is like this and if the
the string the string form of the
reverse string is as you can see here
which is basically bangalore reversed as
always i thank you for watching this
video i hope you learned something about
the stack
the the abstract data structure in
python and how we implemented it using
basic python lists dqs and an
object-oriented approach to the same
and that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on python programming
full course i hope you liked it thank
you for watching stay safe and keep
learning
you